this is a warning order we have some
military folks in the in the uh in
attendance today they understand about
uh uh three minutes to go so anyway we
will start on time at at
09:30 uh and we'll start a little bit
before that with the pledge so just a a
quick heads up uh we're going to get
going in just a couple couple minutes
here
thanks
how many titles has a Minnesota won in
the
last
to lead us in that so if you could uh
please stand at this
time
uned States
americe okay we do have a fairly
ambitious schedule today uh some very
interesting measures looking forward to
all of them thank you for coming anybody
who has taken the time to come here and
would like to speak we'll make time for
you uh depending upon the volume of uh
prospective speakers sometimes
we're required by circumstances to limit
testimony uh don't like to do that but
uh if we have uh many many many people
want to speak we want to honor their
presence and if we need to we will uh
limit uh testimony times we're not at at
this time because I don't see a need for
it at at this moment
um yes so uh and Madame clerk is helping
with the pink cards if you do wish to
speak uh you can just fill out a pin
card pass it up most folks are looking
for two or three minutes which is great
I will say that and I'll repeat this
later in the day at other hearings um
the committee is very interested that's
why we're here is to is to learn more
about these measures now if someone has
explained a piece of the measure a piece
of the bill or the resolution already uh
you don't need to repeat that okay so uh
we don't need to hear the same um Point
uh multiple times over so I would ask
that if a point that you think is
important has already been made uh we
have that it's also on YouTube so we
don't need to to repeat that so at this
time let's get started uh with the first
measure of this ambitious schedule that
is CAC
R20 the prime sponsor for that is
representative geard and he is in the
house uh representative Gard welcome and
uh here we
go thank you chairman members of the
committee Jason Gard Northfield Franklin
marac
25 the measure before us today cacr 20
would
declare independence from the United
States of America for New Hampshire if
the national debt reaches $40
trillion we would proceed as a Sovereign
Nation the reason for bringing this
measure forward is because I like many
Americans right now feel that the
national government is taking this whole
country on a course
that quite simply is leading us to
financial insolvency at a rapid
Pace online you know we have many of
these debt clocks and we're already over
40 34 trillion when we hit 40 trillion
I'm not sure but it's going to happen
sooner rather than
later and I'm concerned that as many
have said the national debt is the
greatest National Security risk that we
face so this is a measure to prevent New
Hampshire from falling
[Music]
into a catastrophe that I don't think
the world has seen before since we do
have the reserve currency and they are
printing it like it's going out of style
so just a little fact sheet that you'll
find on your tables that was
provided this legislation to State what
this actually does this legislation
proposes an amendment following article
seven of the New Hampshire Constitution
that if the US national debt reaches 40
trillion New Hampshire shall peacefully
declare peacefully I'm sorry declare
independence from the United States this
legislation will be submitted and placed
on a ballot for qualified voters at the
general state election November 2024 the
wording of the question put to the
qualifi voter shall be placed in a yes
or no answer context if the proposed
amendment is approved by 2third of those
voting on the amendment it becomes
effective when the governor proclaims
its
adoption with the current national debt
of 34 trillion and its projection to
rise I mean it can't go anywhere but up
at this point this legislation addresses
concerns about future Financial
standings and relationship between state
and federal governments this legislation
does not call for New Hampshire's
immediate secession from the United
States
prompt a vote on New Hampshire
Independence in the general state
election in November 2024 or change
status of New Hampshire as a state
within the United
States well there's there's plenty of
people who want to testify so I'll kind
of limit my testimony but if there's any
questions I'd be happy to answer them
right now conning why this was put
forward but in general my feeling is
that this country is on a course that's
unsustainable and danger to the values
and Liberties that New Hampshire holds
sacred so hence this being brought
forward thank you representative I I do
have one question that I will ask uh of
you uh it's the same question we had a
last term we had a a similar secession
type measure that came to this committee
I was vice chair at the time and I and
I'm going to repeat the same question to
you that I asked the prime sponsor of
that measure that has to do with the the
Pledge of Allegiance which refers to one
nation
indivisible um so I I have to assume and
I'm repeating the question I asked last
time um that you you don't do not
believe in or do not say the Pledge of
Allegiance because it of the
indivisible uh part of the Pledge I
actually don't say the Pledge of
Allegiance because I believe we can only
serve one master and my master is not
government so that's kind of how I feel
about the situation in general I believe
that you should worship the Creator and
not the creation
so that's how I go about it myself
personally thank you and one followup
and this is the same followup I asked
the uh the introducer last term and and
that has to do with some history and
then we all go through the Hall of flags
um into the State House the regimental
colors from the Civil War over 4,000 New
Hampshire men died during the Civil War
countless thousands others injured
wounded uh so the these people these
soldiers who made the ultimate sacrifice
because they believe that this nation as
Lincoln said should be indivi
indivisible so my question is how do you
reconcile this measure with the
sacrifices of these of these men and in
these uh in the hollow flags of
regimental colors some of them are Blood
Stained so if you could just help us
understand how you reconcile that sure I
would this is something I was going to
bring up my testimony but I decided not
to but now I will growing up just this
is going somewhere just follow me second
growing up in I was a freshman when 91
happened in high school and I remember
that the whole thing was about we got to
keep people that we don't know where
they're coming from out of this country
because we got to secure our borders and
etc etc and now we see the border is
completely wide open there is no even
pretense of preventing any so-called
terrorists from entering the country I
just feel
that
the we we the things not the things the
Liberties that those men died for are
not being upheld today including the
actual defense of our borders so this my
point being is that the country that
they died for is not actually in
existence right now all of our
constitutional amendment are being
trampled at every level I think Edward
Snowden kind of proved that pretty
explicitly so we're kind of in this
weird
ersat Nation status where we don't
actually have the Liberties that we're
we supposedly do on paper and that's
what I'm concerned about so those men
died for something yes but the they they
did they die for what we have right now
a federal government that tramples on
every single one of our rights that's
that's my concern those men died yes but
what did they die for did they die for
what we see right now happening a
current that is completely worthless and
increasingly so every day a country
that's involved in Wars all over the
place I think we just started launching
attack on Yemen I saw on Twitter briefly
this morning I can't even keep up I just
so that's what I'm concerned about those
men died for the benefit of the people
that live within this country and their
their posterity and we don't see that I
mean look at conqueror we always
homeless we got roving bands of homeless
people so that's that's what I'm really
concerned about is the actual people who
live in this country and who fight for
this country including the veterans of
which 6,000 commit suicide every
day they're not being supported by the
very government that we we are told we
have to pledge allegiance to they're not
pledging allegiance to us so I'm not
sure if that answers your question I
kind of meandered a little bit but
that's what happens we don't have
prepared mors so thank you we that that
helps and um I think the the suicide
rate is not 6,000 a day I year I'm sorry
I said year that that sounds right okay
that because that's something that this
committee does pay attention to thank
you for that other questions for uh
representative Philo sure thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative in
1869 the Supreme Court in Texas versus
white ruled that attempts at secession
were quote absolutely null and that the
United States is indivisible that
Supreme Court case has never been
overruled given that in what way is the
present measure constitutional under
Texas versus
white well I would first three points to
that one I don't really think nine men
in black dresses has any say on our
Liberty second I believe the Declaration
of Independence holds weight and third
article 10 of the State Constitution and
article 7 State sovereignty but article
10 right to Revolution I don't think
that some federal bureaucrats could
determine that our state constitution is
null and void of which article 7 and 10
I would reference you to
primarily uh represent
finny thank you f a question um your
belief um you know you would believe
Congress is too far gone but if we if we
could have had an article 5 convention
to propose an amendment to Reign and
fiscal spending could we could we you
know
maybe you know you know
um put more of the defenses the
Constitution against the federal
government than just you know saying
that we're going to leave the union and
then that's
it I don't believe at this time that's
actually possible the corruption has
reached such a level it's actually hard
to Fathom the numbers are so huge so for
instance on September 10th 2001 A lot of
people don't realize Donald Rumsfeld our
illustrious previous Secretary of
Defense he announced that I believe it
was something in the line of $2.1
trillion was unaccounted for in their
audit and the Pentagon has never
actually passed an audit so me that's
just one example but I do think the
military-industrial complex is a leading
cause of our woses but I think that at
this point there there's just such an
entrenched Bure I don't even know if you
want to call it deep state bureaucracy
whatever you want to call it these
people are so far underground I don't
think it's possible to to pull them up
like turn-ups I think we just have to
kind of walk away and say Hey you have
obviously some issues with accounting
and basic math and we have some issues
with funding an Empire at this point so
we got to kind of we need to take care
of people in this state that's what we
need to do that's our primary concern as
legislators I that's Lisa that's what I
was under the impression of
so I guess that's my answer to
that other questions for the prime
sponsor rep representative
Gagney thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my
question the sake of argument suppose
this um H cacr would pass the people
would vote it in by
2third so we would separate from the
rest of this
country it takes money to be independent
to be your own country so how if this
thing passes would we support ourselves
we have an 18-mile Coastline we would
have to have raise an army for all our
borders Etc and Etc and Etc so what is
your plan for
that my plan is that I'm a carpenter I
hit nails with a hammer I am not one to
speak on larger issues as far as how we
would organize ourselves but I believe
that within this state we have a lot of
intelligent people who could figure that
out and quite frankly I mean if you want
a personal example I would say that as
far as money goes we have to actually
start getting back to real money so this
is a project where they found a way to
print gold on the plastic so it's a
thousands of an ounce it's worth $4 but
the point being is we need to kind of go
back to reality and the fact of the
matter is the dollars that they're
printing are completely worthless and
the only reason anybody accepts them is
because it's the Petro dollar that oil
is purchased in dollars that's the only
reason it's any worth does that make any
sense so we it's not a matter of money
we have plenty of wealth we simply need
to separate ourselves from the um well
the extortion racket that is the IRS and
keeping our money here I believe we
could entirely support ourselves oh one
last thing I wanted to mention just it's
ties in Texas is putting secession on
their Republican primary ballot this
year and I forget the percentages but
it's we somebody else will definitely
mention this so this is not just a New
Hampshire thing where we're going to
have to support ourselves on maple syrup
sales there is a movement throughout the
country to regulate and bring back the
Federal Government under the chains of
the Constitution as the founders termed
it other questions
followup thank you Mr chairman so if I
hear you right you're thinking that
perhaps we have a revolution possible
Revolution on the horizon uh would my
assessment be correct on that or or
not I would say that we're already in
the early stages of Revolution with a
major Invasion occurring daily but on
top of that we have article 10 and state
constitution the right to Revolution so
I would say that the indiv the men who
created our constitution fora a time
when the people of New Hampshire may
have to peacefully remove themselves
from an entity that was trying to
tyrannize
them other
questions seeing none for the prime
sponsor thank you representative thank
you very much representative Granger has
uh submitted a card he opposes the bill
he's asked for two minutes uh
representative
Granger
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Michael Granger I'm
here representing straford District 2
Glenn Bailey back there he's in the same
district as me and uh that's Rochester
Ward 5 Milton and Milton Mills and it's
been said that a bill is just a
conversation until it actually gets
signed so I hopefully my contribution to
this Con uh conversation will be useful
and help hopefully convince anyone who
supports the session that it is not
exactly the Panacea they think it is um
representative Gard mentioned that we
need to get back to reality I am a
strong believer that you must deal with
reality on reality's terms in fact I
consider it the Bedrock of Sanity if you
do not deal with reality on reality's
terms then you're not dealing you're
you're not going to be doing very well
in anything you attempt to do in life so
in in pursuit of reality I'd like to
point out that the United States is a
Democratic Republic whether people want
it to be a Democratic Republic whether
they have principles that are above and
beyond a Democratic Republic it just is
what it is it currently is a Democratic
Republic the Democracy part is where we
vote for Representatives uh so all of us
were elected by Democratic means the
Republic part is where we're cons we're
supposedly constrained by Constitution
we try we we don't stick to it very well
um but that's it's supposed to be
constrained um democracy is such an old
idea that people often forget why it was
invented in the first place back in
Athens because Athens is remembered for
two things inv ing democracy and
democratically voting to have Socrates
kill himself that's what it was there
for and it wasn't until the Republic was
introduced to the mix that a little bit
more sanity was sort of introduced to to
the governance scenario from democracy
but what democracy really was supposed
to solve the problem that it was
supposed to solve was that you had these
Empires and these great personalities
that were constantly battling over who
gets to tell everyone what to do who
gets to rule and they noticed something
Whoever has the bigger armor Army
has a tendency to win so they thought
well why don't we just skip the whole
War part and just count how many
soldiers you have we count how many
soldiers we have and then we agreed from
there and democracy was born uh it isn't
always a perfect representation of who
would actually win the battle uh but
it's generally a pretty good pretty good
litmus so this let's go to why having a
secession happen at the state level is a
bad idea all right let's assume 100 % of
New Hampshire residents vote in favor of
secession the United States population
is over 300 million the population of
New Hampshire is a little less than 1.5
million therefore the Dem Democratic
process if we have it in New Hampshire
is not a proxy for the war it's only a
proxy for war if all the people on the
battlefield are voting and if they're
not voting then it's it's not going to
represent what would actually end up
happening therefore we'd lose and I you
guys have heard me speak on defending
guard in the past I'm a very very
anti-war person I don't want to deal
with a war especially in my backyard I
also don't want to deal with having to
go through a DHS checkpoint every time I
go to church because my church is in
Maine it's across a bridge I live on the
Sam falls River I cross the cross the
river and then I can go to church I
don't want to go through a DHS
checkpoint I don't like go I don't even
like flying airplanes because I don't
want to ride on with the T I don't want
to deal with the TSA so as I I agree
with a lot of the principles of the
people who are supporting secession um
on the point of the con uh the
Constitution the founding of the United
States is through the Declaration of
Independence we can appeal directly to
the people if we disagree with the
Supreme Court's interpretation of the
Constitution but I don't think we really
should in this case because I don't
think that that's a really good idea um
ultimately as much as I agree with a lot
of the principles and ideals of the
secessionists it just doesn't make any
sense thank you thank you representative
uh will you take questions if there are
any sure are there any questions uh
representative finny I just have one
thank you um how do you think that we
should deal with not just at New
Hampshire but as a country with the
issue of our debt it is our biggest you
know security issue but overall like it
will collapse eventually we will go
through the worst Economic Times in in
history how do we how do we like I'm
either prepare for that or deal with the
reality of that impending doom I guess
so uh I actually have testimony that I
prepared in this room but for a
completely different committee um for
another bill I am going to be speaking
on two different gold bills this year um
one of them was a bill to create a state
depository and have some sort of goldb
currency which is authorized in the
Constitution uh explicitly by uh saying
that states can actually me their own
gold money and all that jazz which is an
interesting concept and then I also have
one in my own committee which is in the
labor committee um to allow gold and
silver for the payment of wages and I
believe that when it comes to the
reserve currency status that the United
States has uh we have a we have to look
at history on this a typical World
Reserve currency lasts 80 to 110 years
that has been a pattern that has emerged
since the 1400s every Reserve currency
since the 1400s has lasted between 80
and 110 years we're due um now on the
other one thing you got to realize is
currency collapses of world Reserve
currencies happen fairly regularly the
last time it happened was uh the British
pound sterling and in World War II that
was the final death Nowell it was
already not doing very well since World
War I but when uh the when the pound
sterling eventually really did die it
wasc it was in 1944 and they had to
start backing their currency instead of
in Gold because they didn't have any
gold anymore they started backing their
currency in dollars and that's how
America became the world Reserve
currency in the first place now it takes
I believe that the actual mechanism
whereby the a a world Reserve currency
dies is that it takes a certain amount
of time for the generation that made
that currency great to to die due to
their own natural causes and for us to
have a generation in charge of that
currency that doesn't understand the
fundamentals and I believe we're at that
point and I don't believe secession is
the cure because it's not like if the
dollar dies we're going to you know have
if we suceed we're better it we we need
to have a better look at the actual
fundamentals and we need to prepare for
the shock that is going to come when the
dollar
dies other
questions seeing none thank you
representative Granger thank you very
much I hear you about TSA I've signed up
for pre-screening I'd recommend you
taking a look at that as
well uh okay uh Pam Ian is in the house
uh a friend from conquered uh Pam has
submitted by the way uh thank you for
the written
testimony um that's always appreciated
and we also have uh online submissions
for testimony and also to uh weigh in on
whether you support or don't support a
measure Pam's asked for up to five
minutes without read uh we we can read
uh and I look forward to I've already
looked at some of this um so if you can
summarize uh in the best way uh Pam the
wonderful written testimony that we have
in front of us and we will we will press
on okay thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm not going
to read that document to you guys I did
submit it because uh I was told that you
would rather hear about personal things
how the federal government has come down
on me for certain things but being a
constitutionalist I couldn't resist not
pointing out where the government over
the years since the 20th century has
violated that Constitution and it's I
know I know some of you probably don't
like this um amendment that that it was
put forth but I really hope that you'll
read what I have to say excuse me
because uh these are things that have
happened over the year and it's almost
like the proverbial frog in the lukewarm
water you you slowly heat it up and
after a while the frog is going to die
and I think that's what's happened to us
is that over the years these things have
happened and not enough people have come
forward and said hey you can't do that
or the Supreme Court has ruled
erroneously and we've seen this many
times where the Supreme Court decisions
were wrong but anyway um my name is
Pamela Ian I'm a resident of conquered
and I strongly support this referendum
this is something that needs to be on
the table we have to let the federal
government know that it has gone too far
and has overstepped its bounds in many
areas and if you see once you read my
document you'll see that many of these
things happened years ago I'm not even
talking about things that have happened
since Obama or um Trump was in in
office I provided each of you with a
handout that explains how the government
has violated the Constitution over the
years the Constitution is the compact
between the people and the government
and when that document is violated
government has become arbitrary and
that's not what our Founders wanted for
us so now I'll tell you about the
personal
story I was a a public school teacher
for about 23 years in this state and
after about 10 years the teachers union
informed me that they would start
charging me an agency fee and which came
out to about
$400 even though I was not a member of
the
Union authorization for this came from
federal collective bargaining rules and
a Supreme Court decision in
1977 Abu versus the Detroit Board of
Education which allowed public employees
to require I mean public employers to
require non-union members in Union
represented bargaining un units to pay
an agency fee also known as fair
share I fought against this and I did
win on religious
grounds instead of my $400 going to the
union I could give it to a charity and
that was what I was told I had to do so
I chose St Vincent to Paul I'm religious
I go to church St Vincent to Paul is
something that my Parish uh participates
in now St Vincent to Paul is an
organization that feeds the poor and
those on the edge of
poverty I was told by the union lawyer
that this was unconstitutional for me to
give my money to a religious
organization now I hope you see the
absurdity in that I won on the grounds
of being a religious person and yet I
was told oh you can't give your money to
a religious
organization he said it was
unconstitutional it's not if once you
read my document you'll see um what the
founders meant by the First Amendment
freedom of
religion
okay so once the Janice decision came
along in
2018 um it became a moot point anyone
who belonged to a public Union was no
longer required to pay this agency fee
however there's still private
organizations uh unions that are taking
money from people and what I find
strange about that is when I did um
testify in favor of right to work one of
the um State reps asked me said well uh
you have you are covered by the Union by
law by federal law if something happened
if I did something wrong they would
support me and I said well first of all
I think that's absurd because I'm not a
union member so there's the first wrong
then the second wrong is that they could
take my money even though I was not part
of the Union so as you can see this this
is absurd you know one two wrongs don't
make a
right now in conclusion it's imperative
to understand that by supporting CAC R20
you are not saying that you support
independence from the United States but
rather that you are giving the voters
the right to decide if it's something
that they would support or
not please remember that this bill is
not about Trump or Biden in fact all of
the things that I pointed out in here
happened before they were president in
fact some of them happened before they
were even born and this is not a
Republican versus Democrat thing anyway
we're all Americans and all of our
freedoms are being um taken away by the
federal
government and the fact that our
Founders vision of peace prosperity and
freedom have come under under attack
should influence all of us and should
get up our our anger about it because
we're losing what our Founders had in
mind for us thank
you thank you Pam and thank you for the
written testimony much appreciated if
there are no pressing questions we will
press on uh thank you again uh I'm
looking next at Carla gki who I
recognize a fren she asked for three
plus minutes uh Carla
welcome thank you honorable chair and
the committee uh thanks for having me
here my name is Carla Garrick I'm the
the chairwoman and president emiritus of
the free state project a movement that
is concentrating tens of thousands of
Liberty lovers in the state of New
Hampshire I'm a naturalized US citizen
I'm originally from South Africa and I'm
an author activist and attorney I was
the Republican nominee for the New
Hampshire Senate in District 20 and I
received 46% of the vote in 2020 as an
open secessionist and in 2022 I ran for
the New Hampshire state house in Ward 11
in Manchester where I live and I lost by
about 200 votes I'm pointing that out
just to let you guys know this idea
might be a little more popular than you
assume I'm a proud Granite stator
because I chose New Hampshire as my
forever home about 15 years ago when I
moved here and I moved here for the Live
Free or Die ethos that we all love and
respect I'm testifying today in support
of cacr 20 which is similar to last
year's CAC
cr32 that was the original Independence
bill that we put fourth and we tried to
listen to the feedback we heard back and
that is the reason we brought this bill
back with a qualifying event what is
that qualifying event it is saying if
our national debt becomes 40 trillion
dollar then maybe we need to do
something about it now I wants us to
stand still with the number of trillions
because I'm not sure if anyone even
fully grasp and understands what is
going on economically and the way I
would like to explain it is by
explaining numbers through time so a
million seconds is 11 and a half days a
billion seconds is 32 days and a
trillion seconds is
31,000
years so again when the jump went from
billions to trillions and we all just
kind of rolled with that we have to
realize when we are talking about the
debt and we are talking about trillions
of dollars this is not surmountable we
have to do something the federal
government has am I too loud was that
what you were saying oh sorry
Larry I can't hear from here sorry uh
the federal government has failed us it
no longer follows the Constitution it
ushers in unconstitutional Wars
Undeclared Wars it ushers in inflation
it's devalued our money by almost
100% if you feel like you're getting
poorer you are if you feel like you
cannot get ahead and life anymore and
you know all of us here maybe on the
older side but talk to the young people
and realize we have to do
something um we are getting poorer and
the fault lies squarely with a federal
government's monetary policies I would
also like to point out we all lived
through covid Mania and if anyone thinks
what happened over the past three years
is an acceptable way for us to be
governed then I think we should look at
that as well Granite Staters are frankly
we're being abused by the federal
government and what do we advise people
when they are being abused to do we say
leave your
abuser the last time I spoke on this
issue here I talked a little bit about
National divorce since then that's
actually a topic that is starting to
come up you see it trending you see
Congress people talking about it um I
want you to understand the people who
support National divorce do not support
Civil War because the thing that you're
are now seeing trend is people are
talking about National divorce and then
the next thing you see is people are
talking about war in the same way the
question immediately came up we do not
support violence in fact we are here
today and we continue to work on this
issue because violence is the tool of
tyrants it is the tool of authoritarians
and it's the tool of control freaks in
other words it's the tool of the federal
government and bad people who support
killing other people because you
disagree with us instead of telling us
you'll punch Us in the face or leave us
to rot in a basement when we try to
leave we should start to have this open
and honest conversation about what
actually needs to take place we have the
right to ask for a
divorce this is all today's proposed
Bill does it says it gives us Granite
Staters the Democratic opportunity to
decide if we want to stay with the
sinking ship of the federal government
and its $40 trillion of federal debt or
if we can do better as Granite
Staters I believe we can do better on
our own um so abusers will tell you
you're not allowed to leave they'll tell
you hey we'll change maybe like if you
put in some bills and whistles we'll
start to listen to the Constitution they
might even tell you it's your fault but
we all know the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and gain it is insane for us to continue
to trust our government it's creating
debt imagine if you ran your household
the way they're running the government I
mean it's
absurd as our elected officials it's
your duty to create the opport
opportunity for granite Staters to make
this decision for themselves you guys
don't really have the right to be the
gatekeeper on this all you should do is
say I don't know maybe we should leave
it up to the voters of New Hampshire um
and let us decide our own destiny we
have the right enshrined in the New
Hampshire Constitution as has been
mentioned here both article 7 and
article 10 to make those decisions and
again clearly we're not here because we
want to revolt even though that right
exists we are here because we're trying
to solve a problem before it gets worse
today your duty is to support democracy
if you've tweeted the word democracy
ever if you've written about it if
you've mentioned it then this is your
Democratic duty is to put the question
to the voters of the Granite State we're
called To Live Free or Die State when we
become independent we will be the live
free and Thrive State and the the
questions that we have about what it
would look like how it would work we're
trying to address that too HB 1130 which
is coming up later as a study committee
to start to talk about those questions
but I advise everyone let's not think in
a limited boxed way let's think with a
growth mindset and let's not have
limiting beliefs I can assure you that
if New Hampshire was independent we'd be
a cool little country and we could make
it work I'm happy to take any questions
are there any questions at this
time uh represent
Mela thank you for taking my question um
would you be in favor of an article 5
convention which could address the
national
de I mean yes I'm actually in favor of
anything where we're all talking and
we're actually trying to come up with
Solutions so I'm not against that
sure other
questions
uh thank you Klo for that passionate
testimony U apparently loud as well
sorry I have trouble hearing sometimes
but I could hear you and I appreciate
that uh Matt Scher
Matt
welcome mat Matt's asked for up to three
minutes hey uh good morning chairman
Moffett and members of the committee my
name is Matt saborn D schaner I'm the
chairman of the New Hampshire
Independence political action committee
we support legislators and help draft
legislation related to the idea of new
as an independent country for the past 2
years in a row the St Amel poll has
registered the federal government
receiving a 75% disapproval rating in
New Hampshire and we'll see what this
Spring's poll will say we share the same
feelings of dissatisfaction and
uncertainty that many Grand Staters feel
regarding the future of the United
States for Grant Staters who have lost
confidence in DC we are proposing
another option we advocate for peaceful
secession in the form of this year's CAC
R20 with a qualifier of 40 trillion in
debt if we hit it uh the current federal
debt GDP ratio is
12229 and we believe New Hampshire can
do better than this while there's no
stand standard international legal
precedence for whether a seceding state
is required to accept its portion of the
federal debt when departing from its
parent State uh it would be smart to
plan for a course of action that
anticipates accepting our portion of the
national debt uh in the apportionment of
public debt and assets during state
seccession by academic Daniel Blum
published in case Western Reserve
Journal of international law provides
theories how debt could be shared
if we were to use New Hampshire's per
capita allocation which is around
170,000 per per citizen or its
percentage of the national of the total
GDP which is
43% as a measuring stick to determining
H's portion it comes to an upper limit
of $172 billion I know Carla was talking
about time
earlier uh if we were to pay if you were
to allocate the total tax burden that
was paid to the federal government in
2022 uh made that an annual payment to
the any debt that we ac acred following
secession it could be paid off in just
over a decade it's just a thought uh
2024 is not the first time Americans
living in New England explored leaving
the Union New Hampshire or New England
states considered seceding in 1803 over
disputes with the Louisiana Purchase and
1814 over disputes with the War of 1812
in 1842 former president of the United
States John Quincy Adams brought a
petition signed by 46 residents of ha m
Massachusetts advocating for the
dissolution of the Union on the house
floor in US conference on account of the
federal government support of slavery
there is historical precedence for the
deliberations we are bringing forth
today uh this month we do have
politicians touring the state giving us
ideas of the future and what might be
inspiring hope in some however we' seen
this play out year after year the
political situation in the country has
only worsened in my lifetime I do not
anticipate it improving following
peaceful seccession we'd love to have
great relationships with our New England
and Canadian neighbors and even the
United States as well uh we enourage the
members of this committee to vote in
favor of the resolution so that people
in New Hampshire may be given the chance
to express their position on the
matter thank you Matt
U yes the Madame clerk would like you to
believe it or not spell your name for
us yeah well we I I'll do it okay
capital s a b o u r i n space lowercase
dit space Capital CH I I
ER this happened last
year you got that man
CL thank you Matt all right thanks
guys representative Glenn Bailey is
asked for uh a couple minutes uh and
rson Bailey is in the house welcome rson
Bailey thank you Mr chairman and
esteemed committee members
uh I would preface it by saying a few
years ago I attended a a civil case of a
of a land owner versus the one of the
towns it was here in concrete I believe
the
trial and the person was representing
themselves proos say and they expressed
everything in terms of the New Hampshire
Constitution and at every step in like
an hour trial the judge would take
whatever the defendant said or the
plaintiff or whatever and translated
into the US
Constitution you know
everything this is an in a New Hampshire
Court over overseen by a New Hampshire
judge appointed under the New Hampshire
Constitution had little interest in the
New Hampshire Constitution it was all
being translated to the US
Constitution so several years later I
attended the
debates of this prior term this same
issue on the prior term this
and there was a pi that
asked are we a sovereign state or just
the district office of
DC well by what I saw in that courtroom
I'd say we were just the district office
for
DC which you can take that as you
like one of the
speeches said that this was all settled
by the Civil
War as if we were a conquered people or
something I didn't quite get that but uh
most of the people around here fought
against the sueding States you know but
somehow or other we can never think of
that we can never do
that because we're like a conquered
people I I don't believe we
are um we've seen positive examples of
this and the the British pulled out of
the European Union in
brexit I've I've lived through through
several Quebec Independence votes and
Puerto Rico Independence votes and
there's countries around the world that
have successfully and peacefully
withdrawn from their larger
unit um I believe we could do the
same but there's the counterveiling
thing that there's places that are
conquered like if to take this this
representative that was speaking and
said it was settled by the Civil War if
Putin manages to crush Ukraine will we
all regard that as settled it could
never be brought up
again or by the same token if if the
Chinese stomp into Taiwan will we and
success successfully oppress them will
we regard that as
settled I don't believe that this is
settled by the Civil
War we retain the right to pull out if
we want
voluntary um as far as the dollar goes I
mean
usually by this point the international
monetary fund has been called in to
save whatever country is in the fix
we're in of course we're funding most of
that but
uh and I believe I one of the prior
Witnesses said we're at 129% of GDP to
Deb debt to
GDP they usually say that when you reach
when the debt equals GDP you will never
be able to pay it off you're already
done you're doomed it's just a question
of when it
fails but that ratio is impossible to
ever pay off despite what they say and I
don't mean to pick on the current
Administration it's been going on for
years in a bipartisan
way um we're constantly being asked to
this this at the county and the state
and even the town level to take Federal
money as grants well you know they
printed in the basement they have no
money they're $34 trillion in debt that
it's magic you know it's not really
accomplishing
anything uh and just digging I'm I'm old
but the younger people I see around me
we're digging them into debt from which
we will never
recover um so I would be in favor of at
least asking the people around me would
you like to get out of this
mess
peacefully thank you thank you
representative for the well articulated
testimony are there any pressing
questions for the
representative thank you again saying
none we will go on to uh Bonnie Freeman
from Kane is asked for a minute Bonnie
are you in the house uh
Bonnie somebody's moving I'll bet that's
Bonnie welcome Bonnie thank
you um my name is Bonnie Freeman and I
heard somebody else say that you asked
specifically for personal reasons why we
support this bill and I would like to
say that as a kid I was I was a military
brat my dad and my mom met in the in the
Army and my dad was in the military for
the entire time I was a child till I
moved out of the house and every
day watching him get up at 4:00 a.m. in
the morning work all day and I
constantly had to hear him say things
like I just can't get ahead I just I
don't have I don't have the ability to
have savings I just can't get ahead and
he is supposedly serving our country
people think that some people who' have
no idea think that military members make
like a whole bunch of money and they
really
don't and um my mom had to take care of
the kids and there were seven of us well
I then graduated high school and I
wasn't a rich person I didn't go to
college I just started working and I
found myself talking exactly like my dad
did my whole life I just can't catch a
break I can't get ahead how is it
possible that this cost this much and
how's it possible I don't have any money
left to put in savings well when I found
out what inflation was that the
government had created this
invisible hidden tax that was stealing
the purchasing power of my money I was
so mad and I didn't even know what I
could possibly do about it I lived in
Utah at the time and I thought well I'll
I'll move to Texas cuz I'm pretty sure
that's the freest State and while I was
there the government closed down
everything entertaining in your life or
anything that made your life purposeful
and I had to walk past cops to go into
Walmart and stuff during covid well my
point is I I heard about New Hampshire
being much Freer came up here and
there's a large group of people who
really care about personal freedoms here
and I am happy to be a part of that
movement well I think that New Hampshire
shouldn't be a part of the federal
government because it's part of what has
done all this terrible stuff to everyone
I know who's a hardworking
person um stealing since Co began 50% of
our purchasing power the dollar still
looks the same but the dollar buys 50%
less of what it did since Co started
because the federal government printed
that much money and it's just not fair
um the federal government also rated but
Bonnie thank you the comments you just
made on the on the money and the
currency we we've heard before and and
you did ask for a minute we have four
more cards and we uh want to give
everybody a shot at speaking to this and
so if you could uh conclude your
comments uh which we really appreciate
um but we want to give the other folks a
chance too before we finish up so so
continue okay well all I was going to
say was the Federal Government also raid
my house and I don't appreciate them um
holding guns at at my face while I'm
naked and forc me to put my dog in some
a pile of glass and put a um boots on
that had glass filled in them and tried
to make me go outside naked in 10 degree
weather and all because my boyfriend
didn't fill out a piece of paper and if
you want to learn more about that so
cryptos
6.com it's absolutely ridiculous that
everybody in Keen New Hampshire voted
against having these bear cats in the
federal government said this guy didn't
fill out a paperwork before selling
Bitcoin so we're going to go do that to
the their house with Bearcats I don't
like them I don't want to live under
their rule thank you bunny uh could you
repeat the uh dotc com that you said
before the what did you say the you
mentioned a website or something could
you repeat that slower for those that
are watching at home yeah it's the
crypto as in
cryptocurrency 6 the number
6.com
thank you for
that uh okay we're going to move along
uh we have four more cards here
appreciate people coming in and again as
I said to to Bonnie uh if some of these
points have been uh made already uh you
don't need to repeat them okay looking
for one minute uh is uh Russell from
Winchester Russell canning
Russell is in the house welcome
Russell
so I'll keep it short too uh hopefully
nobody's brought this up um I of course
also have a problem my friend got thrown
in jail the feds weren't involved he
wouldn't be in jail Ian
Freeman uh as a Christian I'm not
supposed to kill my
enemies I'm supposed to love my enemies
I don't even come close to that but I
try not to kill them the federal
government kills people
they kill people in Afghanistan they
kill people in Syria they fund people
that kill people no matter who we send
as representatives from New Hampshire to
Washington DC they will continue killing
people even if we sent the Most
Wonderful House of Representatives guys
and Senators they can just be outvoted I
want us to leave so we can stop being at
War
thanks thank you Russell
okay we have three more cards here we're
going to go
to uh Christopher
Wade from also from Kee good contingent
from ke today is Christopher here
Christopher is here Christopher's asked
for for a couple of minutes three
minutes welcome
Christopher thank you um so my name is
Christopher Wade I am from
Kean all right
so
New Hampshire declared independence from
the British Empire and that was also
illegal I want to point out New
Hampshire LED Independence for the
Americas in fact and it can do it again
if you recognize the United States or
New Hampshire's prior declaration from
Great Britain you must accept it would
be hypocritical to not also recognize
our right to declare it again against
the American
Empire there is a difference between
what is moral and right and what the law
says we should do what is moral and
right not blindly do what the law says
our veterans didn't fight our veterans
didn't fight to maintain a nation but
they did fight for liberty and freedom
fear of war is a poor reason not to
declare independence New Hampshire is
not the one who would be declaring war
and this would not make sense after all
we're very small population we may be
invaded over our Declaration of
Independence and it might make sense to
fight back back but that is a poor
reason to not declare
independence there's also a possibility
a war with New Hampshire doesn't unfold
at all it's a very
unpopular uh on right right now it's a
very
unpopular uh to go to
war with any state that would break away
that's according to surveys the most
recent surveys
done um in regards to States declaring
independence from the United States so
basically any any president that were to
declare war on New Hampshire if it were
to declare independence would would be
very very unpopular and most of the
population of the United States would be
against it the question is why
Independence though it no longer serves
our interests of our population to
continue in a union with the United
States besides the obvious Wars and
other bad decisions I want to talk about
one reason we should go our own way the
US Supreme Court in South Dakota versus
Wayfair ruled that New Hampshire
businesses have to collect sales tax on
behalf of other states we don't even
have toare uh collect sales tax for our
own State why should we have to declare
or collect sales tax for other states
this isn't the case for Canadian
businesses putting us at a
disadvantage the highest law of the land
applies to States not other
countries this is one good reason to
declare
independence there are over 10,000
taxing jurisdictions and each has its
own set of tax laws it's fiscally in
feasible and costly to figure out the
taxes for each order a company ships
that's what Wayfair did there is not a
single business in compliance with this
ruling there are wrongly collected
amounts because unlike a single business
in a single location complying with a
single set of tax laws the tax laws you
must comply with as a
business are dependent on the receiver's
location not even Europe has a tax
system that's insane
we can't fix this and other bad
decisions without exiting the union this
is just one of thousands of bad laws the
Supreme and Supreme Court rulings we
can't fix without declaring
independence New Hampshire isn't
declaring war on the United States it's
declaring independence from a union that
no longer represents our interests
another example of why New Hampshire is
poorer than it should be is hidden
Federal taxation besides property taxes
federal income taxes and other federal
taxes you see removed from your paycheck
or on your pay stub it there's also
other taxes like tariffs for example I
paid 25% tariff to receive some 4G USB
modems for my business that we sell um
and as an a rough estimate of what
that's taking out of your paycheck or
out of your income that's about 133% if
you're talking about Goods across
there's not tariffs on every good but
that's about 13% if you look at uh all
of Walmart all the goods in Walmart it's
about 13% they're basically the federal
government's getting from you and in a
form of tax a hidden tax um and those
are called
tariffs um some estimates put the amount
stolen by government through these means
and other regulations at
90% so think about that almost double
your income no matter what we lose from
federal bribes they can be made up
through local means whether it's taxes
or other other systems of uh fundraising
okay CH we we've heard a lot of the
numbers material before and I know
you're reading some some testimony and
we're running a little behind you're a
little bit over so I I'm done so oh okay
uh that that was that was a good finish
are there any pressing questions for for
Christopher came all the way here from
ke thank you for that compelling
testimony much appreciated Christopher
we have two more cards here uh as we're
going to finish up uh akmed esah
esfahani uh he'll tell me if I said that
correctly if you see her from
alad if and if you could state your name
for the clerk and your writing is uh is
very good that's what she really
appreciates thank you uh yes my name is
uh akmad
esfahani um I live in alad I'm also
employed by the town of Alstead I'm the
administrator to the zoning board and
planning board uh I'm employed by the
town of Walpole and the recording
secretary and I also serve as secretary
for the Fall Mountain Regional School
District budget committee um the first
thing I wanted to talk about was an
article that was published in 2007 in
the Journal of Homeland Security and
Emergency
Management the title of this article was
Homeland Security and community policing
competing or complimenting Public Safety
policies this article was co-authored by
two different people the first was Dr
Robert freedan Dr Robert Freedman is the
founding director of the Georgia
international law enforcement exchange
this program has police Chiefs and
assistant Chiefs and high ranking
officers throughout the nation spend
time in Israel uh working with their
police force and to summarize they
essentially learn how to police in a
system of apartheid a Us and Them type
of
society the other author was a man named
William Jordan Cannon which was my name
before I changed it I have the document
of my name change if you need to see
that Dr fredman was my mentor and um I
learned a lot from him and I'll
summarize the article that I'm
mentioning on one
hand Homeland Security and the Patriot
Act created a system where there was an
Us and Them society as far as policing
and Public Safety goes this is the
opposite of what community community
policing does community policing engages
the community it works within it does
not see criminals or people who are you
know engaging in any type of behavior as
the
other what I believe that the people
here who are in support of secession
which I agree with many of their
sentiments um all the statements about
the present state of the federal
government I'm in agreement with but I
think that their thoughts of secession
is similar to grasping at a phantom limb
because there is an idea of America that
I think we all have that is no longer in
practice now whether This was um negated
by the Patriot Act or if it was negated
by the recent covid legislation I don't
know
but with the
covid legislation and all the things
that happened there we ended up with a
society again of two different masked
people unmasked people vaccinated people
unvaccinated people and as we all can
probably agree upon A House Divided A
House Divided cannot stand and that's
what I think is going to happen so what
I did after the uh Hearing in 2022 cacr
32 um is I went and visited various uh
select boards up and down the
Connecticut River um and discussed
something that I created called the
Connecticut River 8 project this is not
a revolutionary idea this is not a
secession idea this is something to do
once the collapse happens because most
people are going to go along with
whatever is in place until it no until
it ceases to function at least that is
what I believe
um
the the frustrating thing with being on
a budget committee for a school district
especially with Esser funding I'm not
sure sure if anyone of you familiar with
Federal funding for schools during Co
and now a lot of these positions are
going it's when I'm seeing Federal money
being sent to Ukraine or to Israel or to
wherever and when I see schools lose
teachers it makes me a little bit
frustrated and concerned that the people
in DC do not care about the people of
the United States of America so I don't
think necessarily it is a problem with
America because I I travel all around
this country I actually even work in
Buckland mass as a board's clerk I think
probably the problem is Washington DC
and the all the alphabet organizations
that exist there so what I would ask
everyone here to consider
is that even though secession would be
great and being from Atlanta of course I
can talk about that I think if we look
see what happened the last time session
it was a group of people looking to hold
on to something that was already gone
the American re the uh Confederate
secession was about holding on to
feudalism where we were moving towards
industrialization and technology and I
think what this session is is trying to
hold on to a 20th century America that
does not exist anymore and it saddens me
that that's the case I'll take any
questions if you have
any I there any pressing
questions uh yes so are you in support
or
opposition are you in support or
opposition of this bill or you take no
stance you support this measure correct
I'm I'm neutral to it because I and if I
can explain why the what we're way over
your your minutes
uh and I want to honor the other folks
who've come here and and uh so we'll
bark you down as neutral and thank you
for coming here from Al allad and that
was very uh well organized nice
testimony thank you for that thank you
uh Elliot uh the last card I he is
for Elliot axelman is Elliot
here um and and there he is he's been
here before uh and before ell he's the
last card that I have if there's anyone
else here who thought they put a card
and wanted to speak I want to honor your
time we've gone way over what we planned
on this but uh obviously we care about
what you want to say about this so we'll
finish up here uh Elliot uh if you have
anything anything new that's what we
want to hear is new stuff and you have a
couple minutes sure well lucky for me I
didn't hear any of the previous
testimony but I'll try not to repeat
everything um I only have like 34
trillion reasons why I want to leave the
union so this might not take you too
many more decades to listen to me um
there are so many reasons I think the
the overarching things a lot of people
touched on the inflation the other stuff
the Wars all the violations um just
inflation in of itself is enough reason
to want to leave the union um for me the
biggest things are probably the endless
Wars forcing me so I have to pay taxes I
pay about a quarter third of my income
to federal taxes and that goes to
fighting Wars in 100 180 countries
around the world um bombing people and
as we now know it's it's not even
controversial to say that the federal
government with our taxpayer dollars is
funding both sides of so many wars they
are giving billions to Israel and uh
Gaza the PA or or Iran Hezbollah and uh
Hamas like they're funding both sides
they're funding both sides of other Wars
probably Ukraine probably Russia
probably other sides of uh uh Middle
Eastern count so they're funding both
sides and and uh with our taxpayer
dollars um but the biggest things for me
is we have not had a chance so people in
this room alive today have not had a
chance to vote on whether we want to
stay in this relationship with the DC
politicians in like 250 years so even if
in some Universe in which our ancestors
we had direct lineage to Thomas
Jefferson and George Washington which
most of us don't but even if we had
Direct lineage what we have is our
ancestors 250 years ago so like 25
Generations back um not all of them but
some of them signed onto the
Constitution only like 40 of them but
whatever um but even if all of that
signed the Constitution unanimously all
1 million American col colonists uh that
still couldn't bind all of us to be in a
Perpetual relationship with our
overlords and DC Forever um I my son
over there I could I can't really bind
him to anything I barely have like
guardianship over him but my grandson I
can't bind to anything I can't sign a
contract that any law legal system in
the universe that I know of would be
considered legitimate to bind my son or
grandson or great-grandson to any kind
of contract especially not uh being a
slave to the people in DC Forever um so
if you think of it as as a marriage you
know in the modern era we have uh
unilateral divorce if one party wants to
leave you know it takes two I think um
the Shay said last time you can't just
leave you know it takes two to enter
relationship it takes two to leave
that's you know kind of not really how
the world Works um one it takes two to
enter relationship but one is enough to
leave if you know my wife wants to
divorce me she could do that I can't use
Force so if we want to leave DC uh we
shouldn't need DC's consent to do it um
we can just leave if we're being abused
so I I've written articles everyone on
the committee knows I've written
numerous articles and books and and um
put out a lot of stuff about the reasons
there are hundreds of reasons I have an
article running tally of like 130
reasons why we should succeed um I'm
happy to give a lot of material to the
committee today I wrote a short book
called articles of secession that
answers all the most common questions
I'd love to debate I'd love to have a
study committee as well but I'd love to
put this on the ballot um and one last
thing is it says 35 trillion we're we or
40 trillion we that needs to put up like
45 50 trillion because we're running out
of time by the time we're done with this
bill and we execute in a few days maybe
uh it'll the debt will be past 40
trillion maybe so let's push up to 50
trillion to give us a bit more time but
I think there are so many reasons and
the people should be allowed to vote on
this um we have never had a chance in
250 years to vote on this and there are
so many reasons I could go on literally
Forever Until I Die of old AG so I'll
stop it there I'm happy to take
questions questions for
Elliot Elliott you speak very well uh
and thank you for your testimony and to
your point about submitting stuff uh a
couple couple quick points before we
close this here hearing uh we do look at
what folks send us uh we appreciate the
written testimony uh emails and there's
also a portal where where you can weigh
in um there are a couple members who are
not here this is on YouTube they will
have the opportunity to to go through
everything that happened today uh before
we have an executive session on this uh
at sometime possibly in a week or it or
maybe after that so we will thoroughly
go through again uh the material that uh
we have and that uh I'm sure we will
still come in if there's no one else who
has come at distance and wishes to speak
uh I see there might be one
more uh you can fill up a card later
please have oh you oh in your name
Melissa not here okay Melissa somehow it
uh didn't make it to us but Melissa we
appreciate you taking the time to come
in and uh please take a a couple minutes
if yeah I'll be quick um I didn't
prepare a speech but I'm just going to
speak from my heart um our government
has been
infiltrated um a long time ago and they
are just merely puppets they answer to
the elite
oligarchs and they don't serve the
American public at all They Don't Care
About Us like other people have said and
they do um I had so much more to say in
my head but but I feel Under Pressure um
but the lobbyists they're they're bribed
they're blackmailed um they don't they
don't serveice any any any longer and we
are headed towards a
dystopian um digital future with uh
digital
IDs Central Bank digital
currencies and social economic score um
you can see it coming you really can see
it coming I don't know you can even feel
it coming but um imagine what we could
do if we were were we were to be able to
seced we could create free energy it has
been done and and but they hide
everything they don't allow us to do
something like that we could in fact
Stanley Meyer back in the 70s I don't
know you remember but he was on TV on
the news and everything he was able to
create a car that could run on water and
the feds ended up murdering him got all
of his technology and murdered him um
there's been Healers of cancer and um
you know using
frequencies and there they
were
murdered um so imagine what we could do
if we didn't have those kind of
restraints we could really really
succeed very well um and that's I there
was a lot more I wanted to say but like
I said I know what times run
out Melissa thank you so much for that
is we'll look for your card about your
your last name
economus okay uh great I ask her I did
fill it
out okay and your town is Newton New
Hampshire from Newton all right thank
you so much Melissa you're welcome thank
you for hearing us and I
I appreciate it if you could just let
the people vote that's all we ask got it
thank you again all right with that uh
we will put a call a close to that first
hearing and we're going to jump right
into uh HB 1041 and a couple comments on
that I have a number of cards for that
and
um uh I want to thank Christina Dyer
Christina you're uh I did she is our
researcher and come to find out uh a
measure similar to this came to the
house to this committee uh around 2011
or so so this is not the first time this
has come here and um we're going to look
at what came before I've looked at some
of the notes Christina put together very
interesting that this has come up before
uh before we get started I I want to say
a couple things uh we're going to do
this a little bit differently uh
repesent Gart is the prime sponsor uh
he's asked asked if he could go last uh
to briefly tie tie up any loose ends in
terms of testimony so the co-sponsor
representative Granger is going to
introduce the measure uh before I throw
it to representative Granger um I want
to acknowledge is very important to me
and I've already spoken to some of these
gentlemen there this this measure is
about the uh incident that happened in
1967 uh I was around then I was a kid
but I remember this this incident
happening this incident if that's the
right word uh and there are at least
three gentlemen uh who have already
spoken to earlier who have traveled
great distances to be here to talk about
uh this the the ten of the bill the the
uh the two Representatives will will do
that um I want to point out that there
will be a news conference or a press
conference news conference uh scheduled
for 11:30 down in the L the Legislative
Office Building
Lobby um and I and I appreciate the the
sponsors uh taking my councel to set
this up downstairs we have a finite
amount of time in here and it's very
important that these gentlemen who
traveled a great distance have a chance
to uh say some things that they feel
need to be said and also to take some
questions so we'll do a little of that
in here but we we are constrained by
time so I want to point out that uh news
conference downstairs at 11:30 so all
that said we will get to the uh sponsor
and then um to uh some of the the
gentlemen who were part of this uh this
American history uh representative
Granger uh welcome uh thank you uh thank
you Mr chair members of the committee
this bill is to establish a commission
to investigate the USS Liberty incident
there are many important reasons to form
this commission but rather than have me
speak to that that we have firsthand
Witnesses here uh who can fill you in I
I do want to point out that this bill
was submitted in September and therefore
it was not instigated by the recent
occurrences in October so this isn't uh
a bill to draw any special attention to
the uh issue of Israel at all and it's
not it's not political in that sense it
was submitted before the recent uh re
recent crisises have sparked over there
um in the interest of time I have
provided my card to the clerk so you can
if you have any questions about the bill
specifically you can uh email me uh that
way I don't have to take any questions
uh thank you very much
thank you representative okay I want to
jump right into one of the survivors
who's traveled here from um Baltimore
we're going to ask the folks who follow
the survivors to try to uh limit your
testimony uh succinctly well organized
don't repeat previous information but I
want to give the uh the survivors who
are here uh a little bit more time up up
to five minutes if uh if they need that
uh to speak to us about um this bill and
again as the representative explained
this is a bill to establish a commission
to investigate this
1967 uh naval battle in the
Mediterranean so
uh uh Larry Larry Bowen who I spoke with
earlier I believe from Baltimore Larry
welcome uh and we're very interested to
hear what you have to
say
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Larry Bowen uh back
in June 8th 1967 I was an E5
Communications technician rman and uh
I'm here today to support uh H HB 1041
you speak into the mic please pardon
me i' I'd like to be you know called
under oath if possible because I uh have
never had an opportunity to speak before
a committee to uh you know tell the
story that uh that the American public
needs to hear yes Larry the notion of uh
swearing you wi under under oath has
come up and I contacted and spoke with
some parliamentarian types and we're we
are not going to uh do the oath taking
and I think as a military person uh my
my feeling is that you don't need to
swear an oath we we believe what you're
going to say without an oath so there
there you have it okay thank you well in
the previous bill I heard a lot about
the Constitution and what
uh what the Constitution and our
government is is not not
following um part of the reason that
we're here today is to support this bill
that uh our our government failed in
supporting the Constitution back when we
were attacked on June 8th
1967 um the government failed to come to
our rescue the government put a gag
order on us to um you know not speak
about the the incident um and threatened
us with imprisonment and fines and the
uh the government failed to do a f
thorough investigation of the uh the
attack um the Navy conducted a Navy
Court of
inquiry and during that court of inquiry
they took testimony from several of our
Shipmates um but then they were given
guidance to modify the testimony that
they received um so that
it would comply with the mistaken
identity uh claim that that Israel had
said when they
apologized um so we were
uh we were not all called for our
testimony all of us uh the other two
gentlemen here with me today uh were in
different parts of the ship so we've got
a little different perspective on on
what happened and and why this bill is
so important to us we've we've waited 56
and a half years for something like this
giving us an opportunity to speak before
a government organization that may in
fact follow through because of your you
know Live Free or Die uh statement
that's uh
that's what we're looking for we're
looking for the truth to get out about
the incident with the USS Liberty and
the aftermath um the investigations that
weren't done even though they were you
know constitutional requirement we
submitted a uh war crimes report back in
2005 that was designed to to have our
government do a formal investigation
uh through the Department of Defense and
they replied that there had already been
an investigation conducted and that
there they weren't going to do another
one uh there's been no Congressional
investigation into the Liberty this is
the first opportunity for a state to
actually come forth and say that you
know they're willing to set up a
commission to look into this and uh you
know report back on on the findings
there a lot of unanswered questions that
uh were submitted through uh the remote
testimony process um and I won't go into
those but I will say that
uh we're thrilled that the state of New
Hampshire is uh is willing to take this
up on the agenda and uh possibly give us
a chance to uh you know EXP express our
concerns and
uh you know get some truth out to the
American
public thank you Larry and thank you for
your service I I want to point out that
uh you folks have traveled great
distances there's also a New Hampshire
connection there's a commander David
Edward Edwin Lewis from colbrook North
Country where I'm from uh was on that
ship he might have been the the U um he
was Intel officer I think on our uh
officer in charge of the naval security
group activity that was also being
supported by the National Security
Agency and uh and he passed away in 2021
at the age of 90 so there there is that
New Hampshire connection and I believe
his niece is here and is going to talk
to okay uh well we certainly look
forward to that and okay that would be
her
um it we we do need to roll and I know
you have a news conference coming up
that we don't want to have you miss
because then you'll have full
opportunity but I I have one quick
question uh that has to do with the end
state so the purpose of this measure is
to establish a commission so if if the
commission were to be established uh let
me ask you uh what if if you could
briefly tell us one thing that you'd
like to see come out of this commission
where it to happen
um probably
probably for me I'd like to see the
truth come out so that we can we can
actually you know tell the rest of the
American public exactly what happened
there's still documentation that the NSA
and CIA are holding as classified
information that uh that they haven't
released yet there's uh still
documentation that uh has come out since
the June 8th
1967 uh that's been published in various
books but um it's never all come
together to kind of refute refute the uh
the claim that this was a mistaken
identity attack and and was in fact a
deliberate attack so um yeah I'd like to
see the uh results of the committee to
to verify what uh what the actual cause
of the attack Act was and uh what what
we should have done that uh our Congress
didn't
do thank you for that questions any
other questions uh yes uh represent Lev
thank you chair
Mett you know I appreciate your
testimony it's Larry right
yes a question I have is where did the
government failed I mean your testimony
is rather vague I mean in what
unanswered
questions um need to be explained I mean
you're up here testimony I think the
committee deserves an indepth
explanation as to why you feel that the
government failed and according to my
memorandum here it says uh the official
report states that the attack was
accidental I mean I think in order for
us to make a informative decision
we would probably need a little better
explanation as to why you don't believe
that okay as a crew member uh we had
been
overflown that day uh probably a half a
dozen times by Israeli aircraft doing
reconnaissance on our ship and at the
time we felt safe because the uh the
planes were clearly marked and uh we
thought that you know they had our back
cuz we were out there as an independent
ship the
uh I
guess when the attack occurred they were
using unmarked aircraft so we had no
idea what uh what country was actually
doing the you know the
attacking we uh we didn't find that out
until the torpedo boats came up after
the strafing runs and the napom drops uh
the torpedo boats came in and they were
carrying the star David flags on their
on their little torpedo boats
so the
uh where where our government failed is
that they didn't take into
consideration anything about the
culpability of uh of the attackers or
who was you know there was no discussion
with uh the
uh Israeli Defense Force personnel who
were participating in this um it came
out after the attack that there was
actually intercept voice intercept from
the aircraft uh pilots and their ground
controllers that they did identify it as
a us you know ship with uh the American
flag flying but that was taken out of
the
testimony so so when they Court of
inquiry was done the uh some of the
things that were you
know I guess some of the things that
happened to the ship were uh were not
allowed to be testified about uh we
hadeen follow up followup chair follow
up it's astonishing to me that
this wasn't discredited by our
government because what you're saying is
going open up a whole new
investigation because of a testimony
that
and forgive me if I wrong that was not
investigated because if if what you're
saying it wasn't I mean you know that
could have you know
long-term implications as far as where
this committee not only goes of votes
but you know in some of the U decisions
you know
the government may have to make right
well I understand and it's uh those are
the kinds of questions that came up with
with us as a organization trying to get
Congress to uh to do a full and
comprehensive
investigation um this bill if the
committee you know so chooses um
establishes a commission to do
the the work of the federal government
um to determine not only culpability but
um answer questions about why we were
you know put under gag order to never
talk about the the incident uh I mean it
was it was historical in the sense of
thank you Larry and you just mentioned
historical and I think one of the and I
think representative L's question is
very fair uh gets right to the heart of
what we need to talk about and I think
your answer is very good uh we need to
press on uh you mentioned historical and
I think one thing that'll come out of
this uh this is on YouTube um a lot of
awareness has been raised and is being
raised and will be raised about this
history from 1967 a lot of people did
not know about and they will know about
it now I don't know where this will go
uh we're still taking obviously
testimony um are there any other
questions for Larry
at this time uh M Bowen thank you for
your for traveling here and um and for
your testimony and for your service
thank you and thank you for allowing me
to testify and we'll press on to someone
else who was there in
1967 uh and has come here all the way
from Missouri um Bryce
Lockwood gunny Gunnery Sergeant uras
cifi gny thanks for being here
chairman my name is Bryce Lockwood I'm a
retired guny Sergeant United States
Marine Corps retired Baptist Minister
ordain I have some pictures here I would
like to provide to the members of the
committee Show the ship that was taken
from the aircraft of the USS America on
the next morning there were also some
pictures that were taken of me the next
morning I faced a torpedo explosion from
less than 10 ft away looking at it the
question came up about the identity of
the ship every protocol and
international law that was designed to
prevent such an accident was violated by
the Israelis in this attack they were
using unmarked aircraft they were
jamming our distress frequencies they
machine guned our life rafts ironically
the machine gunning of the life rafts
international law came about as a result
of Nazi submarines machine gunning
Refugee ships many of which contain
individuals who later became Israeli
citizens the question came up that we
were not in a combat zone the Israelis
never broadcasted an area closure
therefore we were not in a combat zone
we were at international waters 13 and a
half miles off the Sinai
Peninsula there was no
investigation by the US Congress into
the attack ownership which is required
by Article 1 section8 the US
Constitution to invest acts of piracy on
the high seas Congress has never done so
the Liberty vets Association has a
letter from the US Congress that that is
in the Congressional
Record some years ago the USS Cole was
attacked off Yemen 17 Americans were
killed the American government US
Congress investigated that accident for
9 months twice as many were killed in
attack on the USS Liberty
that investigation was concluded in 5
days our
organization filed formal war crimes
charges in
2005 the secretary of the Army is
required by law to
investigate all war crimes
charges it has never been
investigated law firm of Ron
gotcher
provided free
graus information by PR preparing that
war crimes charge and the US uh
Secretary of the army has never done
anything about it uh ladies and
gentlemen we are so
appreciative of you folks taking time to
listen to us and we are grateful thank
you gunny thank you for your service and
yes uh a lot of attention is being paid
to this and and will be paid to this
questions uh represent
Rollins yes I'd just like to say thank
you for the photographs that you you
provided us right to you thank you and
thank you for your service from all of
us my privilege thank you
sir thank you
g okay also here who's traveled good
distance is Philip torney uh he's
representing the US Liberty he's the
current president and he can explain U
his position there thank you for
traveling here to support the sponsors
uh measure welcome uh obviously support
the bill and and um uh if you could just
confirm the spelling of your last name
here for our Clerk and then off you go
yes sir uh spelling of my last name is t
r NE okay that's first name Phillip I'm
from Cedar R color colado a small town
on the western slope of Colorado uh I
liveed on a 40 acre ranch there and I
did travel a great distance to get here
I would have walked here if I had to
we've never ever had the chance to sit
before a committee and thank you uh Mr
mofet chairman and and all distinguished
guests here and representatives thank
you for the honor of being here what
what we're here for
is this the truth has never been told
it's been a
lie uh Mr L I believe you talked about
uh the investigation was a mistaken
identity that was put into the naval
Board of inquiry under the direction of
LBJ to tell Admiral Isaac kit in Ward
Boston it was a mistaken identity that's
the farthest thing in the world from
what really happened what you people are
can't do do for us today is the most
important thing you'll probably ever do
in your
life we're here to represent the men
that didn't get back that day 34 of them
were blown to bits 25 of them were blown
to bits by a torpedo which these two men
he was he you testified to that 10t from
the torpedo hole these guys are security
people the most secret people I've ever
met are not a security guy I wasn't in
that part of the ship I was in damag
control uh I saw the airplanes I saw the
attacking planes I saw the the
helicopters coming over to finish us off
this attack lasted as long as attack on
Pearl
Harbor aircraft were sent from the USS
Saratoga USS America they were recall by
LBJ and mber to get back to base do not
help the Liberty they left us out out
there to
die Lyndon Baines
Johnson and
Esco he was a prime minister of Israel
at the time concluded they colluded
together to sink our ship we were set up
to be murdered by our own government
slaughtered left out there alone we
didn't see any help for 17 hours when
help was only 40 minutes
away two aircraft carriers the USS
America and USS Saratoga in fact the
skipper of the Saratoga lost his job
because he sent help to
us from the America they recall
back
the the Congress of the United
States has never investigated this they
say they have but they're lying they've
never had an official investigation this
is the first body of people in
government that we've had the
opportunity to speak before we gave our
blood for this
country we would do it again but not in
the circumstances being set up to be
murdered and that's what they wanted
they wanted to bring us into World War
III we were this close to World War
I believe me and we can prove it we've
got documents and I'm not going to
repeat every all every document will get
all that to you through Jason or Matt or
somebody whatever you want you can go
through
but please please just understand we're
not here in Anger we're here because we
love our country we love our fellowship
mates and we love all of you we're all
Americans if we don't look out for each
other we're done that's why we're here
in the leave Live Free or Die state is
because of you people nobody else has
the courage to do this to listen to
us um I thank my God my God in heaven
that saved that she ship cuz what we had
a 40x 40t torpedo hole in the
ship we were put over life we only had
three life rafts left we put him over to
save to get the most seriously wounded
in him and the the ship was full of
people on the deck bleeding
dying we put the life rafts over and the
Israelis shot them out of the
water they took one aboard their boat as
a trophy of the
kill this isn't about
this isn't about hate this is about
American way that they took away our
first amendment rights I was told by
Admiral kid and four others in a
separate interview I told him exactly
what I saw and what I
thought he he took his Stars off he says
now I'm just like your dad just tell me
everything and I did when I got done he
put his stars back on and says if you
ever breathe a word about what you just
told me to anybody I'll make sure you
end up in the penitentiary your worst we
all know what worse meant
death we just went through hell we've
been going through hell for 56 and a
half years for the truth our own
government did this to us this body here
don't do that to us don't throw us down
the road don't don't please don't we
need you we need if you do this the
United States government has got to do
something then because
you I just can't tell you the importance
of what you what you uh people are
tasked with with this Liberty
investigation and believe me it's the
most important thing you'll ever do in
your life thank you Mr torney uh I want
to remind you and everyone else that
your words are being recorded uh this
will be this is on video and uh you you
will have the opportunity in your
comrades to refer people to this video
which will be around
forever uh in terms of uh shining a
light on this raising awareness about it
um I know you have a news conference you
need to go to before we lose you is does
anyone have a qu go ahead uh Larry uh
representative from Manchester represent
gagy uh is a Navy guy I believe right
yes I was I was a skiy waver okay so I
identify with the
Radioman uh back in that time period too
we're we're all old um I'm looking at
the picture of the ship here which is
badly damaged
I was a Tin Can Sailor by the way um I'm
looking for the American flag which is
usually on the stern I don't see it is
it there yeah it's on the Mast look look
up top on the
Mast it's on the
lanyard mid midm
or I I anyway I don't see it but that's
uh in my opinion it's still no excuse
sir if
I it was shot down from the Flag
Staff two flags were shot down a third
of one was raised a holiday flag from
signal Howard
yeah okay I'll take your word for it sir
we always had a flag flying yeah flag
was flying all the time supposed to yes
in fact the Israelis identified as as
American friendly hours before then they
took us off their war table and forgot
we were there so if there's any other
questions I'll glad to take them but uh
represent
leit no one here is going to take away
your First Amendment right I will be the
first one to vote for a subcommittee to
investigate this and I appreciate all of
your
passionate testimony because this is
something that's been taken too long to
have it and ultimately Cham off it makes
the decision but I'll be the first God
bless you thank
you uh Mr CH we'll see no other hands we
will uh let you go uh thank you for
being here I know it was a long trip
thank you for your service uh I know you
have a news conference we want to let
you go and that'll give you an
opportunity to to better elaborate to
whoever's there uh and take questions
and uh and here course we have some
constraints uh the prime sponsor uh I
want to go to him because I know you
need to be with these gentlemen um as
they go
downstairs uh and I also have a number
of cards so before we get to the cards
to to finish this hearing uh Rees Gard
if you would take a minute or two
whatever uh just to tie things together
before you step
away thank you thank you members of the
committee I've I've asked for a little
more detailed explanation Jason Gard
Northfield
Franklin I just wanted to address what
happened immediately after the attack
and the subsequent efforts to sync the
Liberty just briefly yes we were sent uh
when hell filing got there 17 hours
later and they took the most seriously
wounded off um which was most the
ship they sent us to Malta th000 miles
away with a 40x40 foot torpedo hole in
it hoping we'd sink on the way and all
the evidence would be gone our only sin
that day was staying alive to tell the
truth I'm 77 years old I've I've been
I'm the four-time president and I've
been doing this most of my life it
became a life's
Mission and it was one of the best
things I ever did in my life I will say
this I have two sons that served one one
Serge um in Afghanistan 10th Mountain
lost his eye my other son he's current
Navy SEAL he's still in so uh with that
being said uh and and
sir
your your answer to me and what you said
to me means more than you'll ever know
God bless
you it's my pleasure thank you the
closer port was oh the close report was
in
C much early to get there so I just
wanted to establish that for the record
thank you thank you much I appreciate it
thank you for your service sir I just
just to brush on two things from the
packet that was passed
around the Declaration of Ward
Boston there's some
highlighted aspects in there in June of
1967 I was assigned a senior legal
council for the Navy's Court of inquiry
in to the brutal attack on USS Liberty
which had occurred on June 8th the late
Admiral Isaac c kid president of the
court and I were given only one week to
gather evidence just I'm reading the
highlighted Parts just go through this
very fastly it was our shared belief is
on the bottom based on a documentary
evidence and
testimony we Reed firsthand that the
Israeli attack was planned and
deliberate and could not possibly have
been an accident Admiral kid and I both
felt it necessary to travel to Israel to
interview the Israelis who took part in
the attack Admiral kid L told me that
Admiral McCain was adamant that we were
not to travel to is or contact the
Israelis concerning this matter I know
from personal conversations I had with
Admiral kid that President Lyndon
Johnson and Secretary of Defense robbert
mcnamar ordered him to conclude that the
attack was a case of mistaken identity
despite overwhelming evidence to the
contrary Admiral kid told me after
returning from Washington DC that he had
been ordered to sit down with two
civilians from either the White House or
the defense department and rewrite
portions of the Court's findings Admiral
kid also told me that he had been
ordered to quote unquote put the lid on
everything having to do with the attack
on USS Liberty we were never to speak of
it and we were to caution everyone else
involved that they could never speak of
it
again and the first page we spoke
briefly of Commander Lewis who is from C
Brook New Hampshire so I just want to
establish there is a
very um significant New Hampshire
connection to this Commander Lewis was
in charge of I believe 194 men on board
the ship out of
204 so he in his
obituary this is on the first
page second paragraph well third
technically Eddie's career spanned more
than 25 years he retired at the rank of
commander and he was wounded aboard the
USS Liberty in the Mediterranean Sea
when the nation of Israel attacked a
ship claiming mistaken identification of
the ship for the rest of his life Eddie
bore the scars of that day and he was
deeply involved with the the group of
survivors proving that the state of
Israel and the Johnson Administration
deliberately staged the attack to try
and draw the us into the Israeli
Egyptian Six-Day War of 1967 in 2018 he
was a central figure and collaborator in
the book blood in the water which
Chronicles this dark episode of American
military
history so in
closing I thank everyone for listening
to this testimony I really appreciate
these men coming vast distances to
testify and
I hope that this committee will see the
significance of this issue and bring it
forward so we can get to the bottom of
this situation
that quite frankly he a scar on the
legitimacy of congressional
investigations in my opinion thank you
questions for the prime
sponsor uh representative pH Philo sure
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative um and thank you
representative for bringing this issue
to the committee and thank you to our uh
Witnesses today for not only traveling
here but now putting it on to the public
record what happened and I think for
those of us who were not aware bringing
it to our attention as well I want to
preface this with I think this is
important to put onto the public record
and begin to figure out what happened
through an investigation but I'm also
aware of the limit of state power that
we don't have an ability to subpoena the
the Federal government we wouldn't have
the ability to subpoena Federal record
so if we were to launch an
investigation it is very possible we
could get stonewalled but from what I
perceive of the intent of the bill and
you can correct me if I'm wrong which I
guess is how I'm going to Loop this into
being a question in the end uh what
ultimately this is to try to kick the
federal government into gear and say
this actually did occur start doing your
jobs would you be amenable to perhaps
changing this to an HR to put it on the
record that the legislature of New
Hampshire believes this happen thinks
it's important as well as giving some
form of State recognition to the
survivors more so than an investigation
which could ultimately be an
investigation into nothing because we
don't have a subpoena power or an extr
territorial investigation power I would
answer the later latter part of your
question no I don't believe a house
resolution would would achieve what we
need to happen which is put onto the
official record all of the documents
official documents including that um
affid davit of Ward Boston in 2004 there
a lot of things have come to light after
the supposed Congressional investigation
that need to be brought onto the record
so it's not so much a matter of
subpoenaing and getting p and getting
information that's not readily available
although the 200 so pages that are still
classified would be helpful and I
believe that launching this at the state
level and putting pressure on the
federal government to release documents
that are decades old
would lead to more information coming
out so no on the house resolution cuz
that would just simply say hey we think
this is important but the investigation
actually says we're having people come
and testify there's more sellers that
would if we had a full-on investigation
we'll be here to testify and I think
it's important to get these on the
record because otherwise all the
platitudes that we give to our veterans
really don't mean much that's my
personal opinion on that thank you for
that explanation anything else for the
prime
sponsor yes uh rips of Judy thank you Mr
chair uh who was happy New Year and uh I
would like to know if someone here knows
about the name of that prime minister at
that time Le Esko was the Prime Minister
of Israel at that
time okay yes yeah I remember was
mentioned earlier but I didn't remember
the name so other
questions okay representative thank you
for that uh I know you need to get
downstairs
so here's what is going to happen at
this time we are running late but this
is uh what we do um I I have a number of
other cards and I'm going to uh and I
know some of the folks who want to uh
testify uh also I I encourage to get
downstairs to to be with these survivors
as they amplify their comments so I'm
going to ask that the folks who still
want to stay here and testify uh keep
their comments to a minute or two uh and
then that'll give you a chance to get
downstairs so and that is something I
can do as the chair and um so we're
going to kind of uh be kind of tough on
that keep it as succinct as possible
because we do need to finish this up we
do want to give you a chance to get down
stairs um however uh Kathy Peterson um
is Kath uh Kathy uh I've got you at the
top of the list uh if you could take a
minute or two if you still want to uh
and and before she starts
uh please understand we we do take and
encourage written testimony email
testimony uh portal testimony which we
can uh evaluate and take up at exec
session so uh please utilize those
options as well uh Kathy welcome okay
thank you uh Kathy Peterson a New
Hampshire native I live in
nashwa um as did my
cousin that was on the USS Papo ship
sent in to pick up these fine
gentlemen the 34 that were killed and
the 174 that were severely
wounded uh it affected his whole life it
affected our family's life he drank a
lot he finally stopped and found peace
but I've always known about it and it'd
be really great if somebody could do
something about it finally thank
you thank you Kathy uh John Graham uh
that's if you'd like to pass that around
that would be that would be wonderful
maker
yes I representative honorable John
Graham representating the American
Legion uh representative I mentioned one
or two minutes uh you're in opposition
to the to the me I'm not I'm not in
opposition to the bill as a whole I
think that um anytime we look at
incidents such as this is important I
just wish that the sponsors had bothered
to reach shout to the American Legion
ahead of time to put our name down we do
not desire to participate in this
commission and so I would ask that it be
amended to take us off our National
Organization has a position on on this
issue and if you leave it on there will
not be a member appointed so thank you
very much and in the interest of time as
you have said it the well Mr chairman I
will take no questions
okay uh thank you uh honorable John
Graham for the American
Legion uh and appreciate the uh suc
sness okay uh Derek Pro Derek has been
here
before supports the
Bill thank you chairman Moffett members
of the committee my name is Derek PR uh
from Derry New Hampshire uh former
Sergeant New Hampshire Army National
Guard um I just want to speak as a
veteran there's many members on this
committee who are a veteran um you know
we're brothers and sisters in arms we
supposed to take care of each other
we're a family and we owe it to our
family to give them a proper
investigation that they never had we owe
it to them they've been searching for 57
years and and it's it's our job as
brothers and sisters in arms to give it
to them thank you
thank you
Derek does anyone have a hot question
for Derek if I meant to offer that
courtesy and I sing No Hands thank you
again Derek uh Matt schir has uh is in
support of the bill he submitted written
testimony which is great thank you for
that Matt uh Paul Lloyd Paul from the
VFW was here earlier is Paul
here okay is there anyone else who uh
I've missed or their card has been lost
in transit not seeing any uh again I'll
remind everyone we uh I see hand up yes
sir
sir uh step right up uh state your name
and Hometown and take a minute to two
minutes yes
sir hey good evening guys my name is
Matt Sabor and dhw here I'm not sure I
think I might have submitted two cards I
just wanted to testify in support of the
bill and honor Rel to discharged veteran
a separated Air Force o03 three I'm
testifying today I'm a resident in New
Hampshire and seber and I would love to
see our state pickup where the federal
government left off we owe transparency
to the deceased and wounded survivors
and their families and to the public as
well in the United States we have a
federalized system of government and
it's the accountability of the state
responsibility of the states to hold the
federal government accountable federal
government is not competent or even
loyal enough to its Sailors to determine
the culpability of an act of war against
them then it's up to the states to fill
that leadership
void uh although I'm not a member uh the
current standing resolution by the
Veterans of Foreign Wars resolution 423
to have the tack investigated by
Congress is still standing but has
currently been ignored uh the question
needs to be asked is who do our
government be accountable for uh the
American servicemen of the USS Liberty
who volunteered to risk their life for
the family friends and neighbors and the
public at large deser a responsible
government that caters to Americans as a
New Hampshire resident I would be
thrilled if our state and donor a net
donor to the federal government could
respond to the legitimate requests of
the USS Liberty veterans association and
provide the crew with an impartial and
complete inv instigation of the incident
and its
aftermath thank you thank you Matt and
thank you for getting these gentlemen
from point A to point B and now Point C
is downstairs for the uh the little
conference and so we'll let you get to
that and seeing no other cards are hands
at this time we will uh end that hearing
uh sir I see H up yes sir uh I just
wanted to say about the American
Legion my shipmate Glenn olant with
Ernie Gallow one if there he was a
current president then National
Convention they wouldn't let him have a
booth he uh Glenn tore up his uh
American Legion card and it fell on a
woman they put him in jail for
assault for wanting to represent the USS
Liberty he went to jail and as far as
American Legion goes we've been banned
for life by the American Legion banned
for life because we wanted to have a
booth at the American Legion to voice
our concern to more veterans and we got
banned so that's that's what I think
about the American Legion thank you for
sharing that and that's a something that
we're going to try to get some more uh
background and information on uh I've
just ended the hearing and I know
there's a downstairs uh conference and
we will let you get to that and we need
to move ahead to the next measure on our
docket which is uh
hb130 and that is to establish a
commission to study the economic legal
sociological aspects of New Hampshire
exerting its sovereign state rights uh
the the uh Prime sponsor is
here that's representative
santonastaso uh so uh
Matt if you can uh hang in for a few
moments while these folks head to their
next conference and while we're waiting
uh I know that representative
santonastaso had to be elsewhere and it
asked to start a little bit late so that
works out we are a little bit behind but
we'll hopefully get caught up I do want
to state that this the subject of uh
State sovereignty is something we spent
a huge amount of time on already today
some of the folks are still here from
the earlier hearing uh so uh please know
that the committee um is is and this is
on tape we've got all kinds of uh
written material uh so that we don't
need to hear a lot of the same state
sovereignty points that have already
been made uh I know that the prime
sponsor wasn't here so we want to keep
this moving we want this to be efficient
and effective and we're going to let the
prime fully explain his measure and and
then those who want to speak uh again I
emphasize uh if we've already covered
some of the state sovereignty stuff
already uh we don't need to hear it the
same thing twice all right that said uh
representative uh the seat is now clear
for you welcome and uh talk to us about
HP
1130 thank
you all right uh good morning state
federal relations and Veterans Affair
committee I am representative Santa also
representing the towns of ring Jaffrey
and Dublin House Bill
1130 establishes a statutory committee
to study the economic legal and
sociological aspects of New Hampshire
exerting its sovereign state
rights I chose to introduce this bill
this year because I think it's critical
that New Hampshire is prepared in the
case of a national divorce or similar
incident that would drive New Hampshire
to Char's
Independence you do not need to support
uh the Hampshire Independence to support
this bill this bill is about emergency
preparedness in a time when so many
political leaders are floating the idea
of a national divorce it is critical
that New Hampshire has a sound plan for
exiting the United States if that
scenario were to occur movements in
Texas and California are exploring the
idea of Independence Gavin Nome even
refers to California as a nation state
we could be one election away from a
massive shakeup in the makeup of the
United States in order to prepare for
this potential scenario we need to ask
critical
questions while something like a federal
disillusion seems unlikely today I would
like to remind the committee that
impossible things have often happened
throughout history including the sudden
breakup of the Soviet Union if someone
said in 1988 that the Soviet Union would
be completely gone in 5 years they would
have been considered a crazy person uh
and and to demonstrate this is a real
possibility it is an Open Secret that
the the United States is going to lose
its reserved currency status the
economic social and political
repercussions of this event is
unknowable the study committee would
provide a comprehensive analysis of the
economic legal and sociological aspects
of New Hampshire exerting its Sovereign
rights sovereign state rights it would
allow for an in-depth examination of the
implications of a potential independent
New Hampshire including its relationship
with the federal government and other
states the comme could identify
potential benefits and challenges that
an independent New Hampshire May face
such as changes to taxation trade and
Foreign
Relations the findings of the committee
could inform future legislation and
policy decisions regarding the
Hampshire's relationship with the
federal government a study committee
would Pro promote Civic engagement by
encouraging public input and a
discussion on this uniquely interesting
topic if it would raise awareness about
the issue of State sovereignty and how
it affects the lives of New Hampshire
residents the study committee could
serve as a model for other states
considering similar
issues the work of the state committee
could lead to a better understanding of
the role of states in the federal system
and potentially strengthens New
Hampshire's position within the
Union New Hampshire will be more
prepared for a situation that causes
independent
Hampshire um so uh talks of
uh in general I think helps the state
when bargaining with the federal
government uh a lot of people who would
not Support cacr 32 uh of 2022 the uh
previous uh Independence bill they even
though they ins support the bill they
understood grievances with the federal
government um and they agreed you know
often they agreed uh with the with the
Grievances but disagreed this is the
best method uh or that the federal
government was just not out of control
enough yet uh so similar to like how uh
firearm is a violence deterrent uh you
know a criminal won't attack because the
gun is perceived as a threat uh true
Independence talks is a good tyranny
deterrent because the federal government
will just let off the gas a little bit
uh if they fear the rear possibility of
States breaking
away House Bill 1130 is a Forward
Thinking initiative that prepares New
Hampshire for all invention alties
whether within or outside the Union by
examining the intricate e by examining
the intricate economic legal and and
sociological aspects of asserting our
state Sovereign rights this bill not
only equips us with valuable insights
for potential Independence but also
strengthens our position with the
federal government this proactive
approach ensures Hampshire remains
prepared and resilient in the face of an
unpredictable future while fostering a
deeper understanding of our state's role
within the federal
system thank you for your time and I
will take uh questions from the
committee thank you representative uh I
have one quick quick thing you mentioned
several times study committee uh you
meant study commission I think right
study commission is opposed to committee
that's correct okay thank you for that
correction and and I know that uh
commissions there are some uh protocols
for certain ways to put commissions
together the the previous measure we
just heard call for a commission as well
and and looking at that measure some of
the commission members uh we're going to
have to check with parliamentarians to
see if if it fits the model or the
protocols for commission so I'm looking
on your first page uh three members of
the House Etc so I I'm just asking so is
you the makeup of your commission is
this in in accordance with the uh the
protocols for commissions is that have
you confirmed all that uh I can't
confirm that this time okay okay uh or
or we will um okay that was my question
just on the makeup and the protocols
other questions for the prime
sponsor all right thank you
representative thank you we have some
pink cards here we're going to Dive
Right In we're going to go through these
hopefully
expeditiously uh as I've said before
please submit written testimony um
and uh again we request that you don't
repeat previous information so that we
can uh get right through this uh Russell
canning from Winchester is Russell here
Russell welcome again uh you've asked
for one minute and that's uh wonderful
happy to give you a
minute H yes because he so Russell
canning from Winchester so I was part of
uh writing this uh we do not know how
those procedures are for for commissions
so that'll have to be handled later uh
we are going to be able to do something
that uh the Texas national movement is
not able to do right now uh we're
friends with them they're trying to uh
our government here in New Hampshire is
more open to the people so we might be
able to do something here that
California and other places can't do we
will be the Trailblazers just like we
were the Trailblazers on uh in the
1700s so um I think one person on this
committee two years ago asked for a
commission and a few other people that
weren't in this committee they thought
uh cacr 30 2 was too soon so that's why
we're doing
it thank you again and uh in terms of uh
other states I I think California might
be well uh advised to see what we're up
to here in New Hampshire from time to
time that's just me yeah thank you uh
they won't be able to talk about it and
also the prime sponsor is is he still
here yeah yes so to his point about
making sure that the uh the language and
the protocols and the commission members
fit with with uh whatever the protocols
for a commission are that's something
that uh I'm sure the prime will will
will confirm and these kinds of things
do not have to lead to secession uh
Catalonia looked into it and then it
never happened uh of course there were
some abuses on the Spanish side when
that happened but it was good for them
they did a commission they spent eight
years and a lot of money in New
Hampshire we won't spend that much
money little European history there um
Bonnie is still here uh Bonnie do you
still wish to to testify on
this okay Bonnie from Kain was here
again we've already spent a lot of time
on state sovereignty but uh if you have
some new points for this measure uh uh
take a minute or two for sure go go
ahead okay um I work for a press I I'm a
member of the media and I have
interviewed hundreds of people with my
husband about secession and asking them
what they felt about it and I mean only
people in New Hampshire
too overwhelmingly people are in favor
of it but a lot of them have questions a
lot of them say I can see why that would
be a great idea but I have questions and
all I want to say is this would be the
perfect opportunity to give them solid
answers with real data instead of just
explain to them what we uh think is most
likely true like Alo axelman who
testified um two bills ago he has a book
called articles of secession and it has
all kinds of explanations for many of
the frequently asked questions
but a commission would um give people
more concrete answers that's
all thank you Bonnie Miss Miss Freeman
any questions for
Bonnie seeing none uh thank you and good
luck with your media career I see you
behind the camera uh Matt schir is uh is
still in the house
and uh Matt you spoke earlier in in this
uh General subject and um and you have
some some new some new points right yes
sir yeah y so and it's still it's still
the morning so good morning chairman
mafa and members of the committee thank
you so much for having me again today uh
Matt saor DW I'm the chairman of the New
Hampshire Independence pack excited to
have our pack endorse this legislation
obviously the purpose of this bill is to
create a plan of action for New
Hampshire as its own nation state uh few
things there a lot there's a lot going
on in the country and I wanted to
illustrate a few things that why we
should consider planning ahead should we
need to be our own
country uh Georgia congresswoman Marg
Taylor green brought for support of the
idea of national divorce during her
speech when she visited the Grafton
County Republican committee's Lincoln
rank in dinner this past fall I know
she's tweeted about that several times
but it's not just us or Texas talking
about that there's other folks around
the country that are doing it as well
California has its own National Party in
the Pacific Northwest the greater Idaho
movement seeks to relocate several
counties in Rural Oregon to the state of
Idaho there's even Divide New York
campaign going on and while not
currently legislatively active our next
door neighbor Vermont has its own
independent advoc advocacy group during
this current election cycle there have
been scenarios of major party candidates
for president of the United States being
removed from State ballots in Texas um
they they had nearly 140,000 citizens
sign a petition for Texas to seced it's
possible it could be on the ballot this
spring I don't know additionally with no
predictable ends so far to immigration
into the United States question is could
mult multiculturalism in America today
yield multiple countries in North
America tomorrow Sir John glub in his
book The Fate of Empires oh my goodness
I'm sorry guys and the fate of Empire
Empires analyzed the current uh the
cultural success of 13 different states
and federations over history and
concluded that the average cycle length
of national greatness of an Empire is
about 250 years uh we're approaching the
anniversary with these in the United
States uh these are canaries in the coal
mine of national divorce that is granted
State leaders we should should not
ignore in the beginning of the 1900s
there were 55 States worldwide what will
this Century
bring uh just like how you and your
family have a plan for what to do when
the power goes out at home state
government of New Hampshire should have
its own plann on how to behave in the
event of a national divorce the
questions the bill seeks to answer cover
both foreign and domestic policy this is
a scenario that H should be prepared for
I would love all members of the
committee to feel safe and responsible
voting in favor of this Bill thank
you Matt your written testimony is
that's something that you have already
submitted to us or you're going to
submit it's all it was not for this one
sir no it was yeah you you mentioned ver
this Vermont has a a sovereign movement
as well did I hear you say that like
Vermont independent they got a website
like they were active for like five
years they're not as active now yeah
they okay yeah all right well thank you
qu questions for
Matt seeing none uh thank you again for
your time and for your uh interesting
testimony which hopefully we'll get a
copy for for the clerk's folder I have
two more cards on this measure uh Steve
Steven V Stephen welcome you've been
here all day you here early early right
I promise this will be very very
different uh good morning or still
morning barely chairman Muffet uh
committee members I'm Steven Valle from
do and I'm the founder of the club 75
Alliance One of several New Hampshire
groups advocating for success session
but my group is very different from the
others I want to do it legally and that
means the United States constitutional
amendment to allow secession modeled
after the European Union's article 50
which made brexit
possible now the politicians in DC
aren't going to like this but they need
to remember they're supposed to be
representing the American people and
recent polls show that folks are
starting to open their minds about
secession I want to reach out to to
directly to the American people and ask
them nicely to please be magnanimous and
allow negotiated peaceful secession
because it's the proper decent civilized
thing to do when a clear majority of a
state's residents want independence
that's what consent of the government is
all
about my second big difference from the
other groups is that I'm happy to wait a
few years I actually think secession
today would be premature we probably
don't have the majority in favor
yet in any case for me it's not about
escaping a broken federal government I
don't think DC is broken it's just
trying to be all things to all people
and we need to get away from that we
need to ackowledge that different people
want very different things out of
government Libertarians like me want
small government much smaller than what
most Republicans and Democrats want and
we're gradually realizing our best
strategy is to concentrate ourselves in
New Hampshire until we're the majority
here and then push for peaceful
secession I'm the author of this book
which explains in some detail how it
could work I call it multilateral
secession that means carefully listening
to all sides especially including the
Loyalists those folks already here in
New Hampshire Who Remain loyal to DC and
who would by that time be a minority in
a civilized secession it's vitally
important to make reasonable
accommodations for the Loyalists and in
this case that means grandfathering them
into the big government benefits they
have today my goal for secession is to
make lots of Libertarians very happy
while maintaining excellent relations
with the United States and also making
sure that nobody in New Hampshire is
materially worse off due to secession if
it looks like some people would be
suffering then as part part of this
study commission let's sit down talk
about it and see if we can fix it so
that secession doesn't hurt anybody so
please vote ought to pass on this bill
so we can have a civil discussion about
secession thank you and I'm happy to
take questions thank you Steve you
mentioned the term loyalists which says
a historical term so this is a different
type of loyalist than what we saw in the
history books correct it's parallel
though it means people who remain loyal
to the parent country okay to the
existing yeah uh regime so to speak uh
if you haven't already if you could
submit or get us the name uh
electronically uh the name of your
organization the website I have what I
just said in written form and I'm happy
to hand this in yes if the clerk could
get that and if you can electronically
submit as well okay if you haven't
already okay uh I I would like to to see
the website so we can look more into
what you describe questions for
Steve Valle Mr Valle uh M Le I see you
you're making justicul
justicul I can tell thank you chair M I
can tell he's a little bit um schooled
on this because you know this has been
beat up pretty much through you know our
committees over the last four or five
maybe more years but um you know I
concur with chair MF you can grab that
information so that we can have a you
know quote more
educated decision that would be great
and thank you for your testimony
today thank you Mr Valle okay last pin
card Carla gcki Miss gcki spoke very
eloquently earlier uh a wonderful
speaker uh Carla is and Carla uh you've
been here before and you have some new
new information on sovereignty for us uh
I do thank you chairman
and
[Laughter]
sorry I'm too loud for the committee I
apologize um thank you I'm the same
person I was when I testified earlier
Carla Garrick from Manchester I am also
the acting president of the foundation
for New Hampshire Independence um I'm
here to testify in support of
hb130 uh last year as many of you know
who still serve on the committee we got
a lot of flak uh it seemed like the
feedback was was hey guys this seems
premature do you know what you're doing
what's going on so uh we heard that and
so we drafted this in an attempt to try
and really come to the table and start
to Grapple with these uh difficult ideas
but things that have to be talked about
um I think it's fair to say we don't
have all the answers yet and that's okay
we're starting a conversation and it's
worth letting our imaginations soar
let's say an independent Nation New
Hampshire could be a prosperous and
peaceful country along the lines of
successful countries like Luxembourg
lonstein or Switzerland we would have
four times the population of Iceland
we'd be larger than some countries in
Europe we'd be able to work with our
neighbors to trade much like countries
in the shenzen area in Europe already do
so that whole question about oh would I
have to go through border control to go
to Maine to cabin no probably not it's
something we could solve uh for people
who are concerned about uh Social
Security we have a lot of EX Pats who
already live in places like Mexico who
do receive their Social Security checks
we could even grapple with something
like a duel citizenship you could be a
citizen of the great country of New
Hampshire and you could hold duel
citizenship with the United States a
study committee would give us the
opportunity and create a safe space for
us to explore these ideas of New
Hampshire sovereignity maybe we could
run on nuclear power I know there bills
in front of uh various legis committees
at the moment looking at hey could we
expand our nuclear and maybe we could
export energy maybe we would have
competing currencies and we would start
to attract Banks and you know crypto
companies and people to come invest in
our great little country maybe we would
actually become the Switzerland of North
America the only thing that is stopping
us from becoming more awesome is the
federal government that is literally
destroying our wealth a study committee
would be a good compromise between the
positions we heard this morning and just
saying hey we're going to stick our
heads on the sand and do nothing I will
ask you guys to think about any actual
reform that has happened on the federal
level in the last 50 years in fact the
the bill we heard on the USS Liberty
that's 56 and A2 years and these people
are still trying to solve a problem so
you know if we're going to wait I don't
think it's going to do us any well uh do
us well this um we already mentioned the
trillions of dollars the unsustained
debt the fact that the federal
government literally does not respect us
um and we're basically I mean New
Hampshire is almost like District 12 in
the Hunger Game at this stage we just
this little Outpost uh where they're
leaving us while also claiming things
like they own your body and that they
can force you to inject yourself with
things against your will I say no I say
no to the federal government I say it's
time for all of us to reclaim our right
of conscience and support this bill so
that we can start to have the
conversation so that we don't end up in
a mass rush or a panic when the time
comes let's plan let's start to have the
hard conversations now let's grapple
with the real risks that everyone in
this room knows we are actually facing
um if if we let the federal government
go on we are looking at more harm more
poverty and more decline in our
standards of living I know everyone in
this room knows we can do better we
demand better we know there are better
options and it starts with an appetite
for Change and it starts here today with
all of you you know you have to be brave
to do radical things that actually
improve the lives that is how this
country was born and I ask all of you
here today to be brave to start to
actually address the issues that we know
are real I will leave you guys with the
words of my great grandmother who was in
a British concentration camp in South
Africa no one knows that during the
Anglo War the Brits had concentration
camps and they killed
25% of all Bor women and children in
South Africa my great grandmother would
say the five PS proper preparation
prevents poor performance let's plan
let's do it right let's show everyone in
the world that if you sit down and have
the hard conversations we can come up
with solutions that benefit all of us
thank
you uh representative Le has his hand up
uh Mr M G would you take one question I
will thank you chair M well I can tell
you you're in the right committee
because everybody in here is brave
because they signed the dotted line to
give their life to this great country
but I'm still still undecided I mean we
have gone through this in different
variations several times nothing you
just told me has swayed me to think that
succession is succession regardless of
the um
different formalities that you put it
through a lack of a better word the
different um explanations I'm sorry but
I need a little bit more to you know
feel like I've gotten you know the the
uh the answer I need can you do that in
a minute I uh I can do it in the
following way I would love to have that
conversation with you if you vote for
the study commission we can have those
conversations because we're not saying
with the study committee that it's a
it's a given it's saying hey what are
the problems and if we agree these are
the problems what are the
solutions
the best part about not being the chair
is I can hand that over to chair
office um but you
know I I think at a minimum you have to
recognize that the problems we're facing
federally need to be addressed in some
way and so if you have a better idea
than us going independent and of course
Independence and I think this is
important for the committee to stand for
me I look at Independence as a spectrum
right so secession is the farthest
anchor I'm a lawyer by training I
understand negotiation if you want
something maybe you start there so you
can start to incrementally get other
things right so maybe we should be
looking at nullification more
seriously okay the clock is ticking but
uh representative levit you had your
hand up
again you got my vote okay for a
subcommittee yes I'll take
it every thank you any anything else for
the speaker Miss gki Miss G okay thank
you thank you uh every measure gets a a
full executive hearing um and in terms
of uh South Africa I some of us do know
about the the bore experience of the
turn of the century the term
concentration camp came from the English
experience there you also mentioned that
Luxembourg and lonstein were successful
countries uh we don't have time to to
have you elaborate on that but it's good
to know that there are successful
countries all
right uh we are almost caught up it's
almost noon but we're going to uh plung
head and uh represent porcel is here and
I see a hand up uh yes sir can I speak
on
the uh I've already closed that I uh can
you you're welcome please send uh your
sentiments electronically and we will
all see that uh I've already opened a a
new hearing I'm
sorry uh represent Porcelli or portelli
you can uh thank
you all right we are Switching gears
we're talking about special
education thank you chairman Moffett and
committee members I am representative
Susan pelli Rockingham District 19 from
Hampton Falls and
Kensington house current resolution 10
asks our New Hampshire Federal
delegation to increase Federal funding
for special education services to help
reduce our property taxes for our New
Hampshire residents and provide for the
increasing needs of students with dis
disabilities for a context in
1975 Congress passed a comprehensive law
and for improving the outcomes of
children and their families with
disabilities in
1990 the law was reauthorized and
changed to the individuals with
disabilities Education Act or
idea currently the idea federal laws
include services that must be provided
to children with disabilities in
elementary and secondary
schools you may be familiar with some of
these Provisions such as the individual
education programs or
IEPs free appropriate free appropriate
public education requirements least
restrictive environment also known as
mainstreaming and comp comprehensive
assessment and evaluation
processes these Federal mandates are
very expensive to administer and the
idea legislation originally originally
proposed only had funding at
40% however Congress has appropriated
only a fraction of the promised funding
since the bill was reauthorized in 1990
and this resulted in an unfunded mandate
that shifts costs for educating students
with special needs to our states and
local school
districts for example in 2020 the full
40% and again it's only a fraction of
the overall total special need cost the
full 40% represented about $144 million
in New Hampshire only 52 million was
appropriated as a result of the ideal
legislation and that left a funding gap
of 92 million just for the coverage from
the idea
legislation these totals have only
increased dramatically over the past
several years due to the increased
demand for
services because of some of the postco
issues and the Stagger Mental Health
crisis full Federal funding of the idea
legislation must become a priority and
remember this ideal legislation only
covers a subset of the total cost of
special education
needs currently the US House and US
Senate have both proposed bills to
provide 40 the full 40% of the federal
funding for the idea act and these bills
are co-sponsored by our federal
delegation and we're very thankful for
that however the problem with these
bills is that there is a 10year
implementation
timeline to implement only the partial
funding children and taxpayers cannot
wait 10 years for Relief the bulk of the
cost of special education services is
downshifted onto local property
taxpayers many school districts must
make difficult decisions regarding
hiring professionals providers or
eliminating general education
programs 26 New Hampshire Public School
Districts spend over
25% of their total School Budget on
special education costs this includes
Provisions that are not covered by the
ideal legislation such as instruction
related Services Administration legal
and
transportation so far I have followed
the chain of command to raise the issue
by speaking with local SAU business
administrators the New Hampshire state
director of special education Becky fet
the New Hampshire education commissioner
Frank edbl and staff from both of our
Senators and both of our US House
Representatives in addition to Granite
State taxpayers
Association they all agree that Federal
funding is a top priority for New
Hampshire children Educators and
taxpayers where does that leave us
today the purpose of this house
concurrent resolution is to seek
bipartisan support to help communicate a
unified message in support of our
federal delegation to fully fund at 100%
without the 10-year timeline the idea
2.0 act in addition as a bipartisan tool
this resolution will Aid our federal
delegation to procure funding from the
$80 billion budget of the US Department
of Education to come back to New
Hampshire's special education while
these Federal bills are debated and as
we know there is no guarantee of
Passage therefore I respectfully ask ask
for unanimous bipartisan support of this
HCR and recommend ought to pass to send
a strong and unified message so this
bill can be moved to the consent
calendar thank you and I'll take any
questions thank you represent questions
for the prime
sponsor uh represent
LE thank you chair M how much is
currently funded um by the federal
government how much of it is currently
funded right now 80% correct no it's a
very small portion right now that's
maybe 18% between the uh federal and
state government and you're looking for
100 uh of the idea funding so it's 82%
increase well this is what was
originally esed yes and you want that
all federal no State involved right well
this is the legislation that we're
currently under this is the Mandate that
we're currently under from this
legislation so we're looking to
eliminate the unfunded mandate okay so
of course that's going to have to be
funded somehow as a taxpayer I mean to
the government I mean where the from the
80 billion current budget from the US
Department of Education so you want to
take it out of there and what's the
current budget definitely not to
increase our debt or deficit but to
allocate right from our current um
expenditure from the US Department of
Education is the act no I understand
that so where are we at now on the 80
billion we above Beyond are we are we
asking for more in the next ter yeah is
that being used now or do we have like
six billion and you know save that's the
federal US Department I know I
understand that do you I I I believe
fully that working with our delegation
we could definitely find the funding
within that 80 billion to evaluate where
funds can be moved into special
representative pedmont is uh talking in
my ear so I'm going to let him take over
if that's okay with you chair off it
represent pman go
ahead F follow up representative go
ahead all right uh yes representative
Philo thank you for taking my question
would passing this bill allow
communities to reduce the Reliance on
local property taxes and potentially
reduce those local property taxes it
that is one of the outcomes that should
be a result of passing the ideas act
fully funded without the 10-year
implementation yes it should have a
direct impact on property
taxes other questions for the prime
sponsor rep representative yes
representative cber yeah does this
legislation um involve any change to the
per pupil amount that is um currently in
place sted the current adequacy Formula
it this leg this particular HCR only
asks our federal delegation to fund what
is currently mandated so the discussion
about education funding in the state of
New Hampshire you may have heard
recently that our speaker has formed uh
a commission or a study committee to
look at all of the different funding
requirements so there are this is just
to eliminate the unfunded Mandate of the
current legislation so there no no
changes this is where we are
currently thank you other questions for
the prime
sponsor uh rep representative kery
former School Board member yes for for
18 years I was a school board member and
and our special ed uh payments are about
16% not even
18% and I do know our Department of
Education here in New Hampshire is 100%
funded by federal funds so um I'm
wondering if after and it has been
decades that we have not ever seen that
40% from the federal government correct
there is something different that will
be done to move the
needle is there passing this um
hopefully P having our federal
delegation change the parameters to pass
the new idea 2.0 bill which would
provide 100% of the funding over you
know not a 10-year timeline but as soon
as the bill is passed will have a direct
impact on every school district and
property tax owner in New Hampshire as
you know these costs have absolutely
escalated just from 2020 to 2023 the
costs have almost doubled and just BEC
just because there may be less I mean
these costs are very hard to anticipate
PE families move in and out of the
district so this portion of a school
budget is very hard to be predictive and
just because maybe um there are less
children requiring special needs
services that absolutely does not mean
that the overall budget would go down so
these funds are absolutely critical to
many of our
communities other questions for the
prime
sponsor
singing new hands thank you represent
Peli uh I've also been on a school board
and I very much relate to the the
special ed Dynamic okay I have four pink
cards here uh three of them are from
State reps two of the state
representatives only asked for two
minutes and of course the fact that
we're past noon we're almost caught up
so uh I look forward I'm going to go to
representative dry who would ask for two
minutes um welcome representative dry
Margaret Dy from planfield great to see
you I know you know a lot about
education and uh welcome thank you very
much thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee um I am Margaret dry uh
representative from Sullivan district 7
which is planfield Cornish Newport unity
and Charlestown and I'm a co-sponsor of
this bill U on the education committee
we hear from everybody uh teachers
students parents administrators
Department of Ed taxpayers and whenever
I can I ask the question how much of the
40% reimbursement for special ed that
you're supposed to get does your school
district get and I always get the same
reaction they roll their eyes they give
a nervous Giggle and they say not much
and I would say probably 17 is about the
percent is about the the number that I
usually get um but think of all the
Hoops that special ed requirements
require uh teachers par educators
equipment paperwork regulations and more
uh why do we go through all the trouble
of jumping through all these hoops if
we're only going to get half of the
money that we were promised or entitled
to um I guess maybe because a little bit
is better than nothing but I have to ask
um everywhere else in life if two
parties are in a contract and one party
rigs on their part of the contract then
the contract is null and void and the
requirement
aren't required anymore yet we continue
to do our part and comply with special
ed
regulations so yesterday was the first
day of a special subcommittee on
education funding and one of the bills
we're looking at is one that would raise
the adequacy part of special ed from
$2,100 per student to
$27,000 per
student if we are even going to think
about doing something like that we
better make sure that all the holes in
our equation for funding are plugged and
our federal reimbursement for special ed
is one of these
holes and that's why I'm supporting this
bill our federal de delegation is
precisely the first place to start when
we're dealing with federal dollars and
so I hope you will join me in supporting
this resolution thank you and I'm happy
to answer any questions thank you R Dr
questions say on thank you for your
testimony the $27,000 figure is uh an
attention getter thank you have a good
lunch representative
Nelson from dairy
is is here with us thank thank you for
coming in representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you to the committee for hearing my
testimony um those were two great hard
uh acts to follow and I'm going to keep
it brief as I know that you're stomachs
are probably growling you had a long
morning um I am Jody Nelson representing
Rockingham 13 Derry um in Derry
consistently over several years um of
research that I've done um special ed
funding has been and is
presently approximately 20% of our total
School
budget the dairy school board has
proposed
103.4 million budget for next year and
of course as all of you know 25% of that
is obviously a very significant amount
fulfilling promises made by the federal
government regarding special education
funding would be a much needed relief to
our property taxpayers in
Dairy thank you for your
time are there any questions for
representative
Nelson CA thank you so much for coming
in okay our last two cards uh uh Eric
power and Diane power representative
Dian power how about can we invite you
both to come up as we finish and uh you
can
sit in tandem or or representative
representative is going to go first
okay well welcome thank you Mr chairman
and committee members so as a co-sponsor
I appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you today and to deliver my testimony in
support of
hcr1 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville in
Hillsboro County District 36
today by way of example I'd like to
Simply offer you a snapshot of special
education in my house district in an
effort to illustrate why hcr1 is needed
and there's a handout associated with
what I'm going to speak to so um look
referring to my handout in the middle of
that I have a chart so in my um house
district there are three towns and there
are four school districts um in those
three towns so as you can see from from
the chart Brookline that's the town that
I'm from there's two school districts
and then the other two remaining towns
that I represent they have one school
district
each so um following along in the chart
the N the percentage of students out of
the total student population that are
identified and receive special education
services it ranges in anywhere from in
the brook line K through 6 School
District 20 approximately 21% of the
total student
population um and on the low end in
Mason it's uh almost 12% of the total
student
population so these figures represent if
you look at the last column A A A change
in the percentage of students receiving
special education services for um from
fiscal year
20 um it's an increase of about 30% in
the Brookline K through six school
district and um you can also see for the
msic regional in which is the town of
Greenville that's a similar um
increase and so looking at the fiscal
year 25 special education costs you see
that for these school
districts that budget is running
anywhere from from um almost $6 million
on the high end to
646 um on the low end and for the fiscal
year 25 the
state is contributing to the special Aid
um cost you can see the figures there
and from the state in additional it a
school district can apply for
catastrophic Aid and that's repres
presented um in that middle
column so with regards to the federal
aid that we are expected to get in these
four different school districts as you
can see um compared to that first the
fiscal year 25 sped costs and the
estimated federal aid um it ranges
anywhere from in the Hollis Brook line
Co-op
$821,000
to 93 th
$93,000 for Mason so what this means is
that the amount of special education
services that need to be funded at the
local level for the towns or the dis
school
districts that I represent
locally the funding that needs to be
raised and appropriated as you can see
Brookline 74% Hollis Brookline co-ops 7
5% Mason 81% and the mic Regional which
is Greenville
70% so um it's it's clear if by looking
at the data in this chart that state and
federal special ed Aid covers only a
fraction of the total special ed costs
and this burden affects both specialed
students as well well as reg regular
education
students and this is unsustainable for
the
taxpayers in the three years um since
fiscal year 2020 three of the four
school districts in Hillsboro 36 as as I
mentioned have experienced increases in
the number of students identified and
receiving special ed um and the other
point that I would like to make in my
town Brookline um the Brookline planning
board recently conducted a survey
Brookline Community survey in the fall
of
2023 in order to inform that board
regarding the master plan moving forward
and in that survey that was conducted
both online and inperson submissions
they asked the residents to select their
top three
concerns with regards to the town 70% of
the respondents listed local town taxes
as their top concern as you can see by
the the bar graph there and
41% of
respondents said that they're concerned
about the decline in the quality um of
of our
schools and
um what this means is that with regards
to the increasing you know property
taxes taxpayers are concerned about
their ability to stay in Brookline to be
able to afford that and then also with
increasing School budgets you know it's
it's having a negative impact on the
quality of the um education that we're
able to deliver to all
students so um in
conclusion hcr1 sends an important
message to the United States Congress
the president and our New Hampshire
Congressional Delegation that New
Hampshire is is in urgent need of the
promised Federal share of specialed
funding as soon as possible therefore I
urge this committee to vote ought to
pass on hcr1 in support of both Granite
State
taxpayers and to our
students receiving both special ed and
our regular students thank you Mr
chairman that concludes my testimony
thank you representative and thank you
it's always helpful to get metrics and
numbers and graphs like like you've put
together here thank you for that
questions uh representative Lev thank
you chair Mo and I promise I won't get
into a debate with the representative
because we were we do um debate but I'm
I'm voting a yes on this I think it's
great um you know I truly think that
special ed is
probably going to
increase exponentially did I say that
correct EXP um and with with the and U
with society today is the um stress that
are are put upon um these state and
local governments for funding is huge so
if if we can get
this um taken care of the majority of it
really quick to the federal government I
think that would be
awesome uh repr see
would you support us looking into taking
money from the current voucher build
which is growing exponentially and
moving it to help fund this at the state
level thank you for the question
representative so this to me that that's
not Germaine to to the scope of this
bill this HCR simply sends an message to
the to the federal government that they
need to
support this special ed funding that
that's essentially a a partially
unfunded mandate the the answer to your
question would would you know that has
to do with other legislation and um I
don't see it pertaining to this Bill
thank you other
questions uh representative
kry um do you see with the increase in
your own community and LED population an
opportunity missed by the federal
government to provide supplemental
funding due to children who are
essentially victims of the opioid crisis
in other words they were born to uh
parents who have addictions that then
have caused their special ed
situations thank you for the question
representative I I'm a State Rep and I I
focus on state legislation so I I I'm
not elected to federal office therefore
I I I would have no comment at the at
this
time other
questions seeing none that brings us to
uh Mr Eric power the the final pink card
of the morning uh Mr power
welcome thank you U my name is Eric
power I live in
Brookline and I'm going to speak in
support of
hcr1 and I have a handout that's coming
around um as we talked about today
special education is a mostly unfunded
mandate by the by the federal and the
state government um and it's negatively
impacting both special education and
regular education you heard about that
from the previous
speaker um one of the big problems is
that we have a conflict because we're
getting this Federal mandate for
individuals with disabilities Education
Act
Ida and not not getting it fully
funded and we have our new hampster
Constitution part one article 2A which
prohibits State unfunded mandates we got
a federal unfunded mandate but the
state's also contributing to making us
do this as
well this the federal government as you
heard is supposed to fund about
40% of special education costs but they
only fund it about 14% so they're only
meeting about onethird of what they
promised and um local taxpayers have to
pick up much of the cost it creates a CH
challenge for school boards and budget
committees to provide a proper education
to their students just as a bit of a
background I served on the Hollis
Brookline Cooperative school board for a
term for three years so I have firsthand
experience with this with this problem
and I also serve on the brook currently
a member of the Brookline planning board
where we're seeing the problems with the
growth and you know the housing and one
of the major problems is education
growth EXP expenses and part of that is
being driven by special education so I
I've seen this
upfront um the number of public
education students is growing and it's
growing at an alarming rate over the
past three years um if you look
Statewide we've had an increase about
15.7% of students have been more
students have been identified as
students with disabilities and are
receiving special education services
the graph I have here kind of shows sort
of a histogram of where you know
breaking it down by five percentiles
where the increases are occurring and
you can see in the red that you know
we're seeing a lot more the red as the
increases and you see you know we had 26
that have seen a 15 to 20% increase so
we've had quite a bit of uh demand while
the federal government is is continuing
not to to carry the fair share that they
promised us it's a big challenge people
have hypo hypothesis about the cause of
this some people blame it to the
opioid uh problems that we've had some
blame it on the remote learning and the
and the pandemic response they probably
are all contributors to this problem but
the point is is that we're getting
higher and higher demands for this uh
for this uh for special education and
we're not getting the assistance from
the federal government that was
promised I was at our deliber session or
our budget hearing earlier this uh
earlier this week and we looked going
through the default budget and it was
very disconcerting that everything that
was special ed it was over 27% of our
budget we couldn't touch we just
automatically have to pay for it no
local control it's just that's the bill
and you have to pay it look at the other
parts of the bill so we were forced to
look at the regular education Parts if
any cuts are
needed the the local school district
urgently need the federal government to
meet their special education commitment
to support our sped students and our
taxpayers in New Hampshire so I please
ask that you recommend OTP on hcr1 and
thank you for your time thank you Mr
power as I alluded to earlier as a
former School Board member like ripson
of K and others the this is something
that's been out there a long time and uh
it can only help to shine a light on it
questions for Mr
power ripo
Cary are you aware of how many uh outof
District placements or they're called
$100,000 placements your school district
is now having to engage in I did I did
ask that question and they wanted they
were hesitant to do it but I know it was
a small number um they wouldn't give me
a specific number but my estimate would
be it would be less than five but those
are those are challenging and you do get
some state aid for that um you get the
catastrophic aid but it doesn't kick in
until uh if you didn't see the last two
days ago they released the numbers for
the cost per pupil that they're going to
use for all the formulas it I think it
was 20,000 about
20,300 so your catastrophic
Aid um at the 10x level would not kick
in until the district has already
coughed up about $200,000 but in some of
that from above $70,000 you'll be paying
about only 20% so 0 to 70 you pay uh the
full amount then 70 to 200 you pay 20%
and above that the state pays the rest
but that Gap is is is the problem the if
you if you're not aware it's about
$28,000 extra
Statewide that special education costs
School District so if you're talking
about 20,000 then you got 28,000 so a
special ed student is costing local CL
costing a total burden of about $488,000
a year and that's not a small amount and
that's why the problem is so
large so cber I just have one question
thank you for taking my question um are
there any other identified like states
that have had this same issue and have
used this as a
solution I'm not aware if they have the
same solution but the the problem is
Nationwide is my understanding so we're
not alone it's just there has to be the
will at the federal government to put
the money behind the mandate and that's
the problem here um so that in Hampshire
we're not getting any more or less
percentage wise we're still one of the
problems but we should tell our
delegation they're the ones that are a
voice up in in Washington to to get that
money out of that 80 billion get it to
fund the specialed properly there's
certainly some waste there in my opinion
that we could that could be tapped
into agree with that other
questions c n thank you Mr
power
and saying No the pink cards and things
have thinned out I will end that hearing
now at this time uh we're almost caught
up I know we're well into the noon time
hour we have one more measure this
morning there is one pink card there is
one sponsor uh and that is me I'm going
to uh and before I hand the the uh the
gavl over to the vice chair Rollins I
want to thank you all for uh for being
here and for it's been quite a morning
and and uh we've gotten through it I
think the afternoon will be different
and and we'll go right through the
afternoon I think you never know uh we
will start at 1:00 on time or I will I
know uh once we finish this last item uh
if some of you need more time and and
can't get back from one o'clock I
completely understand uh I will start
the afternoon hearings at 1 and uh if if
like I said if you need extra time uh
that that's fine of course okay I'm
going to turn my mic
off okay I'd like to open up the hearing
on hr20 we have a prime sponsor
representative Mike Moffett and I like
to have hear your
testimony thank you Mr Vice chair uh
hr20 is a resolution on uh Taiwan and to
just quickly go through this for the
record uh I'm representative Mike
Moffett representing marac District 4
lovely towns of canterberry and Lowden
this resolution simply affirms the
long-standing friendship and mutually
beneficial relationship between the
United States including New Hampshire
one of the states uh and the Republic of
China or
Taiwan uh New Hampshire has about a quar
billion dollars worth of business with
Taiwan and companies like Timberland
depend on continuing in positive trade
environment and this already positive
relationship can be further enhanced
with with license reciprocity which is
in the resolution and more peopl to-
people exchanges like uh for those who
want to learn Mandarin for example uh
full disclosure I was part of a New
England legislative delegation invited
to Taiwan in
October uh that visit included numerous
briefings and tours and I was greatly
impressed by the freedom and the
economic vital Vitality I saw firsthand
in
Taiwan um Taiwan is evolved from the
autocratic state it was over 40 years
ago one of the sessions we had in Taiwan
was at a prison where where they used to
torture people which was an eye opener
it was an autocratic state was not a
democracy over 40 years ago
but it is now a vibrant democracy today
in fact the country is hosting free
elections
tomorrow uh which the world is watching
and some of you understand uh why so our
relationship with Taiwan is Complicated
by the fact that we discouraged or
discontinued full diplomatic relations
with the ROC the Republic of China with
Taiwan in 1979 when we recognized the
PRC the people's repu communist People's
Republic of China
so American policy since then is to have
an embassy in Beijing not taipe although
we have trade relations and
liaison activities we don't formally
recognize Taiwan So It's Tricky uh but
our American policy has been to oppose
any violent military action or invasion
of Taiwan by the PRC in fact President
Biden more than once has said the
commanderin-chief has said that uh he
would
uh fight for Taiwan whether you grew
that or not uh that is the state of
policy of the commander-in-chief so it
is a little bit tricky many of us hope
that eventually the PRC and the r can
resolve the differences and possibly
unite peacefully like uh ger happened in
Germany after the fall of European
communism but such unification does not
appear imminent as long as
the PRC the People's Republic of China
remains a Communist
dictatorship communist China has shown
its true colors its red colors time and
again as it's emerged as a prominent
geopolitical threat to the region to our
country to our allies to the cause of
Freedom so the PRC People's Republic of
China needs to know that the forces of
Freedom will stand firm until such time
as the PRC evolves into a more
pluralistic entity and I'm saying this
to the the group in here not a large
group but uh I know we know that my
words are being heard will be heard uh
in a lot of
places and they matter and what we do
know is that European Communism
collapsed suddenly and unexpectedly
after 1989 and um we never expected that
never saw that coming never dreamed
actually those of us who are long enough
old enough to remember the 1980s never
dreamed I didn't that suddenly communism
would collapse and then suddenly it did
in Europe so you never know what could
happen um supposedly when the PRC
absorbed Hong Kong in
1997 uh Beijing was going to
respect the free Traditions that marked
Hong Kong's experiences was a British
Crown Colony unfortunately the
Communists riged on their agreements and
now Hong Kong uh does not have what they
were supposed to have which was a
measure of autonomy a measure of
Freedom so for now Taiwan needs and
deserves support as it seeks to maintain
its island of
freedom and this resolution affirms our
support for that democracy if this
resolution moves forward will anyone
care or notice uh yes
uh again I have no doubt this is this
will be online uh that uh the folks in
the PRC uh would be acutely aware of of
my testimony and if this does uh move
forward in the full house uh will it
matter uh I think so those of us who
visited Taiwan and and care about that
Nation not being taken over or ruined uh
support support
this so uh I hope that when this does
get to Executive session that my
honorable committee colleagues will give
this resolution their fullest
consideration and I'd be happy to take
questions if there are
any do we have any
questions thank you to the chair and to
the
chair um just just one question for you
um in our effort to to improve relations
around the world and to um expand our
you know trade Horizons and our our um
peace agreements can you envision um
with with China being so hostile about
the independence of Taiwan can you
envision that the more that we um
conduct relations with Taiwan that
eventually if they were to to to gain
independence completely from China that
they would call for armed
conflict that's a a good question thank
you represent any further question um
tomorrow is an election in taiwwan and
has having been there I I'm tuned in a
little bit to the Dynamics and the
current Ru ruling party is much more
independent-minded than the previous
part of the Colman Tang who used to rule
so if if the Pres ruling uh party wins
election tomorrow uh there is a movement
there that wants to uh no longer claim
that they're a province of Greater China
that they would be an independent um
nation and are are there folks who want
that yes there are over there is that
the best way to go I I don't know um I I
think to your point that the people who
want full autonomy know that the
People's Republic of China said that
that would be caused for war they're
already threatening War so I don't know
if
uh we we'll know more after the election
tomorrow but uh yes I think there are
people that are ready for conflict and I
think most of us don't want to see
that one one other point I need to make
about Taiwan if you're not aware of this
but Taiwan is like the the pl the place
they're very smart about uh they the
advanced semiconductors that everything
depends on
uh they manufacture like
75% of the the entire world's uh uh
supply of advanced semiconductors if if
Taiwan went to war uh all of a sudden
our computers microwaves anything that
needs Advanced semiconductors uh would
be in Jeopardy big big time so in a way
that's a a they call a silicon shield
for Taiwan the fact that they
manufacture manufacture these
semiconductors that are crucial even red
China needs these semiconductors so any
that's another piece of it but thank you
for that question I hope I touched on it
somewhat any other
questions thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr M for taking my question um I I
was in Hong Kong shortly uh before they
uh Chinese took over there and uh I was
talking with her he brought this up so I
just give you a brief story I was
talking with one of the local uh
businessmen there and I asked him how he
felt and if he thought this was possible
he says it like a light switch you flick
the switch and the Chinese will take
over tomorrow you've got a same
situation in Taiwan which I also went to
um and uh the most valuable part again
is that uh those semiconductors that are
are there um do you think that this is I
think I will support your your your
motion your uh bill here but do you
think this is a little too late and the
process is already starting for them to
take over Taiwan thank you for your
question uh the mainland Chinese have
had War plans forever and those of you
who've been in the military know that
there's all kinds of plans that are in
place that often times will never be
used uh and I've seen some of the
defense plans on the War uh if the red
Chinese were to attack uh this has been
war game to death uh but one point I do
want to make is that unlike Hong Kong
Taiwan has a very big anti-tank ditch
around it uh kind of like England had
during World War II um and so the
logistics and and the challenges of of
Crossing 100 miles of ocean water um is
really uh problematical uh so I I having
been there and studied this a little bit
I think that the Taiwanese have a
defense plan in place they they've got
some sophisticated uh air defenses and
and they have some Advanced
Fighters uh so if red China did invade
it would be uh very ugly uh so I think
it's a little much it's much harder
because of the Ocean than it was for
Hong Kong and uh
and I think the more time that goes by
it's the harder it's going to be for
demographic reasons for economic reasons
uh for the Communist Chinese to to
invade but um I know they have plans and
we watch and wait and again tomorrow is
the election and that'll we'll know a
lot more after
tomorrow yes go ahead thank you
represent Vice chair Rollins
um I wasn't going to let you get off the
hook um follow up to representative
pedmont
um you know it with with we're doing
this on the state
level would you agree that this would
be very
well very well taken up in Congress if
this is something we can get
done thank you for the question do I
think this is something that could be
also taken up in Congress in addition to
to here in conquer yes and I know that
Congress for decades has played paid
close attention to Taiwan and like the
delegation that I was part of there were
I was in a legislative delegation there
are congressional delegations that are
con con there uh speaker Pelosi famously
made a stop in Taiwan that got uh even
more attention than my trip gut uh and
that makes a statement that that uh when
we visit it that we are committed that
we
care and uh should something happen uh
concurrently in DC I think so so yes I
think it is in different ways just the
fact that we have all these trade
agreements in on the from Washington
also from the state levels uh to include
uh as I mentioned New Hampshire
bilateral with with New Hampshire thank
you for the question and thank you for I
didn't expect any questions at lunchtime
so I I'm impressed thank you thank you
for that question do we have any other
further questions see no other further
question I'm sun over there so I can't
even see you how was the food how was
the food there seriously question was
how is the food there was uh fantastic
I'm a terrible food critic because I've
never been to a restaurant that I did
not like but I uh I thought the food was
great thank you for the question and the
PE by the way the people were wonderful
it it's a place where they love
Americans and that was refreshing uh
streets were clean didn't see gang
violence or graffiti beautiful plus it
was warm which was nice for for those of
us who like warmth thank you for the
question any further
questions see no more further questions
representative mofet thank you so much
excellent job I now close the hearing on
hr20 uh quick reminder as the
representative said we'll go starting
back up at 1:00 if you take longer
that's fine we want to stick to the
schedule so do what you got to do and
we'll see you when you get back 18
minutes
right folks as I said earlier this being
veterans committee we will start on time
I excused uh the some of the other
members we ran um the our seccession
measure this morning had a lot a lot of
people that we wanted to honor their
presence and let them speak so we were a
little behind but we're caught up it's
uh 1300 hours and uh this is all on uh
YouTube and the uh members uh will be
filtering back in uh momentarily but I
do want to start on time and I want to
go to the sponsor uh representative
Horgan is here welcome rips of uh Horgan
and we are now going to to uh HB 1179
this is relative to the state park
system fees for retired members of the
Armed Forces uh represent Horgan is the
prime sponsor welcome and uh so uh tell
us about your measure good afternoon Mr
chairman thank you for allowing me to
introduce this bill HB 1179 has one
purpose and that is to uh Grant
complimentary access to retired
military uh and uh the numbers here have
provided come from Massachusetts and New
Hampshire uh we use that because uh
division of parks uh assumes that the
majority of the visitors to the park use
system is uh from those two
states
uh the uh numbers that we used uh they
averaged that the active duty visits
were're running about 3,300 a year uh so
we use that number to do our calculation
uh and we come up with roughly
uh
15,8 potential
retirees at a cost of I'm sorry that was
$1 15,8
16 uh uh out of uh
23,25
retirees so if you look at the fiscal
note that was provided it says
361,000
and I believe that number
includes disabled veterans and other
categories of veterans that are already
being granted free access to deuse Parx
our number that 16,000 or 15,000 deals
strictly with the number of retired
military members we want to add to the
complimentary uh access to deuse box not
a complicated Bill the numbers are not
very big big and we're looking at
$115,000 as opposed to
361,000
okay and can I are you ready for a
question I am okay I'm I'm looking at
the uh the wording in in it's a very
short measure but I see that the
original from from this RSA
2116-a 3-g
uh section uh paragraph 1 Section B
that's that's the line that was has been
eliminated I think I understand why but
is is now this would apply to any
retired member of the Armed Forces as
defining F Federal
Regulations so by adding that I assume
that
makes section B uh that's been lined out
makes that section
um unnecessary is that is that fair to
say okay I'm looking not looking at the
same item that you
are but the
uh numbers we're dealing with is uh of
retirees is
23,25
total uh using 300 uh 3,300 as the uh
the number of visits we come up with a
cost
of
$1,816 and we are talking specifically
of retired military members members of
the armed forces that
qualify legally and uh honorably
discharged
uh that are not on in any other category
in it Regard in regardless a rank or uh
service that makes
sense yeah I'm looking I'm trying to
process this and I know there'll be
other people who will speak to
it yeah I got Mr power coming up behind
me and he's pretty well versed in this
stuff he's he's got the more attractive
U you got on the desk yeah that and
maybe they can speak to that line and
also to the uh to the the change in
Revenue funds that on the fiscal
note okay other
questions for the prime sponsor for
representative
Horan representative Rollins yeah you
say sorry got it uh you're saying
retired that's 20 years plus service
well there was a time when you could get
out for good behavior 196 if you re if
you reenlisted early you if you made it
some time but they have to be officially
retired and typically that's 20 20 plus
okay thank you does that all followup
question sure so that does not include
someone who has serve four six 10 years
in the service and they and they get out
of the service that does not include
them they're just a they're just a
veteran unless they disabled or over 65
and qualify by other means all right
very good thank you thank you for
that other questions for the prime
sponsor okay thank you representative
organ
um represent
Mel from miramac
welcome Good Friday afternoon thank you
Mr
chairman hopefully you're your day has
gone smoothly so I'm here as a
co-sponsor proud co-sponsor of this to
support our veterans and correct an
unintentional carve out that we have an
existing law so I think you're all
familiar if you're an active active duty
member of the Armed Forces you get
complimentary admission if you're over
65 you get complimentary admission but
if you're under 65 and hap happen to
have happen to be one of those one in
six roughly uh Armed Forces members who
are actually retired status you don't
get a free pass to our beautiful places
in New Hampshire the state parks so it's
a bit of a small uh about that I'm sure
is there unintentionally and this bill
corrects that it'll cost us actually my
written testimony says it's about one
sixth of the FIS fiscal note uh because
we they used numbers that included all
visitors from Mass and New Hampshire and
so
$360,000 I think was the estimated cost
and the number of those that are
estimated to be actually retired status
is about uh one and six I'm I've since
been corrected it's actually less than
that so really 152 ,000 is what we're
talking about to allow some of our most
valued members uh of the armed services
those that have served 20 years and
achieved retired status uh but who are
still under 65 this will uh give them
admission to enjoy those places the very
places that many of them fought to
defend so I think it's a a a fitting
fitting thing to do for our veterans
since they often uh gave great sacrifice
for purposes of keeping those lands free
and our land free so
thank you representative uh if I may ask
you've already addressed this so the the
$360,000 figure was a little bit of a
attention getter but you explained that
that's uh really not
accurate you say it's really more like a
six of that given the way it's figured
even less so I did rough math figuring
that about I I had learned that
approximately one in six members
actually achieve retired status so I
just did quick math divided by six I'm
told it's actually even less than that
uh and that the LBA LBA will have a look
at it and you know of course finance
will consider very carefully dollar for
dollar uh but it's considerably less and
I think we've already known but didn't
have time to have the fiscal note
revised in terms of the uh the timing of
introduction and whatnot um but I'm sure
chairman wer will have a and his
division chairman will have a close look
at the actual number which I believe to
be around $15 $20,000
thank you so much for that because uh I
it's significant to learn that the
fiscal note overstated the uh the impact
by uh over 80% that's that's pretty
significant it honestly it was an
attention grabber for me as a co-sponsor
when I saw it because of course you
generally agree to co-sponsor before you
see the fiscal notes many times those
come in well after you signed off on the
bill yep such was the case here so it
was a bit of a attention grabber for me
uh and I did make a couple phone calls
and said wait a minute what about this
one in six I thought there weren't that
many retirees that this actually
affected and so I checked with my
contacts at uh MOA and esac and and I'm
I'm pretty pretty sure on the numbers
and I actually know there's at least
another rep and another interested party
uh behind me who will probably break
that down in great
detail well thank you for that any any
other questions for represent M go yes
represent Rollins thank you Mr chairman
uh just a question from my constituents
what will they have to show for ID in
order to get into these state parks uh
that's a good question I'm sure DD214
would do it but I'm not really sure uh
what else I I know there is another
military idea but uh not having had the
privilege of serving myself I think you
just just the military ID and I bet
representative Manion can tell me and
certainly uh colon moffa could tell me
as well thank
you other
questions thank you
representative uh Paul Lloyd is here I
just saw him there he is he's in the
house representing the VFW actually is
the chair of esvac State veterans
advisory committee Al also a VFW member
W welcome Mr thank you thank you uh for
the record my name is Paul Lloyd I'm the
chairman of the state veterans advisory
committee I'm here today to um give our
position on this bill uh this esvac is
um supporting of this and support of
this while we don't always want to make
it appear that we're only after money
when we come up to testify we think this
position helps our retiree families and
makes New Hampshire a place that people
want to visit and retire too thank
you excellent succinct testimony uh Mr
Lloyd questions for the esac
chair c n I thank you for coming in uh I
have a pink card here from uh is it Bri
Brian Wilson is is it is that Brian like
Brian voice
music you've never heard that before
have you Mr
Wilson good afternoon Mr chairman
committee members um I'm Brian Wilson
I'm the division director parks
Recreation overseeing uh the New
Hampshire State Park system uh apologies
for uh coming in a little late there was
something up the hill that uh gave us a
little reroute on our way down here uh
just a minute ago um I um we're we're
we're happy to um provide some uh
testimony uh on um on this bill here uh
this afternoon um I'm going to I'm not
going to read uh ver ver verbatim into
the record here um every everything
that's that's in here but um the general
nature of uh what we're providing is
informational purposes uh laying out the
intent of uh the structure of the state
park system uh in its uh self-funding
model uh in in in essence uh so folks
are familiar with uh our our whole
entire operation is funded through the
revenue that we receive through uh
admission uh through the visitors who
come to our Parks whether to visit deuse
or to go camping or through concessions
and other uh ancillary uh revenue
streams um so we're we're very uh
cognizant of uh taking a hard look
through our fee package about the um
both our rate structure uh and trying to
maintain as uh uh an accessible Park
system for both residents uh and
visitors alike uh to to be able to um um
have as lowcost entry as we can but also
uh to support uh the the the cost of our
operation to be able to maintain uh that
Park system and improve on the park
system um so um really the the testimony
that's here today is just informational
with respect to providing uh some uh
examples of uh the the statutory
language that that speaks to that uh
while we're not in it's not set up to be
uh en ly self-funded U that that is the
reality of of it and um so anytime uh
there's um an opportunity to look at um
expanding our complimentary visitation
for uh for other user groups um we we
want to make sure that we're just kind
of you know taking a close look at that
and understand the impact a couple of
the things that I heard as I came into
the room here where um one was in
respect to uh the fiscal note um our our
numbers there were were based on a
methodology um of the maximum Financial
impact that that could be imposed here I
would agree uh with some of the the uh
former the prior testimony there that um
the the reality of that would be a much
much less uh impact um than than the
absolute maximum that we um put our
methodology in the fiscal note on so um
I think that's a a valid point to to
bring up uh the other uh question uh
thank you rep Rollins for asking
um we could certainly use some clarity
on uh what would be the inacceptable
form of documentation for uh for
entrance into the park if this were to
move forward one of the most challenging
things that we face um and I've been
there many times is actually sitting and
serving in one of our uh Park entrance
booths um and uh the variety of things
that come at our staff for that in terms
of um you know we're we're we're just
coming in from you know the car that was
in front of us or we have this pass or
this different form of identification if
it's not clear or concise it often
results in um either an uncomfortable
interaction us not having the ability to
collect uh where we might have been
otherwise or turning people around uh
and and an impact on the visitor
experience or um just kind of backing up
the line to get into parks on a busy day
as well too so if there is uh something
a documentation or something that's
specific to retired uh military that
could be added to the language uh that
would absolutely be very helpful for us
as well
too thank you for that questions for Mr
Wilson uh representative levit so it
says here that um it's it's I'm sorry
thank you uh by um chair mofet for
taking my question thank you so this is
just for retirees veterans I mean I'm a
bet I I show my card they like let me in
it's just retirees don't get access to
these our our our current fee package
includes uh active military yeah uh and
disabled veterans okay right so this
would add I'm sorry I'm jumping in here
but would add re retired and just
veterans or disabled veterans I know
disabled already get in I understand
that but that's just for for the retired
do not do not at this time correct okay
thank you thank you for answering that
that's correct any other
questions thank you Mr Brian Wilson
thank
you okay
for 1179 that's the last pink card that
I have is is there anyone else who uh Mr
power for
okay uh Eric please come up uh that
that's in a uh a different a different
stack so uh recognizing again Mr Eric
power uh welcome
back thank you everyone my name is uh
Eric power I'm from the town of
Brookline and I also served in the uh
the Air Force for 30 years um from 19
1988 till
2018 uh 28 of those years in the Air
National Guard and two years in the Air
Force
Reserve um so I wanted to just go
through a little bit of the calculation
you had some you had some perspective
here from some of the other testimony
but um I'm going to talk through the gra
this paper here that has the pie chart
um so if you look at New Hampshire
veterans
today you see that only about 9,500 of
the veterans are actually
um
retirees active members under New
Hampshire law under active members that
are four years of service and continuing
to serve are considered Veterans as well
that that's about 3,800 or 3,900 and
then you have about 85,000 that are
veterans that are NE not active nor
retired and then in down in the left I
show that we have about 1,600 members
that are active members of the military
they're they haven't reached four years
of service yet so they aren't quite
veterans but uh just to keep it in mind
that RSA
2150 um describes and I have it listed
here about who is a veteran in New
Hampshire um
currently active service members
regardless of years of service get
admission to the state parks the DAT the
day use admission for free as du
disabled
veterans um just as a fact and I think
uh uh one of the state reps had
previously mentioned Nationwide into New
Hampshire if you when you join the
military
most people do not make it to retirement
about 1 in six or 1 in seven actually
makes it to the 20 years of service they
qualify uh to uh be
retired I just want to talk a little
about the fiscal note they talk about
the average number of visits per member
being 2.65 it's really not a reasonable
assumption um and I'll talk about that
why in a minute based on some data that
came from the park service itself in
prior
testimony keep in mind that current
National Guard member MERS that are E6
and below that have retired just from
the New Hampshire National Guard Army
your air um Can currently get
admission um no other retirees however
can and we already talked about disabled
veterans so there's some testimony and
the the the the page from the testimony
is on the last page but it shows that in
the last year available data in
2019 they uh State Park wide in New
Hampshire 3,300 one complimentary
entries were given to active military
the fiscal note that's in there also
assumes that the rate that the active
military would use the parks would scale
to the same rate that the retirees would
based on the number of active duty
versus the number of
retirees so the the data that you see
here um shows and it comes from the
defense manow Data Center and it uses
the same time frame the FY 2019 which
ends in for New Hampshire is in June of
2019 shows that um that between New
Hampshire and Massachusetts where people
agree it's a good assumption to say that
most the visitors to our state parks are
from those two states we would have
about
24,2 44 active military during that time
frame with only
3,31 visits so it's not
2.65 visits per member it's. 136 and
that's the big discrepancy
so then if you look at um you know the
department of uh military Affairs and
Veterans Services reports that 51% of
our veterans are 65 years and older so
the other group regardless of military
affiliation if you're a New Hampshire
resident and you're over age 65 you
already get you already qualify for uh
access so the the number of New
Hampshire retirees that would be would
be about 49% of that current number of
retirees in New Hampshire so about 4600
we don't do that for Massachusetts so
all their retirees would be eligible
about
177,000 and the state park has two
different fees depending on which Park
sometimes it's $4 sometimes it's $5
using the upper bound of that we'll use
$5 as the Assumption so if we look at
the the
23,000 New Hampshire and Massachusetts
new retirees times the 0.136 visits
times $5 per visit you see about
$15,200 of impact as an upper Bound for
the uh for if you if you pass this bill
um and if you look at the the the last
page again you can see they have um I
don't think it shows it there but you
can see it on the link they have a right
now like in 2019 the numbers that were
available they have just over $2 million
of uh complimentary programs for
everybody that can that's eligible not
just the military so this would be an
increase of about 3/4 of 1% a very tiny
increase for this group of
military
retirees on the third page I just there
was a question that came up and I I have
this here um talks about how would you
qualify at the gate how would an State
Park employee check a military
retiree and I'm a military retiree so I
do have and I'm so I do have the
military retired ID and you see an
example fimile here uh that's on the top
of that page um that currently shows
where you you that you retired it also
could say
retired or you could say guard retired
or Reserve retired depending on what
what you were doing when you finished if
you retired out of the Guard you retired
out of the Reserve I retired out of the
reserve so mine says retired Reserve but
this this ID could be used very easily
to determine um if the person is
eligible if they don't have that ID then
they're not retired so veterans that
haven't retired a achieved retirement
status wouldn't have this ID and
currently we have the laws you mentioned
anybody that was that's retired from the
New Hampshire National Guard only and is
E6 gets complimentary admission that's
kind of a challenge for the gate
employee to say okay you got the retired
Eve now prove to me okay your E6 and
Below okay I understand that maybe I
don't know what the O's are for officer
but get that now prove to me you
actually retired from the New Hampshire
National Guard that's kind of making it
more challenging so in in some sense
this bill kind of simplifies the process
for the gate employees because they know
it makes it easier for them to
understand what the ID requirements
are um one other note I wanted to talk
about just for comparison to a
neighboring states in in Vermont in
Maine they currently provide free State
Park admission to all veterans in their
states but you have to be a resident of
Vermont for Vermont or resident of Maine
for Maine just to keep that in mind so
we're by adding retirees we're still not
up to where where the neighboring states
are and I'm not sure if we need to or
want to but just as a data
point um the other point is some people
might say well do we want to include
just New Hampshire military retirees
because that could easily be verified by
showing proof of residency like they do
now for age 65 if you're not age 65 show
that you're a military retiree that
could easily be done is that something
we want to do if you only did it for New
Hampshire because of half of them
already being eligible that impact would
be less L than $3,200 a year so that
would be very small but you know served
in the military it's one team one fight
all mil all mil military
retirees regardless of state of
residents have dedicated at least 20
years of their life to service so while
it sounds attractive you might want to
think about that if you wanted to
consider an amendment just to make it
for New Hampshire retirees but I would
support either one I think either one is
reasonable but keep that in mind do we
really want to exclude retirees that
come from other states so in summary um
providing complimentary State Park
admission is a modest gesture it's four
or5 dollar per visit this bill would
simplify the retire ID check process for
state employees that work at the State
Parks military retirees are small group
of veterans who have served in in
sacrificed for at least two decades for
our country and the the fiscal impact of
just about $155,000 is a very small
increase to to the the state park
complimentary and discounted entry
program for those reasons I recommend
that you recommend a to pass or a to
pass with Amendment on this Bill thank
you for listening and I'll take any
questions thank you Mr P that was
helpful with the E6 part and also the uh
the FN fiscal note uh background was
helpful as well rep represent
levit I'm astonished this up through the
cracks I mean you can have a army
personnel complete active duta
training uh complete his tour in four
years get veteran status but a
retired 20year
service Personnel cannot go
to a state park for
free I agree who how come this bill
hasn't taken up 30 years ago this is
ridiculous this is a no-brainer I mean
th this is all we can get into that in
the exec
session uh this is all
great but you got to yes when you walked
in thank you appreciate that other
questions ripson
Rollins thank you Mr chair um just
another question for my constituents say
a husband and wife go to a State Beach
like sonop State Beach whatever whatever
Park and the husband has the paperwork
does the wife have to pay or does that
include both of them
right now the way the law the way that
this bill is proposed is it only
includes the military member themselves
unless the spouse is also military
member that's
retired so I think a couple years ago
there was a bill to to look at doing
dependence of of of some of the people
but I think that that was that made a
much bigger number thank you other
questions seeing none uh thank you again
Mr
power thank you and with no other cards
and no other hands we will at this
time close that hearing and and the next
hearing uh is happened uh an hour or so
ago is going to be open by Vice chair
Rollins because I am going to uh
introduce the next
measure
okay I'm now I'm going to open up the
hearing on HB
1355 I'd like to ask uh representative
MF to come up to uh introduce the
Bill thank you Mr Vice
chair okay you all have this meas in
front of you and you there's just two
things I want to point out about
it uh the first one you you'll see that
it adds the word
reenlistment to enlistment so this is be
kind of becoming a recruiting and
reenlistment measure and then the second
part uh you'll see the cash incentive
goes up to
$6,000 and there is an of course an FN
that goes with
that of course and um let me just speak
to uh why there's a why this there's a
need for this type of thing and the ad
agitant General is here I know you have
in and also there's one or two other
cards uh Mr Vice chair that you have and
they can speak to the uh recruitment
part better I just I'll say at this
point is if you don't know and I know
most of you do because you're part of
this committee where you just know
what's going on uh recruiting military
recruiting is uh probably having the
most difficult time it's had since uh we
went to an all volunteer force in
1973 I remember 1973 because I turned
just when I turned 18 they uh got rid of
the draft and as as an aside they get
rid of the draft they lowered the
drinking aged to 18 the day after I
turned 18 so that's how I remember
1973 so that's when the all volunteer
force uh started we've had it for 50
years ever since and at times it's uh
missions have been met um right now uh
for whatever combination of reasons some
of them are demographic we're having a a
very difficult time recruiting so that's
an important part of this as well is uh
this will hopefully help uh retention
and recruiting so that's my introduction
to the bill I will let the agitant
general speak better to these d Dynamics
but I would try to accept any questions
if if there were any while I'm
here Carri go ahead uh do you know if
the current um program that we put in
place has been effective and how did you
come to the number that you are
currently presenting so question was is
what do I know about the effectiveness
of what we have in place now and how do
we come to this number rather than try
to answer that as best I can I I would
like to defer to the agitant general
because this is his world and he's in
the midst of it and um so if you don't
mind I I will defer to to
him any other
questions chair
uh Mr representative M how do you know
how uh this would impact the other
branches of the service
that are having the same difficulty with
recruitment how how might this impact
other branches branches of service as
well uh New Hampshire just has the uh
the N Army National Guard and of course
Air National Guard as well so the other
services uh would would not be impacted
this is aimed at uh New Hampshire and
the New Hampshire
guard uh so I don't think it would help
the Navy if if that's your question
okay um but the uh New Hampshire
National Guard picks from the same pool
yes as individuals here that the other
the other uh services do also um if I
was to come in again and someone said to
me I'm going to give you $6,000 instead
of U you know living out in the woods
for a couple of months um I would
consider that you know
yes in terms of of recruiting there are
different and I'm I was never a
recruiter although in a sense anybody
who's ever in the military kind of is a
recruiter if you believe in the military
you talk it up with people and you
encourage them to consider it uh the
Marine I was in the Marine Corps Marine
Corp had less of a problem with
recruiting and some of that goes to the
culture that some people want believe it
or not some people want to get their
butts kicked um in
training if you're tracking me and in
other people they want they're more
about you know education benefits or uh
or learning a trade or whatever
so uh again I I really want to defer to
the uh to the agitant general like I
said before to Ripon KY who's immersed
in this because um he knows much more
about about this than I
do any further questions all right thank
you representative thank you Mr M
chair at this time I'd like to call up
General David
midus could I ask you to spell your name
for the record please yeah yes
ma'am m i k o l a i t i
s thank you
yeah uh Mr Vice chair committee members
uh thank you for having me here today
for the record on Major General David
mtis the edit in general for the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services and New Hampshire
National Guard um so let's go broad like
any employer you generally have two big
lovers you got to uh fill your
formations or get new employees and then
you got to retain your employees so you
address this committee address and we
thankful for that um this reenlistment
bonus it was like a referral program
right so if you ref if you're currently
serving Guardsman or retiree as an
enlisted rank or up to the rank of
Captain I could refer someone to join
the New Hampshire National Guard army or
Heir that was a $1,000 sort of uh uh
enlistment incentive program we're
typically a family business or a word of
mouth business so that helped us with
the employment with getting new soldiers
and Airmen into our formations so how do
you retain them uh the representative
over here first like first and foremost
generally speaking people join for three
reasons a sense of service to their
country the educational benefits and
representative maet actually nailed it
the challenge of a military lifestyle
those are the three primary reasons this
next Generation joins how do you keep
them
in so in our formations of about 2800
Army and Airmen there's about a 100
nocos non-commission officers both Army
and air who for whatever reason are
ineligible for a federal
retention
bonus so this is a gap in the system
that we're trying to cover so right so
when we look at the numbers um we feel
like there's eligible pool of about a
100 non-commission officers between
their years of six and 20 years of
service we want to keep them in so
that's the incentive here not double
dipping if there's a federal retention
bonus they're eligible for that is for
those who are ineligible for whatever
reasons when you look at the past
numbers of How It's impacted um our sort
of say enlistment so uh representative
ker your question earlier was last
calendar year we had approximately 20
referrals so we have 20 referrals in the
Army National Guard for a for structure
of 1800 that's moving the Neel over
1% right so if we can keep five ncos in
for $66,000 for up their six-year uh
retention bonus um that's a big deal in
our world so those are the broad reasons
why you know you you address the lever
for us for as a referral business to get
people in the door now it's a retention
issue to try to keep our service members
in specifically only non-commission
officers between the ranks of uh between
the eligible years of six to 20 years of
service subject to your questions and I
am here with our our recruiting
retention Battalion Commander so okay do
we have any
questions
okay don't argue you
go all right thank you sir it's could
seeing you again um just have one one um
quick question in in your um experience
with this program and in your position
have you found that um ncos or otherwise
who have been eligible for this program
have have you seen um any high
percentage of recruitment of that money
for for flagging issues or for any type
of you know like you know PT failures or
whatever like is that still I'm an
enforcement um aspect of this program
yeah so thank you sir a really good
question if you're were flagged for
disciplinary action you're
ineligible that good point Thank
You representative Li thank you for
taking my question Vice chair Rollins I
don't see the downsides I mean
recruiting is down by 30% um I'm not
previewed to tell you why I think
everybody does have a pretty good idea
um you know $6,000 I mean you know for
somebody who's been
um actively serving I is up to is is
relatively small in comparison to the
market out there now for um new
employees um so you're looking for some
money is that is that what we're here
now sir right now we are comfortable
with what the current you know what
we're physically yes yeah we're we're
we're comfortable with our existing
budget what we anticipate is a year or
two once we get some data I don't want
to mislead you we make come back to you
and say Hey listen we might request some
more money but right now we are willing
to live within our means of the 50 have
delate you want to be able to delegate
the money to right now certain
percentage or whatever it is to
Recruitment and part of this is a
financial incentive yeah so like for
example so what's the downsize here
what's the downsize uh we feel none okay
right how about the in the um Community
the you know National Guard I mean
they're all on page on this right uh yes
sir and what about Cham off what does he
feel about about that Cham off is he on
page with that too I think so okay well
good good cuz I'm I'm on his side okay
so so just one clarification too um
every service has a different bonus
system right the Army Navy Air Force
Marine Coast Guard space force everyone
has a different service there was sort
of a running joke that says um the
Marine cord made their numbers and they
don't offer a bonus and the com the
Marine Corps recently said your bonuses
with the ability to call yourself a
marine right that's what they said each
service has a different bonus system
it's either to the assession to get
people in or to retention pce we
identified a gap of those who are
ineligible and we're trying to fill that
Gap with um State resources to try to
retain our
Force follow
up thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
taking my question um what what limited
it to uh
$6,000
did you feel that that was something
that would be uh affordable for your
budgets to to work or uh uh S I think it
was twofold I think one is like live
within your means within our budget
constraints and then number two is when
you compare to the federal bonuses out
there you know for example um you know I
think on the federal system there's
sometimes 10 or $20,000 bonuses right
and a bigger bonus for the The increased
length of time in years so right now
we're strategizing and says okay maybe
uh was it uh $3,000 for three or four
years of service and $6,000 for six you
trying to incentivize the longer term
okay have a
followup go ahead yes uh very quickly um
I was offered a bonus of $10,000 to
reinlist um that was back in
19772 um then that was the reason I
asked that question because back then
they were offering x amount of dollars
uh more than what you're asking for now
and you Pro my opinion would probably be
to increase that number I you know
that's pretty much
my representative pie um thank you again
I just have one more followup I just uh
thought of is this um is this program in
um perpetuity or are we only talking
about a specific funding for this fiscal
year a perpetuity so I think if I
understand it correctly um every year
there's a $50,000 within our
appropriation that's non-aps thing to
continue
on I I think I answer that
correctly representative gagy thank you
thank you General uh 1966 I was offered
six
,000 and an upgrade from E4 to E5 if I
reenlisted uh didn't do it obviously
because my wife we wouldn't be married
today uh have have you thought about
perhaps you
incentivizing in addition to the six
four 3 to six grand that uh if the
person is eligible for an upgrade in
rank that that would be offered
also can you
answer um so in in order for a soldier
to promote say from E4 to E5 they have
to have a certain number of years
remaining in their contract usually that
number is three so if they are already
coming up on their ETS or end term
service then they would be unable to
promote unless they extend it and they
may fall under this if they already have
enough years of service okay that's
because I had uh at that time five and a
half years two and a half res of time
because I was still in high school and
three years active so that's why I had
the time in okay thank
you any further
questions a Manion thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question General do
you guys do any kind of like an exit
survey on why they wouldn't
reinlist yes we do do you want to
discuss some of the exit survey data
you usually the challenge is um what we
do exit surveys
um generally speaking there's two or
three probably bigger rocks of why the
exit surveys or service members are live
in usually 6 to 10 years in um they're
establishing their civilian jobs and
they might be starting a family buying a
house and I'll be honest and blunt a
week and a month gets tiring right when
you missing the birthday the holiday
this or like you know the anniversary
this or that so generally speaking it's
that Junior solders getting established
in his civilian job 70% of our force
parttime that shows you one number two
is typically probably the college
benefits 20 20% of our force is in
college so that they understand with the
free tuition waiver in the state of New
Hampshire that's your pathway to success
and then probably the third reason is um
it it's they might just say the military
is not my my cup of tea I I did my term
I'm okay I check that block but I I
think those are generally the three
broader reasons agree I I would agree
that those are usually the reasons why
uh service members ETS um I I I would
say another piece of this is and this
kind of covers it um one of our
populations that is not covered under
the federal or not eligible for a
federal retention bonus or reenlistment
bonus is our dual status technicians so
specifically our uh internal mechanics
not necessarily our AGR Force but the uh
GS level or wage grade level Federal
technicians so we have a significant
issue in retaining our trained uh
maintenance Force internally on the
full-time side strictly because they may
be able to go get a different job but
strict but be but simply because they
are not eligible for those same
reenlistment bonuses that's that their
traditional uh Guardsmen are um eligible
for so think of it like this we have
four HR departments Human Resources
departments one is for our state
civilian one is for the federal
civilians one is for the Army one is for
the Air Force right those Federal
civilians can have a couple different
statuses so that's I mean there's about
a 100 people who are ineligible for a
federal re uh retention bonus it's it's
super complicated in our HR
World any further questions for the
general seeing
none like to call up uh Brooks Haywood s
good he was up here just to answer
question speak okay sorry I I I really
have nothing else unless anyone else has
questions for me that do not pertain to
the does anybody have any questions for
this
gentleman I'm a lieutenant colonel
sir
yeah okay see you no further questions
I'd like to call up Paul holds from the
CAC good afternoon Paul Lloyd uh
chairman of the state veterans advisory
committee I'm here to let you know that
the committee fully supports this uh
this bill this is part of making sure
that we can successfully attract but
more importantly retain quality people
in New Hampshire National Guard thank
you anybody have any
questions seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on HB 1355
FN
thank you
General
Colonel and Mr Lloyd your succinct
testimony is always
appreciated
okay at this time moving right along our
next measure up is HB
1355 1355 with an FN relative to the New
Hampshire New Hampshire okay I'm sorry
that's the one that uh I just introduced
not 1355 138 1338
1338 relative to New Hampshire's
enforcement of the military Selective
Service Act
okay Prime sponsor is our own
representative Manion and uh Manion um
welcome thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Tom Manion I'm representing Hillsboro 1
pelum uh I'm introducing to nobody
surprise an anti-war Bill uh HB 1338 a
bill that with withholds state support
for enforcement of Selective Service
call-ups repeals The Selective Service
awareness and compliance act from RSA
and gives an opt optional check boox for
individuals registering for Selective
Service with their driver's license to
notify the Selective Service System that
they are conscientious objector ahead of
time uh the withholding support section
is modeled after other Sanctuary
policies which I believe to be the duty
of states to deny further expenditure of
taxpayer money enforcing programs that
federal government forces us uh forces
upon us I did add a carve out to include
the same language template from defend
the guard unless war is formally
declared pursuant to Article 1 Section 8
uh which is probably nicer than I should
be and uh some of the bill supporters
would rather that language not be there
at all uh removing the Selective Service
awareness and compliance act uh was the
original starting point for this bill
since we currently have in statute a
requirement that prospective college
students be registered for the draft
before they are admitted to State
schools I find this unti entirely
unnecessary in beyond the scope of what
our college system should be enforcing
if the feds care about it let them hand
handle it via FASA or some other
mechanism uh finally the conscientious
objector check box I figured this was a
straightforward way of flagging ahead of
time that the next generation will not
comply with call-ups on an individual
basis I was told the selective service
system will not accept these which took
me to by surprise because the federal
government used used to enjoy
warrantless bulk data collection and
this information is voluntarily
submitted uh regardless whether the feds
will accept it I see no harm in
providing an option of sending that
information anyway I know esac
unanimously opposes this bill I've been
in attendance to their monthly meetings
and will continue to do so going forward
a motivating factor for filing this and
another bill was elicit elicit a
response from them I wasn't completely
surprised they opposed it but as a
two-time combat veteran it continues to
be disappointing that there are no
anti-war veteran voices amongst svac
voting members they simply do not
represent me or an entire generation of
veterans however the corrective measures
via legislation are on the 2025 year
we'll see what happens uh but as far as
uh HB 1338 I hope uh you vote OTP and
I'm willing to take any
questions rep Cary so you mentioned that
um in the public college system one must
be registered in order to go to a public
college is the same true private college
I I believe it only affects the state
schools I I have to reread it but it
actually I searched for the phrase
Selective Service in RSA and that showed
up and it was like you know it's been in
RSA since 1999 I was
surprised other questions representative
M thank you Mr chair um could you
explain to me I'm a non-military person
could you explain to me um lines 18 and
19 of the bill yeah have let me bring it
back up
it says nothing in this chapter shall
prohibit a government actor's entering
of registrations with the selective
service system as authorized by RSA
20263 colon 5c so the information that
you're filing when you check when we
have our license registration there's a
check box on there if you're like
younger you check it saying file this
information with the Selective Service I
have an extra check box on there that
simply says I'm I also wish to register
as a um uh conscientious objector which
I'm being told the selective service
system won't accept it but I see no harm
in sending them data the the federal
government loves to collect our data I
don't understand why they wouldn't
accept this check box it seems like a
dumb complaint from The Selective
Service
System other questions for the prime
sponsor representative
Sebert sorry thank you for taking my
question um do you have what if you
don't select the check box upon I might
have missed that the first part The
Selective Service that that's already
like in RSA like u i mean not RSA that's
already that's like a federal
requirement that you're every abled body
person is supposed to register for the
draft well you're supposed to register
but if you're filling out your thing for
your driver's license then you don't do
the check box that's outside of the
scope of what this bill is trying to do
that's that's a that's a problem the
federal government may have with you uh
I do encourage people to not check that
box okay
gotcha
um you're good other questions for the
prime sponsor repr fill you up it's
unlikely you may have this data but what
would be the percentage of people who
would either fail to check the box or
choose conscious objector do we have any
data on that I'm not sure in the current
state of affairs like uh I know for a
fact uh there there's a Pew research
poll about veterans specifically about
uh individuals that think that the Iraq
War was a mistake or I'm sorry not worth
it so to speak only 33% of veterans
thought that the Iraq War was a good
idea and only 38% of Iraq and
Afghanistan veterans thought that was a
worth it and that was before the
disastrous withdrawal so I guarantee
that 38% is not the case anymore so that
type of messaging should go forward I'm
sure that it's bled out into the the the
speaking with family members over turkey
dinners and stuff like that like I've
had these discussions with my family
so other
questions thank you representative
Manion I have two more cards here uh
representative beler is here in support
of the bill and uh Paul Mr Lloyd Paul
Lloyd is still here uh from esvac
opposing the bill those are the other
two cards that I have if anyone else
wants to submit a card they may so
representative beler
welcome thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee um I I was actually
surprised to find that I wasn't a
co-sponsor on this because I did assist
with this bill and I am in favor of this
bill um I would not actually identify
myself as anti-war however I am not uh
for fighting bad Wars for bad reasons
and the way that we make sure we don't
fight bad Wars for bad reasons is we put
that decision in the hands of the people
representing the people themselves to
make that decision um now we really need
to
be uh we we need to understand our
current circumstances as they exist
right now geopolitically
uh we're seeing what could reasonably be
characterized as the opening phases of
World War I we have fronts opened in
Ukraine with Russia having invaded and
we're looking at death tools over there
with this new hyper lethal drone
technology that are the last I heard
they're approaching a million men
between both armies we have possible
fronts opening in South America in
Guyana with the perhaps invasion of
Venezuela we have potential fronts
opening soon with China that appears to
be slated to move on Taiwan in the
aftermath of an election that's due to
happen this very week where the
nationalists appear to look like they're
going to carry Victory there so we need
to be very clear about where we're
headed as a country and as we enter this
extraordinarily World historic dangerous
time we also are at a nationally
historic recruiting
shortfall already we've heard from high
up members of the military and uh
civilian federal government that we will
probably have to reinstitute a
draft so we're talking about
conscription if we have to go to war
with any of these nations in fact I was
listening to some very good analysis
this morning that suggested not for not
even for lack of ships which we
apparently don't have enough of but lack
of personnel to staff ships that we
probably don't even have the manpower to
break
the likely blockade of Taiwan that is
probably right around the
corner so what's likely to happen in
these circumstances is a draft again and
all this is
saying is that if we're going to take
that extreme step where we're going to
send our boys and our girls into the
brand new hyper lethal kind of warfare
that we're seeing out of places like
Ukraine that we actually have Congress
take a vote on it thank you I'll take
questions
uh yes uh Ron
finny would you believe that since we've
had an all volunteer Force for as long
as we've had now that isn't there a
massive conflict with with federal
government saying that you don't um
you're not required to serve in the
military but but you are required to
basically sign up for the military
through their system like like you know
you know wouldn't we just make a you
know conscription illegal
anyway so I'm I'm I'm of dual Minds on
that I I understand the argument and
perspective however I can also see an
argument under a a truly existential
threat such as an invasion of the
Homeland by a considerable Force where
it it could be a necessary thing and and
from my perspective it could be a duty
for any able-bodied person to to serve
therein um assuming however they're not
a conscience objector because we
actually pretty pretty clear in the New
Hampshire Constitution that no conscien
objector shall be compelled to
Arms repres representative levit thank
you chair MFA for taking my question so
this is spin-off from the god bill
right uh I don't know if i' call it a
spin-off some of it language is
certainly inspired or well we're not
going to argue with the term you know
it's a term of endearing if you want to
make look at it that way okay because
you know I mean I'm service military so
you know I been veteran but I mean where
does it stop I mean I don't say this you
know derogatorily I mean we're going to
have you know um the um
um um the veter US Army Reserve next I
mean it's we got to have some type of
guidelines here and and I mean this I I
need to know your position thank you
thank you and a that's a very good
question limiting principles are always
very important so the limiting principle
in this one is I I think fairly clearly
outlined in the US Constitution which is
that we should not be contri you know
contributing troops to fight a foreign
war save for an actual vote of Congress
now this is something that hasn't
actually happened since World War II
because they've passed things like
authorizations for the use of military
force which are of questionable ultimate
legality I think
but that that's what the Constitution
has to say so that's that's what I would
say is is where we need to be going with
this follow
follow
up what that's that's vague I mean you
know you're say basically what you
interpret the Constitutions is saying I
mean that's the truth of
it U yes but I believe that's our job as
a legislature to be coal the Federal
Constitution you're saying that's our
job as a legislator we serve the state
not the
bedroom well if I could just respond to
that that last point I I would say that
um States created through our Federalist
system the federal government to do the
will of the states that couldn't be done
individually by States and as a matter
of a sort of co-ee equality all power is
not strictly delegated to the federal
government are reserved via the 10th
Amendment to the states themselves which
puts us relatively on par we're not
we're not a sort of system where the
federal government is above us they're
just next to us and a little bit
different than us so yes we do have the
ability to um to push back a little bit
if we believe they're making an error
thank you for that explanation
sure uh representative I I do have a
question uh for you or perhaps for the
prime sponsor uh who I can ask because
I'm the chair and I have that power uh
and he's still here uh so as I read the
analysis the bill prohibits state or
local enforcement of the U Selective
Service Act except in times of foreign
military invasion of declared war
so um so
this me you I'll ask the prime again
because I can um you're not favoring the
elimination of the draft or The
Selective Service or are you no it
sounds like you're not I not no
absolutely not and and Mr Prime sponsor
I'm asking you because I can just for
you're not the intent of this measure is
not to eliminate the draft or or or
advocate for the elimination of
Selective Service you're it says it
prohibits state or local enforcement so
do you do do you support the elimination
of the draft is I I personally do but
this that's not what this bill is trying
to do we can't do that there's Federal
uh Supremacy so the idea here is it's
it's similar to all other um Sanctuary
policies where we just won't expend like
State Police local police to help the
feds apprehend draft Dodgers to speak
okay got it thank thank you any other
questions thank you representative thank
you uh Mr Lloyd is
here thank you for sticking around and
and welcome
back thank you good afternoon Paul Lloyd
chairman of the state veterans advisory
committee um and as announced earlier
the uh State veterans advisory committee
um opposes this bill um couple notes
military service act hasn't been used to
draft people for 50 years uh in over 50
years and there's already a policy uh in
the for the conscientious objetives
there already a policy to recognize
those thank
you questions for for Mr
Lloyd represent Lloyd no questions for
Mr Lloyd okay uh um represent gagy does
have a
question thank you Mr chairman I think I
do as it stands now
any
person when they reached the age of 18
like we used to when I was 18 you had to
register at the post office for the
draft is that correct yes and it still
is today I believe so yes okay thank you
y other
questions saying none thank you again Mr
Lloyd and saying no more pink cards and
no hands I
will uh call in to this hearing uh it is
now 20:07 we are almost right back on
schedule thank you uh committee members
for for your great work in keeping
things going the way you have okay the
next measure up is
hr21 house resolution 21 affirming the
New Hampshire
militia Prime sponsor uh is here
probably didn't know he was going to
speak to the previous bill or maybe he
did but uh here he is uh on schedule
for introducing uh hr21 Prime sponsor
representative
beler thank you again Mr chairman and
members of the
committee and uh I don't know if I did
this last time for the record
representative vure Carol District
4 um so I have a small packet going
around that's got a few things we're
going to take a quick look at if that's
all right um the first page is my is my
testimony here today uh and it it opens
with the portions from the New Hampshire
Constitution the New Hampshire Bill of
Rights that I believe are relevant to
what we're looking at
today a well-regulated militia is the
proper natural andure defense of a state
uh article 24 you'll recognize that is
the exact language you will find in the
resolution it relates to uh article 25
standing armies standing armies are
dangerous to Liberty and ought not be
raised or kept up without the consent of
the
legislature and also to article 26 in
all cases and at all times the military
ought to be under strict subordination
to and governed by the Civil
power so these are all very important
things contextually to this proposed
resolution tion um because we are
talking about the state of New Hampshire
militia
here so why might we need a state of New
Hampshire militia now we already have
one in theory and in law although I
don't think there's any staffing of it
at the moment but why might we need this
in the future
well we
have Chinese military operations already
occurring on us soil including drug
Manufacturing distribution pipelines out
of Maine BioWare biowarfare Research
Laboratories out of
California and an estimated division
worth of soldiers already here that's
from forward Observer group all of which
can be turned to Insurgency and Guerilla
Warfare operations on a moment's notice
and are anticipated to do exactly that
in the event of an American Chinese War
which could very well PR be precipitated
by the Chinese invasion of Taiwan
second cartel activity including counter
State operations drug distribution human
trafficking and extreme violence the
cartel is already the deao government
Authority in multiple Southern border
towns and has affected like the Chinese
Communist Party Elite capture of
Americans via bribery blackmail which
can be reasonably forecast to lead to
destabilization operations against the
legitimate Republican government of the
several States as they have previously
done in
Mexico and another third reason
infiltration of known malign actors and
terrorists from such States as Russia
China Iran Venezuela and more who are
believed to be here to conduct agent
sabator operations against critical
infrastructure and as a note on that if
anybody's been paying attention to this
um rather unlikely streak of exploding
and burning pieces of American critical
infrastructure from refining capacity to
agriculture this might be something
worth thinking a real hard look
at so I would offer good members of the
committee that we still require a
militia today as much if not more so
than we did at the founding of this
nation we swore an oath before God to
uphold this truth the militia is the
shest and most proper defense of our
state as is reasoned from natural law
the right to self-defense and the right
to
self-determination now to offer some
evidence and and pointers on this on the
back of the first page we have a
definition of the militia from federal
law um which is important to note
because the militia consists of all
according to federal law all able-bodied
males at lead 17 years of age and
up now if we look to other conflicts in
the world we might find that actually in
terms of true existential credit say
there is no person which the militia
might not be expanded to
Encompass it's also broken down into two
categories the organized militia versus
the unorganized militia there's a little
bit of a debate on the organized part as
to whether the National Guard is truly
the militia of New Hampshire or the
state guard is the militia of New
Hampshire for our purposes today we
don't have to worry about settling that
conflict but it does
exist next page this is the state guard
as it exists in New Hampshire law this
is at least a portion of the New
Hampshire organized militia it is under
State Authority Under the authority of
the
governor currently as I said I don't
believe it's staffed at the moment but
it could be and it may be if we need to
call it up at some point in
time so if it's already here in law why
do we even need a
resolution moving on the state of
Florida has recently enacted oh I
apologize actually the next two pages
are uh the evidence for the um Chinese
uh drug operation and the bow Warfare
lab I didn't include the full articles
because I didn't want to kill that many
trees uh feel free to look these up on
the
web the next two pages however the
Florida
guard when the Florida uh legislature
reinstituted their guard in
2023 it was met with utter Fury and
contempt from the federal government and
from the media it was painted as a
private Army it was painted as a
vigilante militia and they made every
effort they possibly could to shut this
down and the end result was a severe
limiting of the Staffing and capacity of
this militia in the State of
Florida that is the treatment we can
expect effect if we find ourselves in
the situation where we actually need to
call up this militia for any
reason and on the last page if you ask
how timely is this bill well and I
apologize because this didn't print well
this is from Vice
news and if you look at the
date just
yesterday the uh multiple congressmen at
the federal level put a bill in that
would criminalize militia activity and
as far as I can tell and I believe this
is true that bill would criminalize the
training or calling up of the New
Hampshire
militia we as a state need to send a
message to the federal
government that they're encroaching on
our state sovereignty here as I said
before we are a dual Sovereign with the
federal government it is right that the
federal government have an army to
protect us and from Invasion and it's
also right that each state under its own
Sovereign Authority control its own
military to its own necessary ends that
will vary from state to state and they
look different from state to state
too I'd be happy to take any
questions represent
finny would you I don't know if it's
more of a would you believe but do you
believe
from your own perspective that um the
more like uh demonization of militias
throughout the country not just in New
Hampshire has has something to do with
the perceived idea that an organized
group of civilians would somehow be able
to overthrow the government or it's it's
more of a secession thing or or it's a
pretense to armed conflict with our own
people would you believe that you know I
think the demonization that has occurred
around the militia concept has I think
it largely had to do with the veering
away from the founders intent of the
militia concept that occurred during
perhaps the the mid part of the 20th
century um where we saw if I'm honest a
lot of yahoos and places who were kind
of play acting or laring as soldiers who
got some dangerous ideas in their heads
um but the reality is from the from the
instantiation of this nation the militia
has been considered the militia under
the state control
which consists of the whole body of the
people because if you remember the
concept of the Minute Men the idea was
that that all men of of due age were to
keep a musket powder balls and the
training they needed to put them into
effect rapidly to protect their
communities and their state and their
country and that is the militia concept
that I'm trying to get back to with
this representative
levit thank you chair Mett it's just one
question why
and I I understand what you're saying
and where you're coming from here I
sincerely do just the word a militia and
I'm not going to get a debate it does
not have good following but why wouldn't
I call up a highly trained highly
weaponized highly organized
organizations such as the New Hampshire
National guard instead I'm not I don't
mean derogatory instead of Joey down the
road say hey call him up buddy we better
get going here they're invading us it
makes no sense thank you well I I
appreciate that I'm actually very glad
you asked that because that's something
I should have touched on so there's
there's two reasons that really stand
out and if you look at the actual State
Guard law which is on the page number
three um what it does is it gives the
governor the authority to create this
callup Force this organized militia
under circumstances where a National
Guard are
deployed so when they're not
available this is the
go-to the second
reason is that the National Guard and
this is that little bit of a debate I
didn't want to get into is whether the
National Guard actually is the militia
or not it's defined as so under federal
statute but it's a little less clear in
state
law but the federal government has the
ability to activate the National
Guard so so what were to happen if say
just as actually we're about to get a
very good example of this in Texas
yesterday the uh the governor of Texas
Greg Abbott called up his National Guard
to duty in the context of a militia and
he actually took over a uh a section of
the border and he expelled uh Federal
border patrol and he declared that
Federal Border Patrol was actually
assisting with an invasion force of the
United States so so we have a situation
here where there is the potential for a
conflict between state and federal about
who is in control of this
organization and the militia concept is
really ultimately designed to eliminate
any doubt about who's in control of the
organization so where the National Guard
can be called up at the federal level
and can be federalized the state militia
cannot be it is under the state's
control thank you for for that
explanation uh so represent Belcher uh I
actually wrote down what you said uh
federal government has the ability to
activate the National
Guard um it's interesting because we had
to defend the guard bill that kind of uh
goes to that uh notion or that statement
that you just made about federal
government has the ability to activate
the National Guard uh if there's a
declaration of war that that's uh
something that we're getting there's a
lot of civics being learned uh thanks to
these guard bills and militia bills uh a
lot of people as the guard bill was
being discussed they confused the guard
with the militia what you're doing here
is is useful I I think for sure it's
helping it will help people understand
the difference there is a difference so
my my question is uh I I'm looking what
you have out of FL Florida um which is
very interesting um there's 48 other
states and you mentioned Texas as well
can you point to any other states that
have this dual guard militia structure
in place uh where the militia clearly is
not under the purview of the feds and
the National Guard we're we're still
talking about that is there any state
that has that
duel there there is I'm struggling to
remember the third state that has a
there is a third state that has a
specifically outlined in the law
I I don't I'll have to get back to you
on which state that is but you're
getting that very well could be um but
you're you're getting into also a very
important sort of um sort of line of
thought here about whether or not a the
militia concept has to be defined in
state law because a lot of States would
not specifically necessarily have it in
RSA or in their state law because they
have Illusions to it in their
constitution and it's also within the
Federal
Constitution so every state since the
Inception of America has had access to
its own because they are sovereign
basically the definition of a sovereign
might as well be you get your own
military force um so that's just been
the way it has been ever since the
foundations of this
country if followup uh if if a militia
on the state level is better defined um
do you see a possibility of of a county
wanting to organize some sort of a
county
militia uh that that's going to heavily
depend on what is in state law now there
are places I believe in this country
where such a thing would be um would be
within the scope of their state law as
or the Constitution that's laid out
within New Hampshire however there is no
such um there is no such standard it's
very clear in New Hampshire law that the
militia is under the control control of
the state not not a county level
Authority the closest thing you could
possibly get to at the county level is a
is a is a policy that would be set up by
a sheriff sure there you go and you you
provided us some great uh background
with the actual articles that speak to
that any other questions for represent
beler yes represent
Miller thank you Mr chair um in your
resolution you mentioned asymmetric
threats could you define what that means
yes so asymmetric threats is is a phrase
that comes from unconventional warfare
and it basically it just means if you if
you look for instance at what's
currently happening over in um well
actually we launched a bunch of missiles
at uh Targets in Yemen last night at at
the federal level now what was happening
was they the Yemen were launching
relatively inexpensive Iranian Source
drone technology at commercial shipping
and at our military vessels um and those
things were they're cheap they're you
know thousands of dollars each and we
had to shoot each one of them down with
missiles that cost more than millions of
dollars each so the asymmetry in that
threat is something that is thought of
in unconventional warfare terms as a
GameChanger it's something that we
cannot keep up in the long term because
it would either bleed us dry financially
or we would run out of these expensive
things so asymmetric threats are things
that are not they're not traditional
Warfare they're things that exploit uh
vulnerabilities um inexpensive uh newer
Technologies um and they would even grow
to Encompass things like um
um the the sort of Special Forces type
operations that are conducted by various
countries on other Count's soil in order
to foment Revolution and and things like
that thank you for that other questions
R of
kry so just based on the testimony we've
heard today about you know other bills
where there's such difficulty recruiting
and now we're offering big bonuses and
incentives to get people to join how do
you think a state militia might be
peopled if we're having this much
difficulty with our traditional services
that's a good question but I don't think
they're directly related because the
unorganized militia is already defined
it it is essentially the entire body of
the people who is capable of wielding
arms um which is why the militia is only
utilized as typically in true
existential threats um for instance you
Ukraine has been invaded by Russia and
they have now dipped into deep into the
barrel to pull everyone they possibly
can out to defend the Homeland uh that's
the sort of circumstance where you see a
militia uh being employed uh or
alternatively here in the US our
military size is such that if we had if
we had these known uh Bad actors who
were all over the country who are you
know foreign military aged males from
various countries that don't like us if
they had a protracted unconventional
warfare threat where they targeted our
critical infrastructure choke points
Logistics the there is no possible way
that with the size of our military we
could keep this entire country safe and
that's where this decentralized uh
concept of
militia um both within state law and the
Federal Constitution in the Second
Amendment that's where that
decentralized capability comes from
where if something like that were to
happen and we were getting hit all over
the country and we didn't have the
Personnel to respond with the
professional military we would need
things like the state militia we would
need things like sherff
posies could I just follow up follow how
do we I mean how would we be trained so
essentially it's a draft right we're
drafted into the state mil militia and
then how we're not
trained it's it's not strictly a draft
it's it's more of a callup and because
this is under the New Hampshire
Constitution the ability to withdraw
based on um con change objector status
would still apply um but how they would
be trained well that's a very good
question now it's identified that the
unorganized militia exists of all
able-bodied people in in the founders
time the revolutionary period we had
things like the Minuteman we had people
who kept themselves trained and ready in
case they needed to be called in the
service by their Community or by their
country today it's not exactly the same
but we certainly have things like Sig
sour Academy we have police officers who
are trained for such tasks we have
people with the skills necessary and
they continue to need to be able to
build those skills necessary that if
they are ever needed in such a
circumstance that the state can count on
them in the event of a call
up thank you for that other
questions uh thank you representative
beler I have a card here from Warren
Perry who is here he's not representing
esvac but when he sits down he can uh
explain to the clerk uh who he is
representing
thank you Mr Perry thank you Mr chair
for the record my name is Warren Perry
I'm the deputy Adent general for the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services I work
foror General Dave mtis I just wanted to
make I heard one part of the honorable
representative's testimony just wanted
to be clear that the National Guard in
State statue is defined as a militia so
if you go to 110b
1A uh it says the the statute reads the
militia shall be divided into three
classes namely the National Guard the
state guard and the unorganized militia
so the statute is very clear that it is
part of the militia New Hampshire
statute is very clear so I just want to
Mr could you could you repeat that
article just so I can make a note of it
it's 110 B1
110-b colon Das a composition of the
militia so other parts of the statute
just for if if you'll allow me to be
clear chapter uh 110 or RSA one I'm
sorry 111 defines and uh uh outlines the
role of the state guard which is one
another of the three parts and then the
unorganized militia is as defined by the
representative who preceded me the
able-bodied men over the able-bodied
residents it doesn't say men so thank
you so much for that clarification
that's very helpful um would you take
any questions if there are any I will
does anyone have any questions for uh
the
deputy seeing none uh thank you
sir okay with no more pink cards and
with no one else appearing interested in
speaking to this measure I
will end that hearing and we are right
on schedule unbelievably if you were
here this this morning um next up right
at
2:30 is
hr28 and I believe that represent Thomas
is here yes that is that is she welcome
the prime sponsor from miramac I
believe you want me to start proceed
sure okay thank you um I am
representative of Wendy Thomas and I
serve the town of marac Hillsboro uh
District 12 I've been a resident of the
town for 33 years we have six children
that were raised in
marac um I also have a degree in medical
biology and have worked as a clinical
microbiologist that information will
come in uh in later I am one of the
water Warriors who have been ringing or
uh ringing the past Bell since 20 2016
in
marac I'm introducing house resolution
28 which if you look has triartisan
support so there's going to be three
parts to my presentation and I know it's
been a long day and I'm sorry and I'll
try to work through it as quickly as I
can but there's a lot of information
here I'm going to talk about the
resolution I'm going to tell you why we
need the resolution and then I'm going
to bring you down to a micro level of
what it what it's like to live in in a
past contaminated
town so if you look at the house
resolution um in lines one and two we
talk about past chemicals when I there's
going to be two specific P past
chemicals that I'll talk to about later
I'll reference but when I talk about
past chemicals I'm actually talking
about a class of over
14,000 chemicals so uh it's not just an
individual thing
uh in my town There's a high incidence
of cancer medical monitoring costs and
water and environmental
damage the the the corporation that has
done this is called St gobain originally
they located in Bennington Vermont and
they they housed a Plastics facility
there contaminated did exactly what they
did in New Hampshire contaminated the
town contaminated the water contaminated
the
soil then they decided Vermont kicked
them out uh they decided to go to HK
Falls in New York state they this is
going to sound familiar they
contaminated the water they contaminated
the soil they contaminated the
air uh both
uh both of those let me see if I can
find it
uh both states have sued Sano
uh for damages and um I'll have to find
I'll have to find the the number but um
billions billions of dollars to each of
the states for
remediation so sanco Bain has announced
that they're going to leave marac uh
sometime in
2024 what does this mean for our town I
mean we have these forever chemicals and
the reason they're called Forever
chemicals is the the chemical bond is so
strong it's not broken in nature there
are it can be broken under high
temperature uh situations but once it
escapes into the wild you cannot get rid
of these
chemicals uh so there it's been causing
all kinds of problems in my town um
Senco ban is currently in discussion
with Dees about closing down the
Plant um however there are problems with
S
because they continually lie and I don't
say that lightly um I will give you some
some instances of their constant
lying um s Cain said that they did not
use uh full strength pooa 100% pooa
chemicals when um they approached Dees
in
2016 um they they had self-reported that
there was past in the tap water at at
the uh in the building uh when Dees
investigated this and they got uh
documentation from from uh Senco Bain
and Senco Bain sent over 990,000 pages
of documentation the documentation did
not list that they used 100% pooa
chemicals um prior to 2004 they just
they just uh Dees says they never got
the
information so they lied about that um
they
uh in in a in 200 in a 2016 letter to
State Regulators s Goan wrote that it
never used peoa as raw material at any
point in time in marac and in 2014 they
told the EPA that it is not and has
never been a user of pooa per anywhere
in the United States but the documents
that were released at the lawsuit um it
was a lawsuit in the state of New
Hampshire showed that s Cay knew it used
pooa many years
before a former State gobain Attorney
who is now a whistleblower testified
that sales records from 3M which sold
pooa to Senco Bain show that the company
brought hundreds if not thousands of
pounds of pure pooa the 3M sales records
are under seal in the class action suit
and a Salesman for Dupont which also
sold past products to St gobain last
year testified that he had learned they
were using pure pooa and adding it to
our products uh to their
products uh s Cain no longer denies that
it was using pure foa a pure peoa they
they were caught lying and they they now
admit that they used
it uh
uh in in a an a company executive stated
in 2006 that stco Bain quote ought to
downplay the potential health risks of
pooa relative to other PS chemicals and
argued that there are no proven health
risks but a 1995 Company menu memo
showed that management had issued a
decree to stop using poo because quote
of its to toxicity and long
halflife the company also in 2006
conducted blood tests for pooa on its
employees but the results remain under
seal and the plant's previous owner in
1980 investigated why its male employees
were experiencing impetus impotence and
polymer fever so these guys have been
uh being dishonest uh with the town of
marac for
years uh let me see
um okay so so why do we need a a house
resolution like this it's because uh
recently irch uh which is a division of
uh the World Health Organization H uh wh
has concluded that pooa is carcinogenic
it is a it a and uh P fos is is likely
carcinogenic I've talked to Dees I've
talked to our town manager I've talked
to other people um Dees believes that
perhaps uh Senco Bain is going to
declare bankruptcy this is what these
chemical companies do and move to
another location I've also heard that
they might Lo move to Ireland I've heard
that they may close this facility and
move somewhere else in New Hampshire
we're not not getting the information
from this closure and again this is not
about a McDonald's closing down in our
town this is about a a a corporation
that has been spewing carcinogenic
chemicals in our town for years and that
this is not the first time this is their
method of operating they did this in
Vermont Vermont kicked them out they did
this in hak Falls they are responsible
for billions of pay of dollars for
Remediation in those two places
um another reason we need this is that
there are no stakeholders at these
discussions between Dees and St goang
closing we don't have any elected
officials we don't have any Town
officials um we have not been invited to
the table we have no Advocates that have
been working on this problem for years
and lastly there's timing um what what
are we going to do if this company which
is headquartered in Paris us they're not
even an American company this is a
French company what are we going to do
if they leave the United States we have
all this remediation we discover things
down the line uh that more Health uh
effects how are we going to go after
them so this uh house
resolution it outlines the the history
of Senco Bain what what it has done how
it has been Bad actors for our town how
they have continually lied and the
resolution is to go to President
Biden um and President Biden because of
his moonshot cancer program um because
this is a cancer cluster in Southern New
Hampshire it will go to uh Senator
Shaheen Senator Hassen representative
kuster representative papis and I'm
asking for her a copy of this resolution
to go to the president of France this
company comes to the United States
destroys our environment creates cancer
quite frankly and they do it in the
United States because France has very
very strong Environmental Protection
laws and they would not be allowed to do
this in France so they come to the
United States to do
this
um
just quickly I'm going to drill down
into real life what this actually means
because we're talking a little bit in
hypotheticals it's very difficult to
understand what these chemicals are what
the effects are um we have a private
well my well um was tested in
2016 the levels were so high for past
chemicals just a constellation of them
we had to shut down our well in 2016
we've not been able to use our well
since then we have a whole house
filtration system um that cost about
$5,000 to install uh it costs about $500
a year to replace the
filters
um there are I live in an in a on a
street that AB buts an older
neighborhood so we have four houses on
my street that have private Wells four
the other houses are in public water in
house number one the dad has died of
kidney cancer in house number two the
dad and the adult son have died of colon
cancer in house number three the dad is
dying right now with stage four prostate
cancer these are all cancers that are
linked to pest exposure house number
four that's my house I was diagnosed
with breast cancer in
2022 it's interesting breast cancer
there's a lot of it around once you're
diagnosed with breast cancer they start
investigating any family history of
breast cancer nope I got four sisters my
mom no breast cancer they did the
genetic workup on me to see if there's
any mutations no mutations no genes that
are adding to uh that would compel my
body to have breast cancer uh I was
talking with the environmental working
group which was an advocacy group in
Washington DC and they suggested I get
my blood tested for past chemicals now
remember I'm one of these water Warriors
I've been working on this since 200 16
we put in a filtration system we went
you know I protected my kids as much as
I could we thought we were protecting
our family my blood results showed that
I have 12 past chemicals in my body that
are over the toxic limit that's allowed
for humans
12 I have my constellation of
p uh I have um my pooa chemicals I have
38 times what normal people and the
national average have in my in my blood
my posos I have more than
99% based now the P fos chemicals or the
pooa chemicals are related to breast
cancer and the physicians at darmouth
Hitchcock believe that there's such a
tie that they have said that my breast
cancer is environmentally triggered by
environmental
toxins um because the posos chemicals
were so high in my blood those attack
your ovaries and your fallopian tubes so
I had to go and have my ovaries and my
Fallopian tubes removed prophylactically
to try to keep ahead of the cancer
that's what it means to live in a town
that is contaminated with these
chemicals we have to amputate parts of
our bodies to stay ahead of the
cancers this is the price that we
pay my husband when he was 55 years old
um he had several heart attacks and he
ended up having a quadruple
bypass cardiac issues are linked to past
exposure um he's had two kidney
operations kidney issues are linked to P
exposure he has high cholesterol it has
nothing to do with what he eats this is
something that comes from from P um my
my six children we have autoimmune
disease young guys they're they're
they're adults in their late uh mid 20s
to early 30s cardiac issues reproductive
issues cholesterol immune
dysfunction and I've just last summer
put down my fourth dog to
cancer we live in a hot spot we have no
idea what we're going to do the costs
for healthc care there was an article
today that came out in Yahoo news 250 50
billion dollar is being spent in the
United States because of pasas related
health issues 250
billion
now I mean we're just a microcosm we're
a we're one little family in one little
neighborhood in our town I can tell you
that even with insurance when you have a
disease like cancer you spend a lot of
money it is very expensive to to try to
stay healthy when these corporations are
dumping these chemicals into our into
our
environment um one thing I wanted to
just point out there was a mistake on
page let me see where is it on page page
two line
13 it says that it um the stacks failed
and they did fail um and when they did
fail uh s Cobain had installed a a
secret bypass stack that Dees didn't
know about so when the stacks failed
they they subverted the the uh the fumes
into this
nonfiltered stack um which was which was
not allowed that's another lie that they
did they said that they um that they
that we knew about it but we didn't
anyway um when when the stacks were put
when they failed 17b of pest chemicals
went through these filters they're
called RTO filters and Senco Bain is
very proud that only two pounds of the P
chemicals were directly released into
our town one liquid drop of past in 20
Olympic pools is enough to make that
water carcinogenic and they are proud
that they only put forward 2 lbs of this
stuff into our town every night they
they burn the refu because you we don't
know how to get rid of peas um but
remember those those uh bonds are so
strong that many of them don't break and
so whenever they they burn the refu the
soot particulate comes down on our town
it covers our it covers our Lawns it
covers our cars it covers everything the
rain drives this down into the ground
and the produce uptakes it we have
P excuse me we have p in our apples we
have p in our tomatoes in fact Dees has
has advised the condo association that
is directly across the street from Sinco
Bain to not do any
gardening this is what it's like to live
in a town like this and so this house
resolution is it documents what ST Bain
has done to our town and I am simply
asking
for people to people in authority to
come to the table to look out and
protect the residents of my town and
it's not even my town it's it's Bedford
Lichfield Amherst Hollis NASA all of
Southern New Hampshire I just want to
make sure that we're getting the
information we need if uh president
Biden can do something with with his
cancer program that would be great if
the Senators and the representatives can
find any kind of funding that we we
could use for cleanup if they could pull
in the EPA we need help in our town and
we're not getting it right now and so
that's what this house resolution is
asking thank you and I'll take
questions thank you representative so
I'm looking at the last page and this
kind of goes to what you just touched on
about these things that need to be done
um for example the the P contaminated
products materials from the closing of
the St gobain site shall be dispos of
properly that's one of the res after all
the warehouses that's one of the
resolves
so do you want to say it just says that
they should be disposed of properly you
don't say by whom or when or
how um is
that
General it's a little bit generally
vague do you is you just want to leave
if this resolution goes forward then the
details will be worked out uh later
by by whomever yeah well see it's all
it's all relatively new I mean we're
finding new information every day we
don't know how to dispose of this stuff
we don't know whether to put it in you
know it all goes into a lined landfill
um even that's dangerous um so I think
that that's one of the things um I could
try to make it more specific but I think
that um it should be General because
that's one of the discussion points that
that that needs to be
addressed right so in trying to have a
resolution that will be more effective
or has some teeth for
example
um that the
uh closing of the St gobain site should
be disposed of
properly if to me if it's said uh by
whom you know who like uh by the by a
certain um entity whether it's St gobain
uh a federal program I don't know I'm
just trying to look at this and I for
example if it said that something will
happen by a certain date by a certain
entity then that's clear in people's
minds okay this is what the resolution
ca for this has to happen by this person
by this time uh and and you explained it
you know by being a little bit General
that in some ways that's easier so uh
I'm sure if this moves forward it will
definitely raise awareness uh raised our
awareness just now um so anyway my my
question is we and we have time we can
you can we can uh work on some of the
wording but that's that's my question do
you want it to be vague or or would it
be helpful if it was more specific um if
there's a little bit of time I can
certainly do some research but I'm not a
scientist um I I mean I have a medical
biology degree but um I I can I can put
some examples um and not dictate a a
course of action but I could certainly
find some examples of ways to dispose of
it I mean that's a that's a valid point
um I'm not sure it's up to me to decide
because I'm not sure I have the
knowledge on how how to dispose of
pest right or if you said uh who should
do it again I'm just this this is first
time we we've really drilled down to
look at the the the
wording um if it said s go ban should be
responsible then that makes it clear
again this is a resolution it's not a
statute
uh so we're going to start executing
some of these next week but I think this
is one that we we have we have time um
if if you want to uh it's up to you and
and and in the other co-sponsors or in
some of us on the committee if you
wanted
to uh think about perhaps some different
wording or more effective specific
wording towards the end uh those are
just some of my thoughts not really a
questioning other than would you want to
think about uh if if we if you had time
to work on the language
um to your point I would be happy to say
that s Cain is responsible for disposing
of everything and that includes um in um
uh equipment that's inside the facility
that is also dirty that that might be
helpful because in reading this uh you
know is the is the town of marac is the
county of Hillsboro is the state of New
Hampshire is it St gobain is it some
other entity that uh is needs to take
action here I that I don't know it's
what I'm trying to get a handle on I I
think though that the point you're
getting at and one of my one of my
advocacy points is that the residents of
New Hampshire should not be paying one
penny for
cleanup and that perhaps might be if if
we continue to work on the wording that
I think that would be helpful in moving
this resolution forward if if that what
you just said about
uh the residents from New Hampshire
should should not be uh held responsible
for Mal Fe that they did not commit
right be very happy to work on an
amendment um just for clarification for
this is my first house resolution is it
the committee that will do the amendment
or because it's a house resolution is
that my
responsibility well the the committee
owns these measures after they submitted
um but uh if if you want to uh pick
someone uh any of us uh if you want to
uh improve improve the language or
change the language um as chair I I
would say I we we can give give you time
for that you know this is only January
12 yeah so um I'm sure you're going to
get some more questions and input uh but
uh that was my question and thought was
uh the the wording and being more
specific and and I like what you just
said said about uh you know not holding
uh obviously it it appears that the
corporation is is
responsible and uh so okay so there's
that so that I'll leave that to you and
you can Circle back yes uh represent
massila sure thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking me
question so am I correct in saying that
you did this as a resolution as opposed
to a bill to get the attention of the
feds as opposed to getting direct action
from the state that's correct that is
correct I want I want Federal oversight
on this um and again because we're not
closing down a McDonald's we're closing
down a multi-billion doll company
multi-billion dollars in fact they they
had um the European Anti-Trust
commission finded s Cain 1.3 million oh
1.3 billion pounds so these are Big
players um and they also have a whole
slate of lawyers they have more lawyers
than God you know and so every time we
try to do anything we get pushed back
from the lawyers because they've got the
money they've got the the
resources you're welcome to follow up on
that uh again this is new as well but
the you just mentioned that you in resp
respon to repes representative Miller
that she wanted the feds to be aware of
this uh it doesn't really say that here
uh you you you want copies to go to the
president United States and the
Congressional Delegation uh again
perhaps if you specifically mention the
EPA uh that might make it a stronger
resolution um just to follow up on on
the previous question other questions I
saw hands representative
pman U thank you Mr
and thank you representative to Tak my
question what products do they make to
use these
chemicals facility um so uh prior to S
Cain it was a company called chemfab and
what they do is they make chemically
coated fabrics and this is through their
plastic divisions so
these we call them Plastics but they're
really like Teflon chemicals you know
the the stuff that's on your pans that
are non-stick and so they coat these
Fabrics with this Teflon Teflon plastic
and then those Fabrics are used for
radar shields you know those big domes
that are on Radars um some stadiums have
those foldable um roofs that that that's
that's uh chemfab they're also used in
biohazard suits because they're
impermeable that's the whole thing with
these chemicals um they don't breathe um
and they're used in astronaut suits as
well so there is is a need for these
chemicals and there's a need for these
products however I mean I I mentioned
earlier I used to work as a clinical bi
biologist I've worked with biohazardous
material and there there's a way to
handle this you don't just throw it into
our Rivers you don't just you know burn
it and let it go out into the air there
are ways to contain these these
chemicals a followup Mr uh followup and
then representative levit
afterwards how
the
ground some of it is being poured
directly but the majority of it remember
I said earlier they burn and when they
burn at night all of this soot which is
is unbroken pfast chemicals falls down
onto our town and the surrounding towns
which is why we're starting to see
contamination um and the rain drives it
down but the thing is I mean we're
advising people that if you have a an
outside dog if you have your dog out in
your yard you should wipe their paws off
before bringing them into the house you
should vacuum your carpets on a regular
basis I mean people should anyway but um
because you're tracking in pest all the
time you know we filter our water but
the water at Dunkin Donuts is not
filtered the water at the restaurant
that that cooks our pasta is not
filtered you know it's a huge
problem
cyber odds I mean I guess pretty huge
but um is there are they looking at
people from across the state that have
large amounts of pest in their systems
just like you like say you stop at the
Dunkin Donuts you know in marac on your
way to work but you live up north you
know farther up north
um the thing is you cannot assume that
you're you're not contaminated with
pasas until you test just like you
cannot assume your water is clean unless
you test P you can't see it you can't
smell it you can't taste it in your
water so um in my first term in 2018
2020 we passed a bill that um mandated
that insurance paid for past blood
testing so that's and that's available
to anyone in the in um in New Hampshire
okay thank you so you can and I can get
you the the code of the the test that
needs to be ordered because that that's
another thing too is a lot of the
Physicians um don't have experience and
don't have knowledge about how to treat
pest that's in fact I'll just tell you a
quick story my um the surgeon that did
my um
mastectomy um I after I had my blood
work done I came with the results
showing that I had these 12 chemicals
that were over the toxic limit and I
tried to give her the results of the
chemical and without even looking at
them she pushed them back and she said
I'm just a surgeon I don't I don't need
to know about p and I said well you're
no longer my surgeon
then representative Le thank you chair M
let be sure I admire you admire your
strength and courage in this I really do
um and and I sincerely mean that I mean
I could never fathom me having to worry
about wiping my dogs paws off or um you
know the drinking water 32 times I mean
this is something that needs
to be brought to attention as soon as
possible I mean this isn't you know this
is you're doing I'm going to make this
brief is you got the ball rolling on
this and this is something that I you
know as far as I'm concerned lastly is
that I'd be suing the hell out of them
I'm sorry apologize I'm I but the town
needs to get take an effective approach
on this and um I hope this goes forward
in a positive way because um the word's
out now yep and and that's the point of
this is to to raise awareness because a
lot of people have been hearing about
pest they've never seen the whole
picture it is devastating to our town
this situation is
devastating any other questions for the
prime sponsor of this
resolution okay again I would just say
uh if you want if you want to work on
the wording we we won't exec this for a
while uh we'll give us some time and uh
if you want to if you know any of us uh
that you uh looks like you know someone
that you can uh work with on and then
that person that rep Committee Member
can um bring forward the amended
language then we could uh go from there
I absolutely look forward to it thank
you very much okay I have two more cards
on this H HR hr28 um representative
Perez is here she has to speak briefly
in support of the bill in support of the
resolution it's not a bill it's a house
resolution welcome representative thank
you very much um thank you for the
opportunity to speak up and support
hr28 my name is Maria Perez I'm a state
representative from Dix 43 in Milford
the reason that I'm supporting and I'm
uh co-sponsoring this resolution is
because sovin has two buildings in
Milford we already have super siiz and
Mur that we for many
years has to deal with it uh our soil
has been contaminated with other um
chemicals we have to buy water from
panacha water in
NASA um and then we already have issues
buying water from Pena because we have
uh pipes that's so old that now we have
uh Brown drinking
water my issue with single vein being in
Milford is that I've been asking when
they saw the first building that it was
like no one knew it was like one day
single vein was there and the next day
the building was
sold I've been asking for
reports what chemicals they've been
putting in our Soil and Water and mil
for I Haven been getting any answer my
concern is now that I'm hearing that
they selling the second building they
just leing without none of us know
what's going on none of us know what's
in our soil from single and mare we
don't know what they're putting in our
water either so that's why I'm asking
for anyone in here because knowing what
maramman is going through in other towns
I don't want the residence of Milford
just be living with the same issue and
not having any
support uh that's why I'm asking
everyone in here to support this
resolution because we're going to need
your help we don't know what what is
going to affect mil right now like I say
I've been asking for reports I've been
asking for anything that they can tell
us what single V is throwing in our
water and soil and and Milford as
well thank you representative uh rep
will you take a question or
two okay then uh representative Gagney
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Perez for taking my
question uh you're from Milford has
anybody from Milford the town uh
officials have they asked for a sample
or gone to the property and actually
taking a sample of the soil there to see
what's in
it I've been asking the T Miler the
water department many times and some
residents sent me emails um as told them
me that they've been asking the water
department for reports and they haven't
heard anything back I've been waiting
for an email or call back back and I
haven't get it call back on email from
the water department as
well any other questions for the
representative seean thank you
representative Perez uh the final card
on hr28 is Katherine corkery from
conquered in the New Hampshire Sierra
Club oh
yes a rip some SEL uh it it said 21 but
you it you meant 28 and is is uh I have
kathern corker's name is Katherine
here uh
I okay uh please
representative sorry long day um for you
two um I'm representative Laurence
seelig I represent Durham New Hampshire
which is straford county 10 um last year
or two years ago I learned about pasas
at peas um which is in Portsmouth um
which was detected when a number of
children in one of their daycare centers
became unexpectedly ill and they had a
very high child pediatric cancer cluster
they discovered that the uh firefighting
foam that had been used at the Air Force
Base was full of these chemicals um and
all of these children were getting sick
so they then tested and discovered that
every well um within a specific radius
of P's was deeply infect infested with
the p and p foas and p other things
there's a reason I wasn't a science
major um and so um my understanding is
that the Air Force Base is having to do
most of the cleanup but they've
obviously had to do all kinds of things
to bring water into that area I also
know the town of Durham um a few years
ago was tasked with extending the town's
public water supply out to the Lee
Traffic Circle because that was another
area that was discovered to be um deeply
infested with very dangerous water it
was discovered someone was trying to
sell a property and when the water was
tested it came back so high for
chemicals that um the businesses in that
area which included Dunkin Donuts
Wendy's McDonald's and four other
restaurants all had to temporarily pause
to get water brought in to make it safe
so um I just I very strongly support
this resolution and I know that there's
been some work at peas already about how
to address some of issues and trying to
figure out
Solutions thank you
representative
and if no one has a pressing question
Katherine corkery from the Sierra Club
is here
hello thank you so much for taking my
testimony and um allowing me to share um
just some more information uh New
Hampshire Sierra Club supports the
spirit of this
resolution um
and appreciate the um the ENC that the
bill encourages or the resolution
encourages is uh the communication
between all of these entities
um I want to I have some handouts uh I
know this is a committee that doesn't
normally talk about water quality or uh
pollution and so I have some handouts
about uh this
contaminant um pasas and pooa the same
one um these chemicals are um inorganic
and they're uh human-made
manufactured and um they
are called Forever chemicals for reason
um I I I I will be brief but I did want
to um highlight um for your
um uh research um uh a few movies uh
that highlight uh these issues one is
dark Waters and it is about the first
class action lawsuit uh that was filed
against Dupont for these chemicals uh
dark Waters is the name of it and then
there's another one uh called the devil
we know and that documents uh these
chemicals and and it's you know uh it is
very um heavy uh there's some very
serious conditions that that you'll
learn about uh just as we have with
representative um Wendy Thomas um and
the this is a serious pollutant um this
is a chemical that has been brought to
our communities uh through various uh
manufacturing and uses um and I it it's
it's really devastating uh I I'll just
repeat that um so we do support the
spirit of the bill I have some handouts
and um I am certainly not as expertised
as our uh honor or as the representative
but uh I would be happy to take any
questions um oh wait I had a suggestion
uh about um language for the uh page
three um I think um in considering how
to dispose of these chemicals oversite
from the AG um is pretty important um as
well as the Department of Justice
because there are a number of uh class
action and legal matters involved with
this as well so you heard my ear earlier
comments to the prime sponsor about the
language that what prompted okay good
yeah so you can presumably work with
absolutely Aaron Brockovich is that a
name that's you've ever heard of sure
very similar um oh she's
here
uh any question for Katherine uh
representative
carry uh Katherine is this something
that uh maybe the federal brownfields
program might be engaged to do be
involved in the clean
it's it's definitely um there is a
division uh it's like the
chemicals
soils and some development I think it's
called in the EPA that uh CL deals with
um brownfields and also the superf fund
sites and um I I think it's called rra
they you know they have all sorts of
abbreviations
the whole alphabet um but uh that
division is is likely the one that you
want to talk to represent L thank you
chair M so this is going to take a
village you know as legislators you know
we can bring this to the Forefront in
our committee even bring it to the house
floor and we know if we have bipartisan
support probably will we're going to get
this done but my Stern advice is we need
to get the towns involved we need to get
the State involved other than the
legislative part we have you know two
other branches here that the executive
and judicial so I mean I understand and
again I admire your strength and courage
and in coming up here but this has come
to a point where you you know where
people are definitely dying because of
this I mean you know and we need a
question and thank you very much uh
chair
muffett would you believe any other
would you believes or questions for
Katherine thank you so much thank you uh
Katherine so thank you so much seeing no
further cards or signals or hands I
will uh call a termination to the
hearing on
hr28 that brings us to the last measure
of the day
CA I heard somebody chering it's been a
long day uh uh cacr 13 uh Constitutional
Amendment concurrent resolu ution 13
relating to slavery and involuntary
servitude and the prime sponsor is here
welcome representative Balden before uh
before you start um let me just share
quickly uh I spoke with representative
Balden on the phone last night and uh we
were asking about we were talking about
the timing and they said well this is
the last bill of the day round three and
there's nothing following this bill so
we have plenty of time on it and uh I
need to be careful about making those
statements because um I didn't want to
apply to representative Bolen that we uh
this is an interesting measure we we can
be here all night that's kind of what I
conveyed because nobody's coming in
after us problem is I've been advised uh
for example our our uh researcher
Christina and uh there's all kinds of
staff that needs to stay here at the
State House and the lob until we finish
so lesson for me to be next next week
our last bill will be at one instead of
three so uh everybody who's here looking
forward to thank you for coming in
whatever you want to say we're going to
hear you out but as we told the folks
this morning if someone has already made
a specific point that you want to make
if if you cannot repeat that so that we
can keep moving uh for the folks that
are waiting on us this Friday night so
all that said we're ready to go uh
representative B thanks so much looking
move forward to your
introduction thanks um for the record
I'm Amanda Balin a representative from
Hillsboro District
25 um and for what it's worth all the
folks who've showed up to testify and
support of this legislation today are
aware that three minutes or less is the
best way to hold a person's attention
unfortunately I have a little bit more
testimony than that so I'll be breaking
the rule but um so uh this bill uh would
would uh the cacr would enshrine the
abolition of slavery in the state
constitution pretty simple um I'm I'd be
interested to hear if there are any
questions uh later on
about the legislation and why it might
not be simple to some but I think it's
extraordinarily simple and I really like
legislation like that um a little
history of um slavery New Hampshire so
before the Civil War um you know around
the time of the American Revolution our
state was in the habit
of purchasing uh humans um and uh
forcing them to work in the military um
because they had trouble uh recruiting
people um for the to fight the American
Revolution and um in response to that
there were some folks in 1779 about 20
slaves who submitted a petition to this
same body
but we were meeting in exiter back then
um and they were asking for their
freedom and that petition has some
really poetic content for example um P
private or public tyranny and slavery
are alike detestable to Minds conscious
of the equal Dignity of human nature um
and then another part I really
appreciated said uh through ignorance
and brutish violence of their countrymen
and by the Sinister design of others
children incapable of self-defense whose
infancy might have prompted protection
were seized imprisoned and transported
from their native country where they are
compelled to drag on their lives in
miserable servitude thus often is the
parents cheek wet for the loss of a
child torn by the cruel hand of violence
from her aching bosom so is this really
poetic uh petition and we as a
legislature ignored it and never never
granted their freedom uh to those 20
slaves and it was only until 2014 that
Senator Martha Phil Clark put in uh a
legislation to grant them their freedom
obviously post
humously um so a few year four years
after that petition was put in in 1779
uh the con the state constitution was
drafted I went to the state archives for
my birthday uh last month and I actually
get to hold the Constitution and I
highly recommend that activity to anyone
Ashley Miller the state archist is
really nice and really excited to show
people
actual pieces of history that you can
hold in your bare hands um so that
Constitution uh read in part that all
men are born equal and independent with
natural rights among which are enjoying
and defending life and Liberty and I'm
sure in your first bill this morning you
heard a lot of terminology like
that um at the time in 1783 there was
some debate as to whether or not that
ban slavery but obviously in 1790 the
census counted over 150 slaves in the
state of New Hampshire so the
Constitution at that time did not ban
slavery in 1857 the state uh this
legislature passed a law that assessed a
penalty for enslaving another person it
was one to five years of hard
labor um this law is so old that I
couldn't even find the wording until I
found it in a in an article in a South
Carolina newspaper published in 1857
where they quoted the the law that was
passed by the New Hampshire legislature
and they essentially said if we can't
bring our slaves to new hampsh Hampshire
New Hampshire shouldn't visit South
Carolina so they were not having it um
and uh but other than that the the law
did not explicitly abolish slavery
didn't ban slavery it just assessed a
small penalty of one to five years of
hard labor the type of penalty we don't
even Implement
today um and uh so it didn't actually
guarantee freedom to all New Hampshire
citizens but a few years later Civil War
ended 13th Amendment um abolished
private ens slav
um you know Nationwide and that was that
and very few States followed up with
mirroring the 13th Amendment in their
own state constitutions but in recent
years there has been a nationwide
movement especially in light of the
state of national politics to embed a
reflection of the 13th Amendment in
individual state constitutions and I'd
say about half the country's done it so
far at this point and I think it's time
for n Hamshire to join in that effort
and in particular I think in light of
the first bill that you heard today
if if slavery is abolished in New
Hampshire because of the federal 13th
Amendment what happens if one day
something like this morning's first bill
passes it's hard to say
um and I think uh oh by the way so I
mentioned that um you know those 20
slaves were finally freed post humously
but I think even then um you know how
long did that take I'm not interested in
doing the math right now but overall I
could say that for 300 years New
Hampshire's kind of avoided addressing
the issue and it's worth noting that
like we were the last state to
acknowledge Martin Luther King Jr day
and um you know there's a lot to
appreciate about a citizen legislature
but sometimes I think when your populace
is just so distinctly of one type of
person it can be hard to sympathize with
the experiences of people in another
part of the country and to stand by them
um and so on a personal note I come from
slave owning people um this was kind of
a shock to me I I mean I kind of assumed
but I didn't know the extent of it my
11th great grandfather came from England
to Virginia in the 1600s in Jamestown
and uh his like great great great great
grandson my fifth great-grandfather was
a congressman us Congressman for
Virginia and he argued passionately in
favor of slavery it was the 1800s before
the Civil War um I've read transcript of
his speeches in Congress and he
literally said it's a man's natural
right to own another man um he was also
super irritated with women who would get
involved in politics at the time there
was some women who prepared a petition
and submitted it to Congress calling for
the end of slavery and um in his remarks
on the floor he said if they were
married they'd have something better to
do with their time um so I don't think
he would like me but you guys wouldn't
like him either because he was
definitely the kind of lawmaker that
when he started talking you'd leave for
a bathroom break very long-winded more
than me um he would go on and on so I'm
confident that my fifth great
grandfather Thomas Tyler Balin would be
very disappointed to know that just a
few years after he died
um the the US ban slavery um private
enslavement with the 13th Amendment and
I think especially he'd be disappointed
because between him and his brother
James they owned over 40 slaves at the
time um and you know at the time slavery
was framed as a states rights issue the
Democrats were the party of states
rights they wanted to leave it up to
individual states and um and as a result
with the passage of the 13th Amendment
it was assumed that this was applicable
in all states um but again going back to
if something like the first bill that
you heard today were to actually pass at
any point in the future where would we
be
[Music]
um so it is my hope today that uh we can
reject everything my ancestors stood for
and pass full abolition at the state
level enshrine it in the Constitution um
and more specifically allow our voters
to band together to enshrine this basic
freedom in the State Constitution and
hopefully make Thomas Tyler Balin roll
over in his
grave and a note about his grave um my
ancestor Thomas Tyler Bolton is the only
Congressman uh the only person to die in
the Congressional Chambers um I'm not as
nervous right now as I might be at the
well or in front of a senate committee
but apparently Thomas Tyler Balin was
standing at the well speaking when he
literally dropped dead mids sentence
which means his last words are recorded
uh they're just not coherent and um he
was I guess everyone felt so sorry for
him that even the president at the time
turned out for his funeral um Andrew
Jackson so somewhere in someone's pocket
is a likeness of a guy who attended my
fifth great grandfather's
funeral um
you know and when he died there were
many things that I experienced today
that were inconceivable for him um the
idea that I would be able to own
property or get divorced or Vote or
serve in public office um were
inconceivable to my fifth grade
grandfather um so I hope that you will
join with me in deeply upsetting his
memory um and making him roll over in
his DC grave and in closing I just want
to read one more portion of that 1779
petition um this was their closing
statement Therefore your humble slaves
most devoutly pray for the sake of
injured Liberty for the sake of Justice
humanity and the rights of mankind for
the honor of religion and by all that is
dear that your honors would enact such
laws and regulations as you and your
wisdom think proper whereby we may
regain our Liberty and be ranked in the
class of free agents and that the name
of slave may not more be heard in a land
gloriously contending for the sweets of
freedom because you know at the time it
was 1779 so these are folks that wanted
to be included in the Freedom Movement
in our country and um just be really
great if we could stand by them today in
2024 I'll take
questions thank you we of great history
love the history you shared um questions
for the prime
sponsor
uh representative
Massa thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question my
question is presently is slavery and
involuntary servitude defined in the New
Hampshire Constitution at all um it's
not referenced any there's nothing in
our state constitution touching
enslavement and more specifically there
aren't I'm not aware of any definitions
in general in the just speaking to the
issue of definitions say I'm not aware
of the use of definitions in the state
constitution um do you think it would be
necessary to Define them to make it more
clear no no I think that you know for
example your right to sit in that chair
and be a lawmaker it's not in the
Constitution a lot of that comes out of
case law um just the fact that you and I
as women can vote um that's not in the
state constitution those are things that
you know people scrape together fighting
tooth and nail over centuries um arguing
in in court um petitions lawsuits um to
be able to obtain and I think there is
to some extent some things that are now
inferred because of certain changes to
the wording of the Constitution but um
there isn't anything touching slavery
and I think that the way that this is
worded is perfect it's okay yeah I think
it it really wraps it up in a pretty bow
it's short sweet and it's something that
kids can learn about in school thank you
other
questions thank you so much uh Madame
Prime sponsor of Balden uh we have a
number of pink cards here uh to your
earlier comment uh your supporters and
it looks like everyone here is
supporting the the
measure um everyone has asked for either
two or three minutes except for one
person um who asked for four minutes um
and that we'll start with with her I
think uh ofilia from meramac um or marac
Street uh ofilia yes
for
thank you so unfortunately of course
I've been working really hard on this
and I'm not going to be able to speak so
my partner is going to be speaking for
me
today good afternoon and for the record
for our our clerk Madame clerk your
partner your uh your name is Dennis I'm
on the C Dennis
feeo
just a second
Dennis you have a second
card oh here okay Dennis there you go
right uh uh you're on thanks Dennis
thank
you do we agree that slavery needs to be
abolished slavery was supposed to have
ended with at the end of the Civil War
and the creation of the 13th Amendment a
promise that this great nation will no
longer put someone in Chains and hold
them in captivity the promise came with
an ex ception but not just at the
federal level many of our New Hampshire
citizens are not aware that slavery and
inv voluntary servitude still exists in
our state but ironically it's true the
13th Amendment clearly states neither
slavery nor involuntary servitude except
for the punishment of crime shall be
tolerated in this
state it's this particular loophole that
New Hampshire just like many states have
never drafted the bill to
abolish nobody should be subjected to
slavery because of being convicted of a
crime as as individuals with VAR life
experiences we don't agree on many
things but what I believe in my heart is
that my fellow New Hampshire don't want
to continue to be a slave state maybe
you're thinking it's just words and a
really old document and not actually a
practice we uphold on an everyday basis
I mean we're in the north we fought on
the union Civ on the union side of the
Civil War we have a diverse populations
we don't have slaves it is astonishing
that in the 21st century we still find
ourselves discussing the need to
eradicate this V institution from from
our midst but the truth is that the
fight against slavery is a battle that
we must continue to wage until every
last trace of this Injustice is
eradicated from our great state there
are 2,442 people currently incarcerated
in New Hampshire being served spoiled
food sometimes filled with maggots
individuals behind walls are paying 378
for a 3o stick of deodorant 525 for
toothpaste while working and being paid
1 to 150 an hour a financial incen to
incarcerate for-profit prison propers
like GTO phone providers key Fe by
Parker company earn Millions off of
exploiting prison of forced labor I know
this because I was enslaved in the state
of New Hampshire a mission in life is to
help restore human rights to all human
beings because of the atrocities I
witnessed firsthand and suffered while
incarcerated incarceration is marketed
as a mechanism to rehabilitate someone
so that they can be a productive citizen
many times prison staff will retire
retaliate against inmates for filing
complaints if you see something you're
supposed to say something except in
prison standing up for yourself for
others can mean forced labor or the risk
of losing a few hours of fresh air you
may be allowed solitary confinement in a
5x8 cell for months or years how is this
Rehabilitation instead of the culture of
prison only creates or exacerbates many
of the reasons people end up here so
many human beings go into the system go
into the system suffering from some form
of mental illness it could be from drug
abuse childhood trauma physical
emotional sexual abuse or effects of
abject poverty or a combination of all
the above as surveyed you will find a
majority of incarcerated people have
been severely abused or witness horrific
violence from a young age once they're
released from prison it could be
extremely difficult to acclimate
themselves into the outside world it can
be compared to being dropped off in
another country where you don't know the
language the land or the Customs but
you're expected to figure it out with
little no help for many is too
frightening and they end up back in hell
where they they wanted to escape it's
called recidivism but it's also being
coined as post- incarcerated syndrome
The Narrative is that someone is merely
a repeat or offend or a career Criminal
by what they may actually be is
impoverished abused child turned
offender turned abused by the state
enslaved adult everyone needs to be held
accountable for their wrongdoings this
also includes the state that we the
people are attempting to do not just
here but in any other states with the
across but in eight other states across
the country is advocate for empathy and
a radical change on how we re
rehabilitate and help our fellow human
beings become productive citizens who
can be held accountable for their
actions without being exploited abused
or killed this cycle will not end until
there's nothing to gain financially from
a person's life being destroyed we the
people will not rest until any and all
Financial incentives to incarcerate a
discontinued and erased from American
economics we will begin our work with
that the president created we will begin
our work with the president that created
this monster in the first place the
Constitutional exception Clause of
criminality so let us not forget the
Legacy that we leave for our future
Generations one that either perpetuates
the hearts of the past or paves a way
for brighter more inclusive future
there's no such thing as a tough or soft
D crime politician we are either pro
slavery and choose not to accept the
bill abolishing slavery and voluntary
servitude in its entirety leaving the
Constitution and the practices has been
tolerating in place but we are
anti-slavery and we fix our community by
accepting the bill to abolish
recognizing humanity and each of us I
respectfully ask that you accept the
bill to go on record and abolish slavery
in its entirety we can't reform a prison
systems who whose roots are slavery and
involuntary servitude thank you and I
want to make a correction that on the
first page I said a dollar to a150 an
hour and it's a dollar 50 a
day I don't know if anybody has any
questions
but okay thank you for that are
questions for for Dennis or
ailia I have just one thought and I am
trying to anticipate down the road um to
Executive session or when this measure
comes to the house
floor um
that I'm guessing I'm anticipating there
may or may not be some folks who when
they think of involuntary servitude in
in in incarceration or in a Prison
Correctional
setting um having been in this business
while you try to anticipate questions
that would come up so I I'm thinking
someone may ask if this measure moves
forward is that going to restrict people
from um or or require correction
facilities to change their policies or
whatever um I I don't know but uh maybe
uh the prime spart still here maybe
before we go to exec session in a week
or a couple weeks or whatever um that is
that issue of of correctional facilities
and inv voluntary servitude and and how
there's nobody here in opposition to the
bill and I'm just wondering if we we you
will we get some blowback from
Correctional people saying if this
passes then we can't uh do what we need
to do so that's that's I'm just throwing
that out there for uh for your
consideration so qu uh or could you
speak to that Dennis I would say why
would we need that in order to enforce
the construct of Labor why is slavery
necessary in order for corrections to do
business right it's also to an
understanding it is also human rights
violation right section four of the
Declaration of Human Rights says slavery
is abolishing all of its forms the
exception clause in the US Constitution
and from many of the states that hold it
by the exception is a form of slavery so
we are in contrast to international law
right and this is a Humanity issue right
if we have to keep arguing that slavery
is necessary we are still stuck in the
1800s right when we look at the
Abolitionist fight back in the day and
I'm going to say the abolitionist
movement is more American than anything
in this in our history right this is why
we sit where we're at today right they
talked about the gradual process New
Hampshire was very involved with that
process Vermont was as well main right
the Northeast was very involved with the
gradual abolition process it was
supposed to
end right but we didn't we haven't
visited this conversation in 140 years
right now we've gone state by state and
I'm here representing the abolish
slavery national network I'm from New
Jersey but I'm leading the campaign in
New Jersey we got New York Texas Florida
Ohio for the states that have abolished
slavery Tennessee Alabama Oregon Vermont
um Colorado Nebraska Utah and state byst
state we've been correcting the errors
of the past and finally closing this
chapter in American history so that we
can say that we finally live in a
country where slavery is
over questions further questions uh
representative Le
thank you chair M how many states have
taken up this legislation so far that
have passed as constitutional
referendums have been six and one of
them the seventh was Alabama um through
their overall constitutional referendum
process agreed to remove the exception
Clause from their constitution so eight
states we have Nevada on the ballot this
November and hopefully New Hampshire
this November and the
B thank you other
questions seeing none uh thank you for
that testimony and it's also helpful to
have the handouts thank you for those as
well okay
uh all the other cards they have have
asked for two or three minutes except
for uh represent wheeler is asked for
minimal time I'm not sure what minimal
time is but let's go to representative
uh representative
wheeler well chairman Moffett you know
I'm a politician as we all are and a
talker so I asked for minimal time
instead of an exact number because I'll
try to be as brief as I can but I did
just want to come before you today and
express my support uh for this
legislation my name is Jonah wheeler and
I represent the towns of petero and
Sharon which is Hillsboro District 33 um
cacr 13 which is coincidentally uh cacr
13 in uh conjunction with 13th Amendment
I find that uh kind of interesting but
this is a very simple legislation which
is at its core a clerical fix to our
constitution but I would also echoing
the remarks made by representative
Balden about the history of this in New
Hampshire like to mention that this is
still a modern issue in our world and
while this legislation doesn't have any
enforcement in it and doesn't it won't
uh uh uh leave us to to a place where we
solve that issue there are still 1.1
million people in the United States who
are are in slaved or in some form of
involuntary servitude whether that be
forced Labor uh sexual exploitation of
adults or sexual exploitation of
children uh 1.1 million people in the
United States right now and in 1860
there were uh three and a half million
people uh enslaved so we're still in a
really um shameful moment here I think
in in this country and in the way that
we've dealt with this and and there are
global
rating indexs that have uh rated the
United States on this issue and and
unfortunately we don't rate as high as a
nation with the resources that we have
should um so I think this is a good
piece of legislation that as uh Dennis
said before me uh eight other states
have taken up and many other states are
taking up um and and and really this is
at its core a reaffirmation of the
principled work of the people who fought
for our Union the United States of
America in the 1860s in the Civil War
you hearkening back to the secession
bill I wasn't able to testify on that
but I am not in favor of that
legislation but I I I believe in the
United States of America we have a a
troubled past uh a troubled history
there and troubled people right now our
people are feeling uh that troubled
nature but this country more than any
other can represent uh free freedom for
all people life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness for all people and and cacr
13 for me represents a an affirmation
for that principle uh that the state of
New Hampshire can be making uh making
sure that we don't support uh slavery or
involuntary servitude in our state uh
just to hearken back to the question
that you just asked chairman Moffet
which I think was a a good question and
I I was going to I I know Doc is very
diligent about these bills so if they
had any opposition to that I'm sure they
were here and as soon as I was thinking
that my friend from Doc uh Miss Graham
came up and and spoke in my shoulder and
said that uh it does not affect the
Department of Corrections and and I'm
sure she'd be able to to answer that
question if you talk to her afterwards
um so I think that was as minimal as I
can make it chairman Moffett this is New
Hampshire and I you guys I appreciate
you staying here for for as long as you
H you have today this is a one of the
long days for you guys and you're
putting a lot of work into these bills
but I think this is a bipartisan piece
of legislation that we can move forward
on the consent calendar to make sure
that New Hampshire affirms that slavery
and involuntary servitude should not be
going on in our world where 40 million
people worldwide are enslaved in 1.1
million people here in the United States
are as well so thank you chairman
Moffett and the committee for your time
and I appreciate your consideration for
cicr 13 thank you for excellent minimal
uh uh comment uh comments repent of I I
do want to uh comment myself a little
bit on a couple things that you said um
you mentioned uh words the effect early
on I made a note of it that this measure
by itself won't necessarily solve
anything but this is I I have to point
out this is not a HR this is not a house
resolution and I don't think it can go
on consent uh because it is a cacr good
point that's a freshman mistake of mine
Mr I appreciate so uh as this is a cacr
uh it's very weighty and it would change
the law it would change the Constitution
if it if it's added so I just wanted to
kind of uh make that point that and
emphasize this is a
cacr um and which I don't think can go
on consent I think it would have to be
in fact it requires like a 60% vote I
have to check my my Civics um so I just
wanted to make that point uh questions
for uh representative wheeler
well just to your point Mr chairman
you're absolutely right about that and I
apologize for my
parliamentary you know flub on that I I
you're absolutely right this would
require two-thirds vote but this is what
I meant is this is something that I
think that one of those votes on the
floor where we'll cheer afterwards
because there will be no one who votes
against it or almost no one who does so
I that's what I mean roll call yes
exactly thank you Mr chairman thank you
okay moving right along um that was
represent wheeler asking for two minutes
was Joseph Las lasque lcar Joseph is
Joseph here someone's going to get
Joseph you must be Joseph I'm on a work
at the same time I apologize and if you
could just spell your name uh for last
name we got jph yeah Joseph l c a z e
lkas c e a z e l c a z e it's French
it's well I'm haian so M funny that
we're having
thisday my last name uh welcome thank
you um so my name is Joseph laskas uh
I'm going to be representing the
American civil liberties Union in full
support of cacr their te uh I I there's
been very extensive and thorough
testimony that's already been given so
I'm not going to go back over that one
of the things that I really do think uh
needs to be noted is that again we are
in 2024 now and so uh I do think that
this is a common sense legislation and
it's a statement um to the community
members that we that not only does the
legislature support their concerns but
we are making this state inclusive for
everyone um as far as the involuntary
servitude portion was going we heard
testimony again about some of the ways
that it's employed and I do believe that
that is something that should be looked
at when we do see County facilities like
Valley Street that will specifically um
employ practices that were spoken about
earlier uh to have individuals partake
in things that they necessarily did not
want to or may not even be safe for them
too but they they're doing so out of
fear of Retribution for what could occur
if they if they were to not do that uh
so I again I wanted to just reinforce
that the community of New Hampshire does
support this bill and I'm happy to take
any questions that you
have thank you Joseph and again you're
with with the ACLU did I hear that
correctly that correct American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire okay qu
questions for
Joseph seeing none uh Sometimes Late on
on Friday afternoon there's not as many
questions as there are earlier in the
day uh thank you so much um Grace from
the
afsl
and and is it the American friends
yeah okay and if you could spell your
last name for our clerk just so we make
because we want everything to be correct
here in veterans
committee thank you Grace well
welcome here we go is it on all right oh
I'm glad that you were able to hear me
without it but this is much better so I
want to First say thank you to the
chairman and thank you to the committee
for being here on this long afternoon
taking all of our testimony so like I
said I'm Grace kand I'm the program
coordinator with the American friends
service committee but today I'm speaking
on behalf of black lives matter New
Hampshire and so in their
testimony to whom to the committee black
lives matter New Hampshire expresses our
strong support for the abolished slavery
Amendment currently under
consideration the amendment represents a
vital step towards rectifying historical
Injustice in ensuring that our state
continues to be a beacon and a leader of
justice and equality the institution of
slavery left an enduring impact on our
nation's history and it is crucial that
we actively work to act to eliminate any
remnants of this abor practice the
abolished slavery amendment in New
Hampshire is an opportunity for our
state to take a bold stance and to be a
bold leader against modern-day forms of
servitude and
exploitation by passing the amendment
New Hampshire will not only be upholding
the principles our principles that we
fought so hard for of freedom and of
justice but also to send a powerful
message that we stand firmly against any
form of human exploitation within our
borders the deliss legislation is not
simply about addressing historical
wrongs but it is also about actively
working towards a more just and
Equitable future we understand that this
amendment is part of a larger Broad
movement to eradicate slavery in all its
forms by taking a decis and by taking a
decisive Step at the state level we will
contribute to the National and the
global effort to create a world free
from the shackles of forced labor in
human trafficking we urge you members of
the committee to support sorry my
apologies we urge you members of the of
the committee to lend your support to
the abolished slavery Amendment and
encourage your colleagues to do the same
by doing so you will be instrumental in
shaping a future for New Hampshire that
is rooted in Justice in compassion and
respect for human rights thank you for
your attention to this important matter
black lives matter New Hampshire trust
that you will consider the profound
impact that this amendment will have on
the lives of many both here and across
our great nation and we look forward to
seeing New Hampshire take a leading role
in the fight against modern day slavery
and so I want to thank you the committee
for taking my testimony and taking this
testimony on behalf of BLM New Hampshire
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
or take any
comments very well presented uh com uh
questions or would you
believes Cena thank you so much for
coming in it was very well presented
thank you so
much Terry
Robinson
good after welcome Terry thank you good
afternoon
everyone uh before I begin I'd just like
to say thank you to everyone on the
committee as the son of a veteran I know
all the important work that you guys do
here um I just want to say that I am
here on behalf of the black Heritage
Trail of New Hampshire an organization
based in Portsmith New
Hampshire dear chairman Moffett and The
Honorable members of the state federal
relations and Veterans Affairs committee
we are writing this letter in support of
cacr 13 2024 an amendment to the New
Hampshire Constitution prohibiting
slavery and involuntary servitude in the
state of New Hampshire as an
organization devoted to disseminating
and sharing information about New
Hampshire's black history we often are
in a position of having to tell our
visitors and program participants that
slavery has never been formally
abolished by the state of New Hampshire
enslavement is only prohibited here
because of the 13th Amendment to the
United States Constitution ratified in
1865 the right to be free of the threat
of enslavement or involuntary servitude
is a cherished and essential right that
should be guaranteed by the New
Hampshire Constitution the horrors of
enslavement in our past alone should be
sufficient to compel the passage of this
measure what makes its passage essential
at this time is that enslavement and
involuntary servitude persist even today
if enshrined in our constitution it
would be possible for anyone aware of
violations of this amendment to bring
legal action against these practices in
addition in our role as teachers of true
and holistic history we at the black
Heritage Trail would be with the passage
of this amendment able to inform our
audiences that New Hampshire has taken a
stand and its people are now protected
from the evils of this despicable
practices sincerely Jerry amb bogus
executive director and on a personal
note I just want to say to the
committee as a young individual who has
moved here about five six years ago
now I was confronted with history that I
have never heard before I grew up in the
South so a lot of the education that I
learned was framed in the eyes of
Republican and conservative thought I
was taught that the Civil War was about
states rights and not about slavery I
was taught that these states were the
heroes in the story and not the
villains it wasn't until I came here to
New Hampshire and I was confronted with
the fact that an enslaved man Prince
Whipple wrote a petion for
Freedom so early in the founding of our
country that it was impossible to ignore
it absolutely reframed my mind on the
history of our
country I implore you with the passage
of this amendment to our constitution it
sends a signal not just to everyone in
the state but to the rest of the country
and the world that we are doing what we
can to get rid of the practices and the
horrors of our past and move forward so
that future Generations can never live
under threat again thank you for your
time and I'm open to any
questions are there any
questions wonderful presentation very
well P thank you for taking the
time
I think we're at our last card um if I
can uh something
Glenn jezelle
Glenn and and Madam CL can you read that
for the
record is
it is it g i s e l i z
okay the the red ink on the pink cards
at my age sometimes is hard to read but
we've we've got it and welcome thank
you yes it's grelli and um I'm just here
today I wanted before I read my part of
the testimony I just wanted to um recite
what we have enshrined in the New
Hampshire State Constitution Article 10
where it says government being
instituted for the common benefit
protection and security of the whole
community and not for the private
interest or the ellent of any one man
man family or class of men therefore
whenever the ends whenever the ends of
government are perverted and public
Liberty manifestly endangered and all
other means of redress are ineffectual
the people may and of of the right ought
to reform the old or establish a new
government the doctrine of
non-resistance against arbitrary power
and oppression is absurd slavish and
destructive of the good and happiness of
mankind and so I I was here I'm here to
say to say um how dare we people of new
Hampshire knowing our state model Live
Free or Die have not drawn a clear line
to demonstrate which side of slavery we
stand on we have not made it clear that
we will not support condone or accept
slavery of any kind slavery and
involuntary servitude are said to have
been abolished in 1865 or was it it
wasn't if we have an exception clause in
the 13th Amendment the exception was a
way to to continue enslaving blacks
without making it appear that's what
they were doing those practices have
been embedded into the very core of our
society a way to justify slavery and
involuntary servitude we the people have
allowed this to go on far too long I'm
taking a stance and stating that the
reason we are here today should be clear
you are either pro-slavery or
anti-slavery there is not an in between
there is not a discussion or a
conversation that needs to be had how
can we proudly say we are the Live Free
or Die State all the while making an
exception to slavery the answer is we
can't there are no exceptions
period thank you and I will take
questions if there
any thank you for that passionate com uh
uh testimony uh questions from the
committee uh representative Manion yeah
I really appreciate the article 10
reading I think that's fantastic and and
I the way that I like this the thing the
Simplicity of this is exactly as you
described it's you either are or against
it's it's simple so thank you very
much anything else
seeing nothing else thank you for
staying here this late and for your
testimony and thank you for everyone who
who uh came in always appre appreciate
anyone who takes the time to to come in
and uh take a stand and do some
testimony so with that uh I see a handup
uh Prime
sponsor
yes not even gonna sit down just wanted
to say that on the issue of um the
impact on the incarceration on the
impact the uh incarceration system it's
possible that that would just need to be
litigated and that's probably the best
way to address it um it's through the
court system but other than that you
know just be great if we um abolish
slavery in New Hampshire thank you
Madame Prime sponsor with
that we will close at